COMMITTEE ON HOUSING, WILL COME
TO ORDER- WE DO NOT CURRENTLY
WE'RE JUST SHORT OF A QUORUM BUT
WE WILL START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
AND THEN ESTABLISH A QUORUM ONE
ANOTHER MEMBER ARRIVES A GOOD
MORNING IN RESPONSE THE COVER
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND PROTECT
THE PUBLIC. LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND HERE
TO SOCIAL DISTANCING OUR
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES TO ENSURE. THE PUBLIC
INTO TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE AND THE- STREET BUILDING- I
ASK ALL MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE-
TO BE PRESENT IN TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED TO SALVAGE A QUORUM AND
LOOKS LIKE WE NOW HAVE A QUORUM
THANK YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE- WE
HAVE A MINUTE MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT
POSSIBLE I WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE. IF YOU
WISH TO PROVIDE COMMENT BY
PHONE- THE PARTICIPANT NUMBER
TODAY IS 877-226-8163 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN THREE SIX
TWO EIGHT THREE THREE YOU CAN
ALSO GO TO OUR WEBSITE-
INFORMATION OR PROVIDE FEEDBACK-
WHEN WE MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT ON
BILLS. YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT OPPOSITION JUST
PRESS IT ONE TIME ONLY AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER- AND
THEN BELT LINE NUMBER WILL BE
RECOGNIZED- AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. BOB PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK
PLEASE MUTE THE DEVICE THAT
YOU'RE USING TO WATCH THE
HEARING BEFORE YOU GIVE
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE
OTHERWISE. IT WILL BE HARD FOR
US TO HEAR YOU- OBVIAMENTE.
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING. AND
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS THIS FOR.
MAY BE RE- FROM THE HEARING OR
FROM THE REMOTE SERVICE. WE HAVE
A BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA I DO
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE WILL BE
TAKING UP ONE BY BILL OUT OF
ORDER FILE ITEM NINE. SB A
NINETY SEVEN SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
SKI- WILL BE MOVED- TO BE THE
FIRST BILL WE ARE HEARING
EVERYTHING ELSE WILL REMAIN IN
ORDER- BEFORE WE- START HEARING
BILLS LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
OF CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR WIENER PRESIDENT
WIENER PRESENT BATES. BATES
PRESENT OR DOES. CORTEZ THE
PRESENT HOW TO YOUR- MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE HERE BUT CHAU BOTH HERE
THE TROUBLE HERE SKINNER. I'M
BURKE. WHAT KASKY. OKAY WE HAVE
A QUORUM THANK YOUR COLLEAGUES-
OKAY WILL NOT HEAR FROM OUR
FIRST AUTHOR- WALKING CENTER
LIKE HEALTHY- WILL BE PRESENTING
WHAT IS LISTED ON THE AGENDA IS
FILE ITEM NINE- SP NINETY SEVEN
CENTER YOU MAY PROCEED SURE
WINNER LETME FIRST START OFF BY
THANKING YOU IN THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT FOR THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE TO THE CHAGRIN OF
MANY INTO THE JOY OF OTHERS S.
B. EIGHT NINE SEVEN WILL BE MY
LAST EIGHTY YOUR BILL HERE IN
THE STATE LEGISLATURE- AS FOR
EVERYBODY'S. CONCERNED AS THIS
IF I'M LUCKY ENOUGH TO HAVE
MIGHT BUILD MOVE OUT OF YOUR
COMMITTEE MISTER CHAIR HI WILL
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
MEMBERS CENTER HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS THE
MAJORITY LEADER AND THE CHAIR OF
GOVERNANCE FINANCE IN KEEPING
YOU MISTER CHAIR AS WELL AS THE
OTHER PLAYERS INFORMED OF THE
ONGOING DISCUSSIONS AND ANY
POTENTIAL AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
MADE TO THE- TO THE BILL. EIGHT
NINE SEVEN ON THE PREVIOUS-
EIGHTY LEGISLATION THAT I'VE
WORKED ON AND OTHERS OF THE LOT
PAST SIX YEARS. BY ADDRESSING
SOME OF THE UNNECESSARY
OBSTACLES AND BARRIERS THAT WE
HAVE IN FOR EIGHTY NEW
CONSTRUCTION. MUCH OF THE BILL
INVOLVES FEEDBACK THAT MY OFFICE
HAS RECEIVED ALONG WITH THE
HOUSING COMMUNITY DEVELOP
OFFICES WE'VE HEARD THE STORIES
OF THE PEOPLE THERE TRY EITHER
IN THE- FIELD TRYING TO BUILD.
EDUS AND HOMEOWNERS AND-
EXPLAIN. THAT THEY THAT THEY
STILL FACE WHICH WE BELIEVE IS A
SUPPRESSION OF EIGHTY YOU
CONSTRUCTION AND MEETING OUR
GOALS OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
THE STATE. EIGHTY USE ALLOW
HOMEOWNERS TO MAKE BETTER USE OF
THE PROPERTY AT THE END OF THE
DAY. THEY PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
GENERALLY MORE AFFORDABLE RENTAL
AVAILABILITY IN THE COMMUNITIES
INCOME PROVIDE WEALTH BUILDING
FOR COMMUNITIES AND THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT WHEN I FIRST
STARTED OFF I DIDN'T REALLY
APPRECIATE HOW MUCH. HOW THE
WEALTH BUILDING CAN WORK ON. A
LOT OF THOSE WHO THAT
OPPORTUNITY JUST HAVE NOT OR
JUST DO NOT EXIST IN THE
COMMUNITY THEY PROVIDE THE
HOUSING OPTION THE FLEXIBILITY.
OF I'M LIVING IN THE EIGHTY YOU
I'M LIVING IN THE HOUSE I WANT
TO MOVE OUT I WANNA MOVE IN. IT
I WANT RENTAL I WANT MY COUSIN
TO COME LIVE WITH US AND AS
PEOPLE AGE IN THEIR COMMUNITY
SOME OF A ONE I HAVE THAT
FLEXIBILITY FOR LIVING SPACE FOR
THEIR FAMILY. THEIR FRIENDS. AND
PERHAPS ARE CARED- GIVERS SO
EIGHTY YOU. S. B. EIGHT NINE
SEVEN FIRST ELIMINATES THE OWNER
OCCUPANCY REQUIREMENTS AN EIGHTY
YOU AND J. EIGHTY YEARS THIS WAS
ONE OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
BARRIERS. TO THE FINANCING AND
CONSTRUCTION WHAT IF THIS IS THE
BANK'S HATED WHAT WILL HAPPEN IS
THAT IF YOU HAVE A RESTRICTION
ON HOMEOWNERSHIP. AND YOU MOVE
OUT OR YOU DIE THE BANCHAN
CALLING YOUR LOAN YOUR STATE
DOESN'T. WANT THAT THEY DON'T
WANT TO LAND WITH THESE
RESTRICTIONS IT WAS A-
COMPROMISE FIVE YEARS AGO FOUR
YEARS AGO. SO WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE OUT THE FIVE YEAR SUNSET.
IT ADDRESSES THIS IDEA OF
UNPERMITTED EIGHTY YEARS THE
BILL PROHIBITS A LOCAL AGENCY
FROM DENYING A PERMIT FOR AN UN
PERMITTED EIGHTY YOU UNLESS
THERE IS A HEALTH AND SAFETY
VIOLATIONS. WE HAVE LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL THAT WAS THAT THAT HAS
BEEN THE LAW WE HAVE SAID THAT
WE UNDERSTAND IF YOU BILL THE
NAVY YOU. MY NEIGHBORS PROBABLY
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE IT WAS
BUILT TO CODE IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE AND NOW THEY'RE
JUST TRYING TO LEGALIZE IT WE
WANT TO HAVE A MEET THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE. RATHER THAN GO
THROUGH THE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
TWO- PERMITS WE WANT THE PEOPLE
TO COME OUT OF THE DARKNESS AND
HAVE THE CITIES GET THE- GET
THE- LOW INCOME TENANTS. A
CREDIT FOR THE ON THE READING
NUMBERS IT PROVIDES IT ALSO
ALLOWS UNITS AND- THIS WILL OUT
ADDITIONAL UNITS FOR- THE
OPTIONS. OUT FOR THE COMMUNITY
AS THEY TRY TO. MEET THESE
DEMANDS THAT THE STATE IS
PUTTING ON THEM. S. BY DRESSING
THE REMAINING PLAYERS WERE NOT
ONLY ENCOURAGING HOMEOWNERS TO
ASSIST US IN DEALING WITH THE
HOUSING CRISIS ALLOWING
HOMEOWNERS TO CREATE MORE
FINANCIAL STABILITY FOR
THEMSELVES AND THAT'S- THE
BOTTOM LINE I HAVE. KELLY
FALLON- THE BEAR WITH THE BARE
CANCEL AND BOBBY ARE TEH WITH
THE WELLNESS COMPANY HE'S A-
OFF. OF HELD GENERATIONAL WEALTH
IS BEING BUILT BY PEOPLE BY
FAMILIES THAT NORMALLY HAVE BEEN
LEFT OUT OF THE HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION AND THE AND THE
WEALTH BUILDING- ARENA SO MY
FIRST WITNESSES HERE. FOR HERE
GREAT THANK YOU- SENATOR WE WILL
NOW. GO TO YOUR LEAD WITNESSES-
WILL START WITH KELLY FALLON
FROM THE BAY AREA COUNCIL WHO IS
HEREBY. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I MEAN IF CALIFORNIANS ARE
MISSPELLING I'M SORRY CAN YOU
PLEASE PAUSE FOR ONE SECOND
APPARENTLY WE HAVE AN ATM OKAY.
ONE SECOND. THANK YOU ARE WE
GOOD NOW I KNOW HOLD ON WE HAVE
TO WAIT FOR A SECOND OH NO I'M
SORRY NOW WE'RE GOOD YOU ARE
BACK IT SOUNDS GOOD THANK YOU
OKAY SORRY ABOUT THAT. MISS ON
YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU SO
MUCH I'M POLICY STARTED EARLY-
SO MY NAME IS KELLY CALLING THEM
I SEE YOUR FAULT MANAGER. I'M
VERY COMFORTABLE WITH THE COURT
BECAUSE WE HAVE EXPERIENCE. THE
MORNING. AREA BECAUSE OF THE
THAT ARE WERE US ALL AND WE
DON'T KNOW CHALLENGING. WHERE
PATHFINDER PETER SEVEN. WHICH
THE FEDERAL FOR AFFORDABILITY
SHALL. BY REMOVING ADDITIONAL
PLAYERS WORKING FOR TO BUILD.
HOUSING CRISIS IS ONE DIFFICULT
IMPORTANCE TO EMPLOYERS THE LACK
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPTIONS. I
THINK THERE THE BILL YOU TO
TRACK YOUR TEAM. AT THE
CHRISTIAN WORKFORCE TO MAINTAIN
THE LONG TERM SUSTAINABILITY AND
HEALTH OF OUR KIND. TO DRUG USE
USE THE VERY HELPFUL SPONSORED
ONE OF THE- FIRST MAJOR STATE
REFORMS TO EASE THE PROCESS
ABILITY TO USE IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
WITH FEDERAL COUNTY. BATTLE SB
TEN FIFTY NINE REDUCED PARKING
REQUIREMENTS DISCUSSION
PERMITTING AN ONEROUS UTILITY
CONNECTION FEES THAT MADE IT
BUILDING IN THE- EAGLE COMPANY.
HOMEOWNERS BECAUSE IF NINETY
CAME LAWS THE STATE HAS HAD. ARE
YOU PROFIT EIGHTY. AND THEY NOW
HUNT TO A LOT OF ALL RESIDENTS
BUILDING FOR STATEWIDE. AND
810040% IN. IN NUMBER THAT
THERE'S THE ONLY OF HOUSE.
EXPERIENCING PROTEIN. CURRENTLY
IN SB NINETY SEVEN CONNECTING I
CURRENTLY HAVE OWNER.
REQUIREMENTS FOR EASY USE. AND
EXCELLING MESSAGING USE. THAT
AFRICA'S. TO GIVE HER WHICH TO
PROVIDE EIGHTY OKAY ONLY OR OF
THE- ORANGE NOT TO HELP THE- IN
. AND WE HEARD STORE OF HOME IN
EIGHTY ROGERS HAVING A FOR. CARE
UP. OR HAVE A BETWEEN TO
GENERATE EXTRA AND- ESPECIALLY
IN TIMES LIKE THE COMING KING
CAN MAKE IT INVALUABLE. WE'VE
SEEN GREAT SENSE FOR EIGHTY
THREE BY THE HORRIBLE OPTIONS
THE CAL. ENGINEERING FOR HEALTH
. FACING THE SUCCESS AND ENSURE
THAT ALL HOME ARE ABLE TO ACCESS
PROPERTY. EXACTLY ON I IN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THE WELLNESS COMPANY. I WOULD BE
OPEN SERVICES SMART MEDICAL
EIGHTY YOU. OF THE FAMILY SO
THAT THEY CAN PRINT ABOUT GOING
HOME SAFELY. EXCEPT WE FOUNDED
IN THE AREA FIVE FIVE SEVEN. AND
WE GOT OUR START AFTER. STROKE
WE CAN VERY QUICKLY THAT SENIOR
CARE IN CALIFORNIA LOOKS PRUDENT
AND CONSISTENT HAVING HARDWARE
OF CARE GIVERS WITH THE COURSE
OF THE USE. AT ALL OF OUR BEST
SECURITY SCARE ACTION ON
QUESTIONERS FOR YEARS WHAT WHAT
IS. OUR OPTIONS WERE EXTREMELY
LIMITED AND OUR FATHER WASN'T
GIVEN ABOUT EIGHTEEN MONTHS. TO
LIVE. SO WE CHARGE HOME. WHICH
WAS X. IN CONSISTS. AND EVEN TRY
TO CURE FOR PUBLIC SALES BUT MY
PART AND EXPERIENCE. THE NEXT
TIME YOU WITH A SISTER WITH HER
FIVE YEARS. THE COMPANY DIRECTLY
TO WE NEEDED OPTION. SO AT THIS
TIME WE GET RESERVE. SENIOR COPS
. I FELT THAT THE BEST. HERE
WITH. A SAFE THE SPACE CLOSE TO
FAMILY IT CAN. SO WE CAN ALL
SHARE IN HIS. SO SET OUT TO
BUILD EIGHTY. WE FIXED PUTS FROM
NEIGHBORS FROM LOCAL BUILDING AT
TO BECAUSE NON COMPLAINTS AND
THE WAS ARE YOU AND OVER A YEAR
COULD. WHAT WAS MOVED. AFTER
LEGISLATION WAS TO MAKE. EIGHTY
PROCESS EASIER. TODAY SEVEN
LATER APPLAUSE HELPING IN
GETTING. ON IT SAY THAT EIGHTY
YOU SAVED HIS LIFE. SO BUILDING
A FOR PROPER WAS A GREAT STORE
WESTON SHARED WITH OTHERS AND-
TWO HOURS. AND ARE OUR COMPANY
APPS TO. OF AND THEY ALL SHIP
WITH SENTIMENT. BUILDING EIGHTY
YOU HAVE. OR HELP SIX LEVELS
LIFE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND AYE AYES HAVE-
MENTIONED I APOLOGIZE THAT- EACH
WITNESS WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES
FOR PRO AND CON TO PRO TO
CONDUCT THERE ARE THAT MANY OF
THOSE WITNESSES WERE WELL WITHIN
THE LIMIT- SO WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO- ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT IF THERE'S ANYONE HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM IN SUPPORT
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND THE FACT OF
YOUR SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN I DO ARE YOU READY FOR
WITH LONGER ON HOW WE'RE DOING
HEARING ROOM ALL THAT YOU KNOW
WHEN WE'RE READY FOR A PHONE
WITNESSES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
DIFFICULT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION AND SO
FORTH. ANY ADDITIONAL US SUPPORT
OF PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND- SOUNDS LIKE MISTER
MODERATOR COULD WE GET SOME YOU
DOING GOING ON THERE BECAUSE
THERE'S SOME SOUND COMING FROM
THE PHONE LINES. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES PLEASE MUTE
. YEAH IF FOLKS COULD JUST MOVE
THEIR LINES UNTIL THE RATE OF
SPEED- MANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
OF PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SAYING NONE WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES
OF THE MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANY SUPPORT OF. PUBLIC TESTIMONY
AND AGAIN. WE'RE PLEASED TO
STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATIONAL AFFILIATION IF
ANY AND THE FACT OF YOUR SUPPORT
. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
IN EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR WILL
QUICKLY GIVE YOUR LIGHT NUMBER
AND THE PLACE YOU BLACK BACK
INTO THE QUEUE. AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY. ON THIS BILL AND LIKE
TWENTY FOUR YOU ARE OPEN. HE
TURNED SENATORS JOHN THE TWO DAY
ON BEHALF OF THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN SUPPORT FOR. LINE
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING IS NOW ARE GOING OUT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOMEBUILDING ALLIANCE WHICH
INCLUDES BECAUSE HE TOOK
OWNERSHIP ARE INTO THE CALL AND
SUPPORT EACH YEAR. AND AS A
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL AND WE WILL GO. ONE MOMENT
ONE THIRTY YOU ARE OPEN. KAREN
MEMBERS- ROGER DICKINSON ON
BEHALF OF CIVIC WELL IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR NOTED A
PARTICIPANT QUEUED UP. GREAT-THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW
GO TO- OPPOSITION TO SB NINETY
SEVEN WE DON'T HAVE ANY
OFFICIAL- OPPOSITION. OPPOSITION
WITNESSES- FOR OUR TO BE OUR
LEAD OPPONENTS SO WE WILL GO TO-
ANY OPPOSITION TESTIMONY HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO. TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION HERE TODAY I DON'T
SEE ANYONE SO WE NOW GO TO THE
PHONE LINES- IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY OPPONENTS THE S. B.
THE NINETY SEVEN. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO AYE TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME BUT- BASED THERE'LL.
ONE MOMENT WE DO HAVE A
PARTICIPANT QUEUING UP ANYBODY
ELSE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. THANK
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE SHARING THEMSELVES
WITH THE READY PUBLIC POLICY
GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
BAKERSFIELD IN CARLSBAD IN
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT NINETY
SEVEN THANK YOU. AND A FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
THE TEST PLAN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL AND WE WILL GO TO ONE
THIRTEEN YOU ARE OFTEN. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS PRETTY CURTAIN
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING OFFICIALS ARE OPPOSED
TO AT THE A. NINE I'VE BEEN OF
BRITAIN THAT WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR STAFF ON AMENDMENTS
AND LOOK FORWARD TO UP. THE OPEN
DIALOGUE AND CONTINUE DIALOGUE
I'M ABOUT THANK YOU. AND NEXT UP
IS ONE THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY MR JERRY LEWIS
MARONDERA BEHALF OF PROPERTY IN
THE IN THE PORT BARRE RELATE.
AND THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL NOW BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS SENATOR CRITICIZES.
THANK YOU SECURE- IN IN I JUST
WANNA RACE THREE POINTS- A BE.
AN AYE VOTE ON BILL- YOU KNOW
REALLY REALLY IS- MUCH A
COURTESY IS ANYTHING TO GET IT
OUT I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT WOOD- WHAT THE AUTHOR
IS DOING. A TO TRY TO MOVE THIS
ALONG CERTAINLY- IN MY WORKING
WITH LOCAL REGIONAL GOVERNMENT
BEEN A HUGE ISSUE TO TRY TO GET
SOME UNIFORMITY AND- SOME
STREAMLINING GOING AND WE DON'T
ALWAYS GET THE COOPERATION OF
SOMETIMES OF OUR OWN PLANNING
PROFESSIONALS- THAT SAID THERE'S
THREE AREAS GOING FORWARD THERE
ARE A I WILL CONTINUE TO LOOK UP
WITH- A LOT OF CONCERN IN IN I
SEE THAT- CERTAINLY IF. THE
AUTHOR WANTS TO RESPOND. BUT NOW
WE'RE DURING HIS CLOTHES- SO
WITH THE PERMISSION OF THE CHAIR
THAT'S THAT'S UP TO THE AUTHOR
BUT- MORE THAN ANYTHING I JUST
WANT TO FLAG THESE THREE ISSUES
FOR ME BECAUSE- IT COULD COME
DOWN. THE TWO FOUR VOTE AT SOME
POINT- I'VE BEEN PRETTY CLEAR ON
THE RECORD- THAT IN IN MY NECK
OF THE WOODS PREDOMINATELY-
PARTICULAR THE EAST SIDE OF MY
DISTRICT- THAT WE TYPICALLY USE.
AN EIGHT HUNDRED FOOT THE
QUARTER MILE PEDESTRIAN-
LIMITATION IF YOU WILL OF. FOR A
PARKING AROUND TRANSIT STOPS
WERE WERE JUST PEDESTRIAN
FRIENDLY A TRANSIT STOPS- I
THINK CENTER BECAUSE OF
NEIGHBORING DISTRICTS YOU KNOW A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT THE AREA IN THE
TRANSIT AGENCY WORK BILL- TO BE
WALKABLE- AT HELP AT HALF MILE
DISTANCES TO BE SAFE A NUMBER OF
LEVELS AT THOSE DISTANCES SO. OF
MY CONSTITUENTS- HAVE A BIG
PROBLEM WITH THAT- SO YOU KNOW
REDUCING THAT DOWN WOULD BE AN
ISSUE SIMILARLY- ON THE HEIGHT.
LIMITS WHICH I'M READING THE
BILL AS A TWENTY FIVE FOOT BY
RIGHT- WOULD REALLY FLY IN THE
FACE OF COMMITMENTS I'VE MADE TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS IN MY
DISTRICT THAT THEY WOULD HAVE
SOME DISCRETION AROUND HEIGHTS
INCLUDING THE RECENT SB NINE
DISCUSSION WHICH I WAS WAS A
PROUD CO AUTHOR OF THE BILL BUT
ABOVE ALSO HAD. TO WORK REALLY
REALLY HARD YOU KNOW WITH FIFTY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MY
JURISDICTION TO REASSURE THEM
THAT- WE UNDERSTAND OR
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S
NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE- HI. HER
LACK OF HEIGHT LIMITATIONS
CANNOT JUST BE A BY RIGHT ISSUE
SO I ENDED UP THERE SOMETHING
MORE THAT CAN BE DONE WORKING ON
THAT. IN THE LAST WEEK- CODE
ISSUES AGAIN I WANT TO HARKEN
BACK TO THE MOST REDLINED
PORTION OF MY DISTRICT- WHICH
WHICH EIGHT EIGHT I THINK AGAIN
IF ANYBODY WANTS TO WRITE I
THINK THE BE THE GREED THAT WE
HAVE A VERY RED LINED UP THE
SIDE OF OUR DISTRICT- IN THAT
AREA WE HAVE HUGE PROBLEMS WITH
CODE ENFORCEMENT ISSUES IN IN A
SORT OF THE ILLEGAL EIGHTY USE
SEPARATE CONVERTED GARAGES AND
SO FORTH I NOTED THAT- IN THE
ANALYSIS IT TALKS ABOUT SAN
FRANCISCO HAVING. OF PERHAPS 8%
HELLO NINE CODE COMPLIANT EIGHTY
USE THAT ARE OUT THERE
ESSENTIALLY ILLEGAL EIGHTY YEARS
I WOULD. I WOULD. SUBMIT I DON'T
HAVE THE DATA FOR THAT IN THE
SIDE OF MY DISTRICT THE NUMBER
IS FAR HIGHER THAN THAT. IN AN
ADULT IN EIGHT I DON'T. I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE BILL SAYS-
THAT THERE'S ONLY AMNESTY IF
THERE'S NO HEALTH AND SAFETY
VIOLATIONS BUT I JUST DON'T KNOW
WHAT THOSE. WOULD BE PRESCRIBED
TO BE- OR OR HOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WOULD INTERPRET
THAT. HE I JUST THINK IT'S
HUGELY IMPORTANT HERE TO
PREVENT. FRANKLY SOME OF THE
CONDITIONS WERE SEEN RIGHT NOW
IN TERMS OF HABITABILITY IN
TERMS OF. FIRE SAFETY IN TERMS
OF- YOU KNOW FOLKS SAID YOUR
SORT OF PACKED THE AND- LIKE
SARDINES INTO EXTRAORDINARY
SMALL SPACES SO- THERE'S LOTS
AND LOTS OF GREAT STUFF IN THIS
BILL- SO I PAY HEED TO FOCUS ON
THE THREE THINGS THAT. I WOULD
BE LOOKING FOR SOME CONTINUE TO
WORK ON AND- AND NOT HIGHLIGHT
ALL THE ALL THE THINGS THAT HAVE
BEEN. YOU KNOW REALLY I THINK
REALLY APPROPRIATELY CALLED OUT
IN THE BILL ON THE POSITIVE SIDE%
SO THANK YOU FOR. YOUR
LEADERSHIP THANK YOU FOR
CONTINUE TO WORK IN THE SPACE-
BUT- I'M TRYING TO BE HELPFUL IN
TERMS OF. WHAT I THINK IS FOR ME
AND PERHAPS THE- SOME OF OUR
CALL GOING TO BE THE CHAU.
ISSUES WITH THE BILL THAT COULD
PERHAPS TO BE WORKED OUT THANK
YOU. RESEARCHER IF YOU COULD
RESPOND TO THOSE QUESTIONS AT
LEAST HOPEFULLY. AND THAT'S IT
YES MA'AM- YES PLEASE OKAY- HE
SAID WITH REGARD TO THE HALF
MILE THAT WAS PART OF- AB TEN
SIXTY NINE THAT ALLOW PEOPLE
THAT IF YOU LIVE WITHIN HALF
MILE OF TRANSIT THEN YOU'D BE
ELIGIBLE BY RIGHT TO BUILD AN
EIGHTY YEAR IF YOU LIVE OUTSIDE
THE HALF MILE YOU COULDN'T SO
THAT WAS SORT OF A STATE WIDE.
IT COMPROMISE THAT WE TOOK SIX
YEARS AGO- THERE WERE PEOPLE
THAT OBJECTED TO THAT AT THE
TIME AND I. I REPRESENT THE EAST
SIDE WITH VARIOUS ALSO SO I
REALIZE THAT ANY PARTICULAR
NEIGHBORHOOD THAT MAY HAVE
STRESS STRESS ON IT I KNOW I CAN
FROM HE WERE TO GET FROM
UNINCORPORATED AREAS JUST PEOPLE
GO THROUGH BUT THAT'S WE DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S WHERE AN
ABUNDANCE OF ITS BEING MADE BUT
THAT WAS SORT OF THIS. LET'S
MAKE IT AS AN EASY THING SO I'M
NOT CHANGING THAT THAT'S ALREADY
THIS STATE LAW ON THE HALF MILE
RADIUS FROM FROM- TRANSIT- WITH
REGARD TO THE HEIGHT LIMIT YOU
KNOW I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY SIX
YEARS AGO ON AB R. S. B. TEN
SIXTY NINE AND I TOOK AN
AMENDMENT. FROM THE DAY I STILL
HAVE SIXTEEN FEET WITH THAT
DISCUSSION AND WHAT WE DIDN'T
REALIZE IS THAT YOU NEED TO
CRAWL SPACE. IN YOUR HOUSE THE
IDEA IS THAT. IF THE C. WARD.
FOR SINGLE FAMILY HOUSING IS
TWENTY TWO FEET. I'M FINE AND
THAT'S ONE OF THINGS WILL BE
TALKING ABOUT WITH THE CHAIR OF
GOVERNMENT FINANCE AND THIS YEAR
WHAT THAT SWEET SPOT IS IF THE
CITY ORDINANCES SAYING YOU CAN
BILL TWENTY TWO FEET. AND I'M
OKAY WITH THAT RIGHT- BUT
SIXTEEN FEET IS SORT OF A
TRICKSTER'S WAY OF SAYING THAT
YOU CAN ONLY HAVE ONE STORY. AND
THAT THE CHALLENGES THAT I HAVE
A PERSON ON MY LEFT SIDE OF MY
HOUSE TO MY RIGHT SAID HOUSE ALL
HAVE TWO STORY BUILDINGS AND IF
I WANT TO PUT A- EIGHTY WILL FOR
MY GARAGE WHICH IS SMALLER THAN
THE TWO STORY ADDITIONS. I
TECHNICALLY COULDN'T DO IT
BECAUSE IT'S OVER SIXTEEN FEET
OR I WOULD HAVE TO TRANSMITTER
PEOPLE WE'VE HAD REPORTS FROM
EACH CITY WHERE PEOPLE ARE
TRENCHING. JUST TO GET THE
FOUNDATION IN AND SOME SORT OF
PROOF BECAUSE- AGAIN I WAS. NO I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MAGIC
NUMBER IS BUT THAT'S WHAT THE
IDEA IS I DON'T WANT IT TO BE.
BIGGER AND BETTER THAN WHAT
EVERYBODY ELSE IN THE CITY HAS
AND THAT IS. THE BIG COMPANIES
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
IS WHAT THAT HIGH LIMIT IS SO
AND I'M OPEN AND I WANT
EVERYBODY TO KNOW THAT. IT'S
UNKNOWN WHAT'S CINDY WAS FOR ME
AS FAR AS THE CODE ENFORCEMENT
AS WE YOU KNOW WE GET YOU KNOW
SOME OF THE PEOPLE THE BUILDING
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE BUILDING
OFFICIALS NO WE DON'T WANT. WHEN
WE CHANGE THE DEFINITION FROM
SECOND UNITS TO EIGHTY USE BACK
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE REASON WHY
SHE SAID ALL THE CITIES IN THE
STATE PASSED SECOND UNIT ROB
RIGHT WAS THAT SENATOR HE WAS IN
THE SETTLEMENT OF TIME PASS A
BILL SAID ALL THE CITIES HAVE TO
DO A SECONDARY UNITS AND WHEN I
GOT HERE IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
THERE WERE. LIKE FIVE SECONDARY
UNITS THAT WERE BEING BUILT
STATE IT WAS A IT WAS IT THE
FACT AWAY TO HAVE NO MOTHER IN
LAW UNITS BUILT LIST YOU'RE RICH
YOU LIVED ON THE HILL AND WHO
CARES IF YOU JUST THIS PAPER SO
THIS WHOLE. TRYING TO BILLS IN
THE DISCUSSION HAS BEEN TO TRY
TO TRY TO DO THAT SO THE
QUESTION IS WHAT DO YOU DO WITH
THE BOOTLEG UNITS AND AGAIN WE
PUT HEALTH AND SAFETY IN THERE.
BECAUSE IF SOMEBODY IS. FIVE
PEOPLE LIVE IN A IN IN THE
GARAGE AND ALL THAT STUFF THAT'S
ILLEGAL THAT'S DONE. I'VE WE
DON'T HAVE ANY TOLERANCE FOR
THAT BUT IF YOU HAVE A UNIT.
THAT YOU DIDN'T GO THROUGH. THE
BUILDING PERMIT BUT YOU BUILD UP
TO CODE AT THE TIME. AND IT'S
CONTINUED TO BE HEALTHY IT'S NO
DIFFERENT FROM THE MOTHER HOUSE
IT'S HEALTH AND SAFETY WE WANT
TO. WE WANT TO GIVE DIRECTION TO
THE BUILDING AUTHORITIES THAT
HAVE THE DISCRETION TO SIGN OFF
ON THIS WE DON'T WANT. PEOPLE TO
STAY IN THE DARKNESS AND NOT DO
IT AND THAT. AND THAT PROVISION
HAD A FIVE YEAR LIMITATION SO
WE'VE LOST TWO YEARS WE- RIVER
NOBODY HAS. THE CAN'T GET A
BUILDING OFFICIAL OUT I'M BRAND
NEW BUILDING IT'S HARD TO GET.
OFFICIALS THERE SO WE SO WE'RE
THINKING THAT THAT'S THAT'S-
THAT'S THE- PROBLEM THEY HAVE
IT'S STILL GOING TO BE PROBLEMS
DOING EDUCATION WITH FOLKS
BECAUSE THEY'RE STILL SCARED
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THIS. ILLEGAL
UNIT AND TRYING TO GIVE A CARE
TO THE CITIES AND STATES. THAT
HELPS ON YOUR RENEW THAT HELPS
WITH YOUR LOW INCOME SO IF IT'S
IF IT'S SMALLER AND HORRIBLE.
THAT'S THE SAME THING WITH THE
HOUSE THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS BILL
IS TRYING TO DO WAS JUST SAYING.
IF YOU'RE WITHIN HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND TECHNICALLY. TODAY'S
CODE DOESN'T MATCH UP TO WHEN
YOU BUILT THIS- AND I DON'T WANT
TO PERPETUATE THIS I DON'T WANT
PEOPLE DILLON ILLEGALLY COMING
BACK FOR GRACE THAT'S NOT THE-
THAT'S NOT THE RULE. I HOPE THAT
HELPS. THANK YOU COLLEAGUES ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS-
CENTER MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIRPERSON FOR MOST
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
CENTER I KASKY FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE- CINEMA
CASKEY FACED INCREDIBLE
HEADWINDS WHEN HE FIRST BROUGHT
FORWARD- THE ISSUE ON A SAYS HER
DWELLING UNITS AND THAT IS AN
UNDERSTATEMENT. IN WE FAST
FORWARD NOW TO TWENTY TWENTY TWO
WE TAKE A LOOK AT THE SUCCESS
THAT THIS LEGISLATION IS PASSED
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. DID I. IN A
SMART NEIGHBORHOOD DRIVEN WAY-
WE CAN WAVE THE FLAG OF SUCCESS
KNOWING THAT WE'RE GONNA SEE
MORE IN THE COMING MONTHS AND
YEARS IN FACT- THERE HAVE BEEN
THREE STUDIES IN THE STATE. THAT
HAS SHOWN TO WIN SEVEN
CALIFORNIA ONE IN- IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THAT SHOWS THAT OVER
SIXTY PERCENT. OF THESE EIGHTY
TWO UNITS ARE AFFORDABLE TO
FOLKS THAT ARE MAKING- AT OR
BELOW A MONTH. WHICH IS TRULY.
REMARKABLE AND THESE AREN'T EVEN
DEED RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE
UNITS. THEIR EFFICIENCY UNITS AT
THAT AT THE WORK FORCE CAN
PROVIDE THE NEEDS OF THE TYPE OF
SOLUTIONS THAT WE NEED IN
CALIFORNIA. SO I WANNA TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU SARAH
CASKEY FREE LEADERSHIP AND ALSO
KNOW THAT OTHER BEEN SEVERAS.
OVER THE YEARS AND YOU HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD- AND PASS THEM. THE
ISSUE IS AND WHY CASKEY HAD
POINTED OUT WHERE THEY'RE- AT
I'LL BE SPEAK FOR MYSELF
CONTINUE CHALLENGES IS. GOING
FROM SIXTEEN TO TWENTY FIVE
FEET. APPRECIATE CINEMA KATHY'S
COMMITMENT. AT TO BE ABLETO SIT
DOWN AND IN WORK OBVIOUSLY WITH
THE CHAIRWOMAN OF GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE AND- LOOK FORWARD TO
OUR- PERSONAL ENGAGEMENT AS
WELL. ON THAT ISSUE- BECAUSE I
THINK WE HAVE A REALLY GOOD
THING RIGHT NOW. WE HAVE A GOOD
THING WITH EIGHTY USING ADIS-
AND WE KNOW THAT NOT ALL AGREE.
S. AND HER TEETH IT SAID AND
MAKE SB NINE WILL BE THAT NEXT
GAME CHANGER LEGISLATION.
LOOKING AT NEIGHBORHOOD.
DEVELOPMENT THAT IS S. AT SUMMIT
SAID VERY ELOQUENT APPROACH. SO
WHAT I WOULD HOPE IS THAT WE
DON'T UPSET THAT APPLE CART. WE
KEEP IT AT THE SIXTEEN FEET AND
OR IF THE CITY COUNCIL WANTS TO
BE ABLE TO. AT SAID THEY WANT TO
GO BEYOND THAT THEN THE CITY
COUNCIL CAN THEN- PASS THEIR
OWN. OR NEEDS. TO BE ESSENTIALLY
OPT INTO THAT. HAVE TO CONCERN
IN REGARDS THE PARKING OF THAT
WILL A- CONTINUE DISCUSSION. BUT
IN PARTICULAR ON THE ISSUE OF
THE TWENTY FIVE FEET. I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT CAN BE
DONE HERE AND- NEXT FEW WEEKS
AND GETTING. TO KNOW MY CASKET I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR ESSENCE
YOUR ENGAGEMENT AND YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK ON THAT.
THANK YOU CENTER REQUIRED OUR
COLLEAGUES ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS SENATOR OTOBO. GOOD
MORNING. SO I SHARE THE SAME OF
THE SAME CONCERNS AS MY
COLLEAGUES DO ON A DIET I ALSO
WANTED FOR THE RECORD- WOULD YOU
MIND- CERVIX SPENDING A LITTLE
BIT MORE WITH REGARDS TO OR
PUTTING ON THE RECORD. WITH
REGARDS TO THE SECOND FLOOR
EIGHTY USE AND- WITH THAT
INCLUDE- PIECES OF OUR
PROPERTIES THAT ARE SINGLE STORY
IN ADDING AT AN EIGHTY YOU TO
THE GARAGE. OR IS IT JUST FOR
UNITS THAT. ALREADY HAVE TWO
STORY- HOMES IN ADDING AN EIGHTY
YOU TO THE TOP OF THE GARAGE
WHAT IS YOUR UNDERSTANDING OKAY
IT'S ALL OF THE ABOVE IT'S ALL
THE ABOVE YOU WOULD GET. IT
WOULD ALLOW SINGLE STORY HOUSES
THAT. CURRENTLY DO NOT HAVE A
SECOND FLOOR TO PUT AN EIGHTY
YOU OVER THE GARAGE FOR INSTANCE
AND WHICH SHOULD BE NEW
CONSTRUCTION- THAT WOULD GO IN
AND AS YOU'VE HEARD WE WANT A
HARMONIZED AT WHAT WHAT THE CITY
ORDINANCE ARE ON ON HIGH
CLEMENTS TO- WHETHER IT'S AN OPT
IN OR OPT OUT OF PROGRAM. IT IF
THE IF THIS UNIT ALREADY HAS THE
SECOND STORY AND THEY WANT TO
BECAUSE YOU CAN HAVE ATTACHED
AND DETACHED IF IT ALREADY HAS
THE SECOND STORY YOU CAN. CUT UP
YOUR HOUSE. HOUSE PROBABLY NOT
THE MOST ELEGANT THE CHANGE YOUR
HOUSE SO THAT THAT SECOND STORY
BECOMES TECHNICALLY A SECOND IT
BECOMES AN EIGHTY YEAR THAT'S
ALLOWABLE THAT'S ALLOWABLE NOW.
UNDER UNDER THE LAW AND THIS
WOULD ALLOW A BACKYARD COTTAGE
IF THE TWENTY FIVE PEOPLE OR
SOME VARIATION COMMENT TO HAVE A
SECOND UNIT THERE- I DON'T LIVE
IN THE COMMUTER MAY I HAVE A
COMMUTE A LITTLE BIT OF MY
COMMUNITY HAS. DETACHED GARAGE
FOR A LOT OF I KNOW LOS ANGELES
HAS A LOT OF DETACHED GARAGES IN
THE BACKYARD VERY POPULAR FOR
PEOPLE COMMENDED JUST. GOT THEM
AND THEN MAKE THEM INTO EIGHTY
USE THIS WILL ALLOW THEM. AT A
PRICE THE BILL THE SECOND THE
BILL THE SECOND STORY AS LONG AS
THEY- YOU KNOW THEY WE HAVE A-
NEW IMPACT FEE FOR SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY FEET SO THAT SEEMS TO BE
THAT. THE HARDLINE. YOU KNOW I
MEAN IF YOU WANT TO GO BIGGER
YOU PAY YOU PAY SO IT WOULD BE-
WITH THE LOOSENING IT WOULD IT
WOULD. I THINK THAT'S HOW IT
AFFECTED ON THE GROUND. AND THEN
THE OTHER QUESTION THAT THAT I
HAVE FOR YOU IS- WOULD YOU MIND
EXPANDING OR EXPLAINING- TO OUR
AUDIENCE. HOW THIS AFFECTS OUR
DOES NOT AFFECT HOAS YEAH THE
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION I'VE HAD
SOME FIGHTS WITH HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATIONS ARE DIFFERENT BILLS
ON THIS BILL WE DON'T TOUCH THEM
BECAUSE I THINK. THE HOMEOWNER
WHO BUYS IN A HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATION SIGNED SIX
CONDITIONS AND COVENANTS AND IF
THOSE CONDITIONS AND COVENANTS
SAY THAT YOU CAN'T BUILD. AN
EIGHTY YEAR YOU CAN'T FILL THE
SECOND FLOOR YOU WERE TO THAT.
ALL THOSE OF US IN REGULAR
SUBURBIA WERE. SITTING COUNTY
SOMEWHERE- THEY THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE THOSE RESTRICTIONS AND THE
CITY'S ALLOW THAT CONSTRUCTION
THEN THAT WOULD BE CONSISTENT
WITH. THAT BUT THIS THESE. S. B.
EIGHT NINE SEVEN WOULD NOT
CHANGE. AT ALL THE CONDITIONS
WITH EIGHTY EIGHT- M. H. WAYS TO
LIMIT OR PROHIBIT. EIGHTY YEARS
FROM BEING CONSTRUCTED
CONSTRUCTED IN THOSE AREAS IT
JUST REMAINS THE SAME IT. THERE
IS ANOTHER BILL I THINK-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN HAD THE
BILL THAT INVITED EIGHTY EIGHT.
H. WAYS TO CONSIDER WHETHER THEY
WANT TO VOTE AS A BODY TO ALLOW
THEM BUT THAT'S UP TO THEM. NOT
THAT THE STATE AND THIS
LEGISLATION DOES NOT CHANGE THAT
. THANK YOU OKAY. ON ANY OTHER-
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
CENTER BATES. I THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU OF FINANCIAL ACCOUNTS
BEFORE THAT VARY ON DETAILED
DESCRIPTION I WILL SAY I LIVE IN
AN H. AWAY WITH QUITE LIMITED
AND WE DID HAVE TO TRANSHIPPED
TO GET A GARAGE BUT IT'S NO BIG
DEAL OKAY SO PEOPLE ARE MAKING
OUT IN ONE OF THE REASONS WHY I
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THAT- BUT IT IS CONCERNING WHEN
MY ANALYSIS OF THAT THE CCN
OURS. ARE FOR HOAS ARE OVER
RULED AND IF THAT'S NOT ACCURATE
I WANT THAT ON THE RECORD
BECAUSE SENATOR- ARE PROTIUM AND
ARE GOOD CHAIR HERE BOTH AGREED
WHEN THEY HAVE THE ADDITIONAL
THAT- CC IN OURS IN TERMS OF
HOAS FOR ANY ADDITIONAL- MULTI
FAMILY AND SINGLE FAMILY ZONING
WOULD NOT BE EFFECTIVE SO I'M
NOT SURE THAT MIGHT BE AN ERROR
IN THAT YOU DON'T HAVE YOU ON
THE RECORD SAYING THAT IS. IT'S
AT LEAST COMFORTING BUT I'M NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY UNTIL WE SEE WHERE YOU GO
WITH SOME OF THE OTHER ISSUES
FOR THE RECORD KNOWING THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO VOTE NO ON THIS
BILL. THIS IS A LOT OF THE SAME
AS- CONDITIONS AND- CABINETS AND
THE H. AWAY AND THAT'S THAT'S A
THAT'S AN ERROR ON THE TRADING
OUT FOR GARAGE WE DID AND WE GOT
A FOUR CAR GARAGE WHICH ALLOWED
US TO NOT VIOLATE THE PARKING
RESTRICTIONS IN OUR H. AWAY AND
LESSER THINGS I THINK ARE VERY
IMPORTANT FOR DEVELOPERS WHO ARE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL BENDER
STAND YOU KNOW FOLLOWING THE
COMMUNITY. REGULATION RULES I
HAVE A LOT TO DO WITH PROVIDING
COMMUNITIES WHERE WE DON'T HAVE
A LOT OF AGGRAVATION AND
LITIGATION AND HOAS AS YOU WELL
KNOW ARE VERY SUBJECT TO THAT
WHEN PEOPLE VIOLATE THE PARKING-
WITH LARGE VANS AND BOATS YOU
NAME IT SO NO ONE IN AND I HOPE
THAT THAT THAT EVERY EIGHTY YOU
FELT THAT I'VE HAD INCLUDING
YEAH EIGHT NINE SEVEN INCREASES
THAT PROTECTED THE RESPECT THAT
THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN HOAS AND
PEOPLE THAT THAT THAT FORM A
CHOICE. WITH THOSE RULES TRUMP
BECAUSE THERE WE WHO STUDIES
THAT YOU SIGN A CONTRACT IS A
CONTRACT EITHER BY BY THESE.
THESE RULES OF THE THAT THE AT
THE REQUEST OF US IN. AN IN THE
STATE OF. HAVE OUR CITY
ORDINANCES THAT THAT RULE AND OF
THE CITY ORDINANCE MY SIT OF
FREMONT. AS A SEVEN FOOT. HIGH
ON SINGLE FAMILY HOME. I KNOW
KNOW ANYBODY WHO'S BUILT ON THIS
TOUCH MORE BUT IT'S A BIG IT'S A
BIG DEAL. SO I'M GONNA BE
WORKING WITH. THE CHAIR OF
HOUSING THE CHAIR OF GOVERNMENT
FINANCE THE FORMER CHAIR OF
GOVERNMENT FINANCE AND- AND
PROBABLY OTHER PEOPLE TO. TO
RIGHT SIZE THIS THIS HYPHEN
ABOUT WITH. REGARD TO. HOAS
THAT'S NOT MY FIGHT OR NOT I'M
NOT. I'M NOT IN THERE VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR AND-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS.
SENATE SKINNER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND- SIDERITE COUNTY BRING
THE BILL I WANT TO MAKE A CASE
FOR- WHY. THE TWENTY FIVE HI BUT
HI CAN BE APPROPRIATE AND YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY PART OF OUR
INTEREST IN EXPANDING THE
ABILITY FOR HOMEOWNERS TO DO
EIGHTY YEARS AND MAKING IT
EASIER TO GET PERMITS IN FACT.
IS TO THE AUTHOR HOUSING CRISIS
BUT AT THE SAME TIME AS WE DO
OFFER HOUSING CRISIS WE ARE ALSO
. COGNISANT OF YOU KNOW WE WANT
TO ALSO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD STILL HAVE
AMENITIES AND SUCH. AND
DEPENDING ON THE CONFIGURATION
OF THE YARD HAVING A NARROWER
BUT HIGHER EDU COULD ALLOW FOR
MORE. ROOM YOU KNOW YOUR GARDEN
SPACE YARD SPACE RECREATIONAL
SPACE FOR PLANTINGS YOU NAME IT.
AND I THINK THERE'S A TO FOR US
TO FEEL THAT WE HAVE TO
ARBITRARILY AND I KNOW BARB
THREE MAY NOT BE THE RIGHT WORD
BUT- THAT WE WANT TO JUST KEEP
EIGHT USE CONTACT. EIGHT EIGHT
TWENTY FOOT TWENTY FIVE FOOT
HIGH EIGHTY YOU COULD STILL BE
VERY CONTACT IT COULD JUST BE AT
A HIGHER PRICE. AND IN MY OWN
NEIGHBORHOOD- THE LOCKS IN THIS
IS COMMON IN SOME OF OUR OLDER
CITIES LIKE TURNER. AND ONE OF
MY NEIGHBORS WANTED TO PUT IN A
BEFORE WE HAD DONE BEFORE THE
STATED DONE THE TYPES OF- YOU
KNOW. GIVING THE GREEN LIGHT TO
EIGHTY YEARS WANTED TO PUT A
SECOND UNIT IN. AND WANTED IT TO
BE. A TWO STORIES IN ORDER TO
PRESERVE MORE AT THE YARD FOR
THAT NOT ONLY THE NEW RESIDENTS
AND NEED YOU BUT THE EXISTING
RESIDENTS. AND VARIOUS NEIGHBORS
FOUGHT ARE BASICALLY ARGUING YOU
KNOW SHADE PROBLEMS BUT THEN
ONCE THEY DID THE SHADE STUDY
ONCE THEY PUT THE POLES OF
EVERYTHING THEY FOUND THAT NO IT
DIDN'T CREATE. IN FACT IT WOULD
HAVE A BETTER YOU KNOW BETTER
IMPACT ON THE DIFFERENT LOT
AROUND IT AS A TWO STORY BEING
NARROWER. NO MORE CONTENT THEN
IF THEY THEN THE PLAN IF IT WERE
YOU KNOW THE SQUARE FEET ALL IN
ONE STORY. AND ANYWAY WAS JUST
AN INTERESTING THIS WAS MORE
THAN TEN YEARS AGO IT WAS JUST
AN INTERESTING NO DEBATE THAT
WAS GOING ON AROUND AND PEOPLE
ASSERT IMPACTS. JUST BECAUSE WE
ASSUME WITHOUT REALLY KNOWING SO
I THINK THAT WHAT YOU'RE
PROPOSING IS VERY IMPORTANT. AND
I ALSO THINK THAT WE THAT WHILE
YES MANY RESIDENTS COMPLAIN
ABOUT PARKING. THE REQUIREMENTS
OF PARKING HAVE BEEN ONE OF THE
MAIN REASONS WE CANNOT BESIDES
ALL OF OUR ZONING RESTRICTIONS
OTHER ZONING RESTRICTIONS AND
SUCH IT'S ONE OF THE MAIN
REASONS THAT WE'VE NOT BEEN ABLE
TO ACCOMPLISH THE AMOUNT OF
HOUSING THAT WE NEED IN
CALIFORNIA. SO I THINK THAT
YOU'RE GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION I SUPPORT THE BILL IF
IT HASN'T. BEEN MOVED ALREADY ON
THE- GREAT I THINK EVER MEMBER
OF THE COMMITTEE ON THE EXCEPT
CABALLERO GOING TO ONE TO SAY.
SO MADAM CHAIR WHO'S GOING TO
RECEIVE A AFTER THIS. SEVEN FOUR
SEVEN. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- AND I DO APOLOGIZE
FOR WALKING IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
HEARING I WAS IN AND THAT THE
COMMITTEE. BUT I JUST THAT THIS
THIS- THIS BILL. I'VE HAD A
NUMBER OF CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
CENTER RIGHT HOUSE KEY ON IT
AND- IT WILL COME TO GOVERNOR
GOVERNMENT AND FINANCE.
AFTERWARDS BUT AND SO- MY
COMMENTS ARE JUST REALLY
CONSISTENT WITH THE CONCERNS I
HAVE AND THAT WILL BE LOOKING AT
IN THE M. IN THE COMMITTEE IS
THAT- I WHILE I AGREE WITH THAT
WITH A SENATOR SKINNER SAID.
SAID ABOUT IT CAN'T MIGHT BE
APPROPRIATE OR DEPENDING ON THE
CONFIGURATION OF THE I THINK THE
CHALLENGE HERE IS. DOES IT.
DOESN'T WORK IN A IN A AND EVERY
COMMUNITY AND- AND I HAVE SOME
REAL PROBLEMS WITH THAT TWO
STORY. AND IF THIS IS NOT ABOUT
ARE WE GOING TO BE ALLOWING.
MORE UNITS THIS IS ABOUT WHAT
THE UNITS WILL LOOK LIKE AND HOW
IT WILL IMPACT. NEIGHBORS IN THE
NEIGHBORHOODS AND- SO I THINK
THAT CITIES AND COUNTIES CAN
ALREADY. THROUGH THEIR ORDINANCE
ALLOW. EIGHTY USED TO GO UP TO
TWO STORY- AND SO I'M NOT SURE
THAT WE REALLY NEED TO HAVE A
BILL THAT SAYS YOU HAVE TO ALLOW
IT BY RIGHT AND THAT'S REALLY
WHERE I'M OUT OF THE PARKING AND
ALL THAT IF YOU. I'M OKAY WITH
BUT- BUT THE- IT'S A SAID IT'S
THE TWO STORIES AND IN MANY
COMMUNITIES. THAT HAVE SITE
VIEWS THAT ARE PROTECTED VIEW
SHEDS THAT ARE PROTECTED THIS
BECOMES A PROBLEM AS WELL. AND
I'M- SO WE'LL BE LOOKING AT THIS
IN IN IN THE SECOND COMMITTEE
AND RIGHT NOW I'D I I'D LIKE TO-
JUST INSANE IF YOU NEED TO VOTE
TOGETHER. TO GET IT OUT I WON'T
I WON'T STAND OUT ABOUT IN
SUPPORT WITH THE UNDERSTANDING
THAT- THAT IT IS COMING TO
SECOND COMMITTEE AND WE'RE WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO SIT DOWN AND-
ARM WRESTLE OVER IT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU CENTER
CABALLERO. SO NO ACTING UNSPOKEN
SO IF NO OTHER COMMENTS. SERVER
MY VOICE- SO FIRST OF ALL-
ASSEMBLY FORGET TO THIS BILL
THAT I UNDERSTOOD IN TERMS OF
THAT HE CHOICE COLLISIONS GOES
WELL BEYOND THE SPELL. I'VE BEEN
FORCED TO PUT A TWO EXCLUSIONS
IN MY BILLS BECAUSE WHAT I THINK
OF THAT REFLECT POLITICS. AROUND
HOAS I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD
HAVE I DON'T THINK HOAS OR ANY
COMMUNITY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
EXEMPT ITSELF FROM STATE HOUSING
LAW BY BYTES OF THROUGH A-
PRIVATE CONTRACT IMAGINE THAT
YOU CAN CONTRACTOR WAY OUT OF
COMPLYING. WITH STATE HOUSING
LAW BY PUTTING TOGETHER SINCE
YOU SEE IN OUR DOCUMENTS. IT IS
WHEN YOU LOOK WHAT HATE STATE
HOUSING LAW DOES IT IS ABOUT.
THROUGH THE- NEXT THE SUPPLY OF
HOUSING IT IS ABOUT- AND YOU'RE
MOVING AWAY FROM EXCLUSION AND
SEGREGATION. AND WE ALLOW HOAS
TO EXEMPT THEMSELVES. THAT IS.
THAT EXACERBATES SEGREGATION AND
EXCLUSION. TO ME BUT THAT ISSUE
IS REALLY NOT. SORRY BEFORE US
TODAY I'M GOOD SOMEWHERE IN SOME
WATER PLEASE. AND DOT I'M HOPING
THAT AT SOME POINT- WE WILL- BE
ABLE TO. TACKLE THAT ISSUE
PUTTING THAT ASIDE ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK-RESOURCES. THANK YOU MADAM
ESTHER. ON THIS BILL I REALLY
WANNA- THANK THE AUTHOR FOR.
PERSISTENTLY EVEN BEFORE I WAS A
SENATOR ON OVER ONE YOUR FIRST
EIGHTY YOU BILLS WHEN I WAS AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WAS EXTREMELY
CONTROVERSIAL AND YOU'VE JUST
BEEN ADDED ADDED OUT OF WORKING
WITH SOME SKINNER AND SOMEONE OR
TENGAN SUMMER BLOOM- AND OTHERS
AND I'M VERY VERY APPRECIATIVE
FOR THAT WORK ON. EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY. LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAS
BEEN VERY VERY OPPOSED PEOPLE
DON'T WANT TO USE AT ALL- AND
NOW THAN PEOPLE THEY EMBRACE
DATA USING SAID THE DON'T PASS
ANY OTHER LAWS HAS LED US TO A
TO USE. BUT THEN WE HAVE THESE
CONTINUING RESTRICTIONS THAT
UNDERMINE EIGHTY YOU PRODUCTION
LIKE PARKING LIKE SOME OF THE
HEIGHT. RESTRICTIONS AND SO I'M
VERY APPRECIATIVE THAT YOU COME
FORWARD WITH THE BILL- TO TRY TO
MOVE AWAY FROM SOME OF THESE
RESTRICTIONS. ON UNDERSTANDING
THE BIG PICTURE HERE I
UNDERSTAND I LIVE IN A
NEIGHBORHOOD TO MY NEIGHBORS
HAVE OPINIONS AS WELL WE ALL
HAVE A ROOM AS OPINIONS WITH A
NEIGHBOR WE ALL OF OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS- BUT WE DO HAVE
THIS MULTI MILLION HOME
SHORTAGE. THAT IS THAT IS WORSE
NOW THAN IT WAS BEFORE C THAT
IN TERMS OF THE COST OF HOUSING.
WE SEE A SPIKE IN INFECTIONS OF
LOW INCOME RENTERS. YOU KNOW
LET'S LOOK AT THE LOW INCOME
RENTERS WHO CONTINUED TO BECOME
HOMELESS WAVE AFTER WAVE OF LOW
INCOME RENTERS WHOSE OUR
HOUSING. AND BECOME HOMELESS AND
IF WE HAVE OPPORTUNITIES WITH
EIGHTY USE TO CREATE MORE
HOUSING A MORE POSSIBILITIES FOR
PEOPLE. AND IF WE HAVE A TWO
STORY. EIGHTY YOU. TRANSLATE TO
UNITS INSTEAD OF ONE- YEAH OR
HAS MORE SPACE FOR A FAMILY
THAT'S A GOOD THING AND SO WE
SHOULD ALLOW THIS KIND OF
FLEXIBILITY AND THAT'S WHY I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. I UNDERSTAND
THERE ARE CONCERNS ABOUT HEIGHTS
I'D CONSIDERED SUGGESTING AN
AMENDMENT TO SAY THAT YOU CAN'T
GO ABOVE WHATEVER THE
SURROUNDING HEIGHT LIMIT IS IF.
IF A CITY HAS A THIRTY FOOT.
HEIGHT LIMIT FOR SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES. A FIVE HIGH FOOT HIGH
LIMIT. FOR EIGHTY YOU STRIKES AS
REASONABLE. THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES ALREADY MADE THAT
DETERMINATION- BUT DOT- I THINK
WE WOULD LIKE FOR US TO DEAL
WITH THAT ALL TOGETHER- AND
THAT'S WHY I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATION EGGMAN FINANCE.
CENTER CABALLERO AND I WORK VERY
VERY CLOSELY. TOGETHER AND
THAT'S WHY WE SERVE ON EACH
OTHER'S COMMITTEES- AND SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION- AND MOVING.
FORWARD A STRONG BILL SOME
RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
BILL- WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR SKINNER AND SENATOR YOU
MAY CLOSE. I'LL TAKE YOUR
COMMENTS AS MY CLOTHES. IT HAS
YOU AND I BOTH. AGRE WITH THAT-
WE WILL CALL THE- THIS IS SENATE
BILL EIGHT NINETY SEVEN BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE. SENATOR
WIENER. FIVE WIENER HI CENTER
BATES NOPE. BATES NO CABALLERO.
WHERE DOES HE LIVE OR DOES HE HI
MCGUIRE. BUT SHOWBOAT I TROUBLED
BY SKINNER SKINNER HI NUMBER
WHAT KASKY. FIVE TWO ONE. THE
VOTE SURVIVED THE ONE THAT IS
ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT BUT
WE'LL PUT IT ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU CENTER LIKE
ASKING. OKAY WE'RE NOW GOING TO
GO BACK IN ORDER AND SENATOR HER
TADO THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AS- YOUR ORIGINALLY NUMBER ONE-
WILL CALL. ITEM NUMBER. ONE SB
EIGHT FORTY SEVEN. BY CENTER
HERZOG.
GOOD MORNING TO ADD THINK MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO
OFFER START BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS ON PAGE NINE OF THE
ANALYSIS I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
OUR OFFICE. AND MAKING SURE WE
PRIORITIZE OUR SMALL RENTAL
PROPERTY HOMEOWNERS IN THIS
BILL. R. AS OF JULY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE MORE THAN ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION HOMEOWNERS WERE
BEHIND ON THEIR MORTGAGES MANY
OF THESE HOMEOWNERS ON REAL UP
RENTAL PROPERTY. AND ONE FEDERAL
MORTGAGE FORBEARANCE ENDS THEY
MAY BE FORCED TO REMOVE THE
RENTAL UNITS FROM THE MARKET AND
SELL THEM IN ORDER TO AVOID
FORECLOSURE. SB EIGHT FOUR SEVEN
ESTABLISHES A GRANT PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT THAT ALLOWS FOR
DISTRIBUTION OF FUNDS TO
HOMEOWNERS APPLICANTS UPON
APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE. THE CALIFORNIA
MORTGAGE RELIEF PROGRAM USES
FEDERAL HOMEOWNER ASSISTANCE
FUNDS TO HELP HOME OWNERS GET
CAUGHT UP ON THEIR HOUSING
PAYMENTS BUT IT DOESN'T INCLUDE
HOMEOWNERS WHO HAVE RENTAL
PROPERTIES. UP WE DO HAVE
TENANTS IN CALIFORNIA OR BEHIND
ON THEIR- ON THE RANCH BUT WE
WILL NOT RECEIVE GOVERNMENT
ASSISTANCE BECAUSE WHAT THEY
MAKE FALLS JUST ABOVE THE
EXISTING THRESHOLD FOR THOSE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE FEDERAL
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. THIS LEAVES THE OWNERS
OF THEIR RENTAL PROPERTY WHO
SOMETIMES ARE STILL PAYING OFF
THE MORTGAGE. ON THE PROPERTY
STRUGGLING THEMSELVES SB EIGHT
FOUR SEVEN CLOSES A GAP FOR
TENANTS AND HOMEOWNERS WHO HAVE
APPLIED AND BEEN REJECTED FROM
STATE RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
IN TRINIDAD A RENTAL UNIT STAY
IN THE MARKET AND PEOPLE DO NOT
LOSE THE ROOFS OVER THEIR HEADS.
I HAVE THREE WITNESSES HERE WITH
ME TODAY JOINING US IN THIS
ROOM. THE FIRST WITNESS ANITA
EARL SHE'S A SMALL RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNER I HAVE MICHAEL
HAGERTY- SMALL PROPERTY
HOMEOWNER AS WELL. AND I ALSO
HAVE A DEBRA CARLTON WHO IS WITH
THE APARTMENT ASSOCIATION HERE
FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. THANK
YOU SENATOR- HER TADO NEEDED
EXCEPT THE AMENDMENTS CORRECT
YESTERDAY GREAT- OKAY WE WILL
START WITH- ARE YOU IN NEED A
GIRLS I AM GREAT. WELCOME GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS. MY NAME'S
ANITA IRWIN I OWN A HOME IN
SACRAMENTO. CURRENTLY I'M LOSING
MY HOME BECAUSE I HAD A PERSON
LIVING IN THE HOME SINCE TWENTY
NINETEEN RENT FREE. THE WELL
MEANING PANDEMIC EVICTION
GAVE HER PROTECTION. THE RESULT
IS THAT SMALL PROPERTY OWNERS
LIKE MYSELF HAVE BEEN
FINANCIALLY RUINED WITHOUT A
REMEDY. IF THE TENANT REFUSES TO
COOPERATE. I APPLIED FOR THE
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE
DOLLARS AS REQUIRED BY THE STATE
SHE DID NOT. WHEN I FINALLY HAVE
MY HOME BACK. I FOUND THAT THE
TENET HAD DID THAT DAMAGE IT
BEYOND MY FINANCIAL ABILITY TO
REPAIR IT. I FOUND ELECTRICAL
RECEPTACLES AND SMOKE DETECTORS
PULLED FROM THE WALLS. ALL
CEILING FIXTURES WERE DESTROYED.
ALL OF THE WALLS AND DOORS HAD
HOLES IN THEM. THE HARDWOOD
FLOORS HAD BEEN INTENTIONALLY
LOCAL FROM BEING INTENTIONALLY
FLOODED. MY DRIVER WAS MISSING
STILL DESTROY DEBRIS ALL OVER
THE PROPERTY INCLUDING TWO
ABANDONED VEHICLES THAT RESULTED
IN THE PROPERTY BEING CONDEMNED.
AFTER SHE FILED A COMPLAINT WITH
THE CITY. THE ESTIMATE TO REPAIR
MY HOME IS FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS I DO NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PAY FOR IT SO IT'LL
HAVE TO BE SOLD AT A TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR LOSS. ALL OF
THIS BREAKS MY HEART BECAUSE THE
NINETEEN FIFTY NINE MY
GRANDMOTHER ALONG WITH MY MOTHER
HER DAUGHTER. TRAVELED VIA
GREYHOUND TO BUY THAT HOUSE AND
IT'S BEEN IN OUR FAMILY EVERY
SENSE. LITTLE DID I KNOW IF WE
I'M SORRY. THAT IT WOULD END
LIKE THIS. LANDLORDS WERE ASKED
NOT TO MAKE PEOPLE HOMELESS
DURING A GLOBAL CRISES AND WE
DID NOT WE'RE ASKING IN RETURN
THAT WE NOT BE BANKRUPTED
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T. SO TODAY
MEMBERS I'M ASKING FOR YOUR I
PULLED. IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY- OKAY WILL
NOW GO TO- MICHAEL HAGERTY. WHO
IS ALSO HERE WITH US TODAY
WELCOME. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME MICHAEL
HAGGERTY I LIVE IN A MOBILE HOME
PARK IN SENATOR MCGUIRE'S
DISTRICT I'M RETIRED I OWN JUST
ONE RENTAL UNIT. REFILL WHICH
HELPS WITH MY RETIREMENT
UNFORTUNATELY AFTER THE PANDEMIC
BEGAN MY TENANTS STOP PAYING ME
RENT TO DATE HE OWES ME FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN BACKGROUND.
HE WAS DENIED FUNDING FROM THE
RENT RELIEF PROGRAM BECAUSE HE
MAKES TOO MUCH MONEY TENET IS
AND HAS BEEN EMPLOYED. BECAUSE
THE UNIT IS SITUATED ALAMEDA
COUNTY LAW PROHIBITS ME AND ALL
OWNERS IN ALAMEDA COUNTY FROM
EVICTING A TENANT EVEN THOUGH
THEY'RE CHEATING AND CLAIMING A
COVERT HARDSHIP FOR REFUSING TO
PAY THE RENT. BECAUSE THE
GENERAL WAS DENIED RENTAL
ASSISTANCE ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
FUNDING FROM THE STATE OR LOCAL
RELIEF PROGRAM. I'VE HAD TO
BORROW MONEY FROM MY IRA TO PAY
THE MORTGAGE AND TAXES ON THE
PROPERTY. I WON'T BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN THIS
PROPERTY OF MY TENANT IS ALLOWED
TO LIVE RENT FREE. I WON'T BE
ABLE TO SELL THE UNIT WITH THE
TENANT IN PLACE AND THE
POTENTIAL IS FORECLOSURE IF I
CAN'T PAY THE MORTGAGE. BECAUSE
STATE LAW ALLOWED TENANTS TO
SELF CERTIFY EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE
NOT TRUTHFUL MANY OWNERS IN THE
STATE ARE FACING THE SAME
SITUATION AS I AM. CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO INVEST IN NEW HOUSING
ALSO. AND I SUPPORT BILLS LIKE
SENATOR WIENER'S HIGHER DENSITY
PROPOSALS IN FACT I'VE WRITTEN
SEVERAL OP BEDS- IN SUPPORT OF
YOUR EFFORTS. BUT LANDLORDS AND
DEVELOPERS WILL NOT INVEST IN
NEW RENTAL HOUSING IF WERE
DENIED TWO YEARS OF BACKGROUND
WITHOUT RECOURSE. SB EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN DESERVE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
AN ENORMOUS CARLTON'S HERE FOR
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ON DO WE
HAVE ANY- SUPPORT FOR S. B.
EIGHT FORTY SEVEN PHYSICALLY
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM SO
PLEASE COME FORWARD. AND PLEASE
I STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION IF ANY ON THE FACT
OF YOUR SUPPORT. HIS CHAIR THANK
YOU- CHRIS WYSOCKI WITH WMA WE
DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION
ON THIS BILL BUT WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE EFFORTS THAT
THE AUTHOR IS GOING THROUGH. AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OF PUBLIC
COMMENTS HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. THE THING NINE WE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES ARE WILL THE
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY
SUPPORT PRESS BE. EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN. MISTER MODERATOR. OKAY I
AM BEING TOLD WE NEED TO- PAUSE
FOR A MOMENT- JUST BEAR WITH US
PLEASE. I THINK WE HAVE A AT&T
PROBLEM AGAIN. OKAY WE CAN HEAR
YOU NOW NOT NOT WELL I'M SORRY
CAN YOU CAN YOU YOU CAN'T HEAR
ME WELL. YES WE'RE HAVING
COMPLAINTS FROM THE ARTIST BUT.
WHO IS IT YOU ARE BACKED UP AND
- OKAY I MISTER MODERATOR I'M
BEING TOLD THAT WE NEED TO
RESTART THE EIGHTEEN TEAM LINE
SO THAT SO. ABSOLUTELY HOW DID
CONNECT QUICKLY CALL YOU RIGHT
BACK OKAY. THANK YOU THEY WERE
DOING A VERY BRIEF RECESS MMHM
ONE MOMENT. NOT ENOUGH HELP TO
BE.
MISTER MODERATOR MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES I
CAN HEAR YOU NOW THANK YOU OKAY
PLACE YOU BACK. OKAY SO WE'RE
READY TO GO. OKAY ARE RECESSES
OVER- YOU ARE BACK IN THE MAIN
ROOM OKAY THANK YOU- I
APPRECIATED ACTUALLY WHEN WE
KNOW AN EXPLANATION FROM
EIGHTEEN T. ABOUT WHY THIS KEEPS
HAPPENING BECAUSE IT REALLY
SENATE SOME. YEAH OKAY I'M GREAT
THANK YOU- WE ARE BACK- FROM A
RECESS AND OUR TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES- AND WE'RE NOW
GOING TO GO TO THE PHONE LINES
MISTER MODERATOR COULD YOU
PLEASE QUEUE UP- ANY- TELEPHONIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF A SPEED
FORTY SEVEN. YES THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN THE PHONE
LINES IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY ON S. T. EIGHT FOUR
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHEN
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE WILL
BEGIN WITH ONE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SIXTY FIVE YOU ARE
OPEN. YES I WAS INTERESTED IN
COMMENTING ON SB EIGHT SIX NINE.
AND YOU'RE NOT THERE YET THAT'S
CORRECT THAT'S THAT'LL BE AFTER
THIS ONE. OKAY I WILL RECALL IT
THAT ALL RIGHT YES THANK YOU.
THANK YOUNG. REMINDER PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY TWO ZERO
AT THIS TIME IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR- AB
EIGHT FOUR SEVEN ONLINE EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE CAN I THINK
YOU TOOK YOURSELF OUT IF YOU
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AGAIN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY. AND
YOU ARE NOW OPEN. SURE HI YES
SIR GOOD MORNING ERIC MEMBERS
GREEN GRIEF NOW THEY HAVE TO
CALIFORNIA'S OF REALTORS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. KNOW WHETHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR OKAY THANK YOU
WILL NOW- GO TO ANY OPPOSITION
THE SPD FORTY SEVEN WE HAVE NO-
OPPOSITION REGISTERED SO I'LL
ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL. SEEING NONE MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE DO YOU
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION. TO SB FORTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU AS MR CARE SAID
THAT YOU'D LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO HOW
TIME OPPOSITION. NOT SUPPORT
OPPOSITION THANK YOU OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME PROPOSITION. MISTER CHAIR
NOBODY IS GOING UP. OKAY GREAT
WILL BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ABOUT THIS BILL. OKAY
YEAH SEEING NONE- TO HAVE A
MOTION- MOTION BY SENATOR BATES-
SO I WANT TO THANK GOD- THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD FOR WORKING WITH US- IN
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE WORKED
OUT WITH THE AUTHOR HAS ACCEPTED
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
PRIORITIZING AND WHICH THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE CENTER ON
BURKE AND I. WORK TOGETHER ON
THIS ONE MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
PRIORITIZING OUR SMALL- MOM AND
POP LANDLORDS IF THEY GO TO THE
FRONT OF THE LINE OBVIOUSLY THIS
IS ULTIMATELY A BUDGET ISSUE IN
TERMS OF MAKE SURE THE FUNDING
IS THERE- AND AS WITH MOST
THINGS BUDGET FUNDING IS NEVER
INTERNET AS MUCH AS WE WOULD
WANT TO BE. AND SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT ARE SMALLER
LANDLORDS WHO WERE THE ONES WHO
WERE THE LEAST LIKELY TO BE ABLE
TO SUSTAIN ITS LOSSES. ARE AT
THE FRONT OF THE LINE AND WE'RE
NOT PRIORITIZING OUR LARGE
CORPORATE LANDLORDS- AND SO
WE'VE- PUT AND AMENDMENTS ARE
PRIORITIZING THOSE SMALLER
INDIVIDUAL LANDLORDS AS WELL AS-
PRIORITIZING OF PEOPLE WHO WERE-
CLAIMING UP TO A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS I AM LOSSES SO
I THINK THIS REALLY FOCUSES THE
BILL AND I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR- WORKING WITH US AND
ACCEPTING THOSE AMENDMENTS- AND
SO I AM NOT RECOMMENDING AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS BILL. AND CENTER
TADI MAKE CLOTHES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO THANK THE
WITNESSES HERE TODAY FOR-
SHARING THEIR STORY AS I'VE
ALWAYS SAID DURING THIS
PANDEMIC- IT'S CALIFORNIA IT'S
NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL AND
EVERY INDIVIDUAL ACROSS THE
STATE HAS THEIR OWN PERSONAL
STORY TO SHARE THAT- IN ON HOW
THE- COVERT NINETEEN PAN.
BECAUSE THEM PERSONALLY AND- I
THINK THAT THIS IS IT AT. GREAT
BUILT HELP MUCH NEEDED
INDIVIDUALS AT THAT DISTANCE THE
SUPPORT DURING THIS TIME AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BOAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR BATES AND-
CONSULTANT WILL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS SENATE BILL EIGHT
FORTY SEVEN BY SENATOR HER TADO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
SENATOR WIENER AYE WIENER AYE
BATES. BATES HI CABALLERO.
CABALLERO HI PARTISI OKAY
PORTELLI I REQUIRE. BUT CHAU
BOOK I A CHOI BOGUE HI SKINNER.
SKINNER HI I'M BURKE WE CASKEY.
HI WE CASKEY BY. SEVEN AND A
SEVEN VOTES WHICH IS ENOUGH BUT
WE WILL PUT IT ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS OF THE CAN OUT ON
THEIR VOTES LATER THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR COMING TODAY- WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM NUMBERS
TO- WHICH IS SB EIGHT SIXTY NINE
BY SENATOR LEAVE US CENTER THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE- AND YOU
MAY- PRESENT YOUR BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I WORE FLAT SO I'M
A LITTLE CLOSER TO THE
MICROPHONE TODAY- WHEN I FEEL
LIKE YOU I HAVE HERE YOU
UNDERSTAND I DID REGISTER IN A
FORMAL COMPLAINT ABOUT THE
HEIGHT OF THE LECTERN MUCH
APPRECIATED ALL RIGHT GOOD
MORNING- MEMBERS I THANK OU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT- MY
BILL. I AM VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THIS BILL I LOVE THIS BILL
REGARDLESS OF HOW YOU FEEL ABOUT
THE BILL WE CAN ALL AGREE ON ONE
THING TRAINING IS IMPORTANT. NO
MATTER WHAT YOU DO. I WOULD
FIRST TO THANK MISTER CHAIR OF
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL OF
YOUR HELP AND WORK ON THIS BILL.
I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
REFLECTED IN THE BILL ANALYSIS.
AS MANY OF YOU ARE AWARE I HAVE
BEEN THE CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON MOBILE AND
MANUFACTURED HOMES. MY EIGHT
YEAR. IN THAT POSITION I HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO SEE FIRSTHAND MANY
OF THE ISSUES THAT IMPACT THESE
COMMUNITIES. THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED AND
NINETEEN THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY TWO MOBILE HOMES OR
MANUFACTURED HOMES IN
CALIFORNIA. WHICH ACCOUNT FOR
THREE POINT 8% OF TOTAL HOUSING
STOCK AND EQUALING ROUGHLY ONE
POINT MILLION ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION RESIDENTS IN THE STATE.
SENATOR WIENER. FOR PARKS WAS
SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ONE
SPACES- US SENATOR BATES YOU
HAVE SIXTY SIX PARKS WITH EIGHT
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY
EIGHT. THE SENATOR CABALLERO YOU
HAVE A HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE
PARKS WITH EIGHT THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE SPACES.
SENATOR CORTESE IS NOT HERE SAN
REQUIRES NOT HERE ALL THE SENATE
REQUIRED REQUIRED AS WHEN. HE
HAS FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
PARKS WITH 280-002-0013 SPACES.
ZERO TOWBOAT HAS TWO HUNDRED
NINETEEN PARKS WITH TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED AND
TWENTY EIGHT. RESIDENTS CENTER
SKINNER HAS TWENTY TWO PARKS
WITH SIXTEEN HUNDRED ANDSEVENTY
ONE SPACES. AND CENTER RIGHT
KELSEY YOU HAVE FIFTY TWO PARKS
WITH SEVEN THOUSAND. NINE
HUNDRED AND NINETY RESIDENTS I
WAS ALWAYS LIKE TO REMIND PEOPLE
BECAUSE SOMETIMES PEOPLE FORGET
THAT THEY HAVE. MOBILE HOME
PARKS IN THEIR DISTRICT WE HAVE
MEANT TOO MANY OF THEM. NEARLY
HALF OF THESE HOMES ARE
AFFORDABLE TO VERY LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. AND SERVE AS A
SIGNIFICANT SOURCE OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. IN OUR STATE THAT WE
KNOW HAS A DEFINITE ONGOING NEED
FOR HOUSING. THAT IS AFFORDABLE.
MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS MANY OF
WHOM ARE SENIORS. RELY ON
EFFECTIVE MANAGEMENT OF THE
MOBILE HOME PARK TO ENSURE THAT
THEIR HOUSING IS SAFE. AND MEETS
APPROPRIATE QUALITY STANDARDS.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA HAS NO
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE TRAINING OR
EDUCATION OF MOBILE HOME PARK
MANAGERS. IN MANY INSTANCES THE
PARK MANAGER MAY BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE SAFETY. OF OVER TWO
HUNDRED RESIDENTS AND SOMETIMES
IN REMOTE LOCATIONS OF THE
STATE. ONGOING VIOLATIONS. OF
THE LAW THAT GENERALLY STEM FROM
THE LACK OF SUFFICIENT
UNDERSTANDING BY PARK MANAGERS
OF THE MOBILE HOME RESIDENCY LAW
WE COMMONLY REFER TO IT AS THE%
BIBLE. AND THE COMPLEX OVERLY OF
OTHER LAWS ANDREGULATIONS. THIS
LACK OF TRAINING HAS LED TO
SITUATIONS OF UNLAWFUL
EVICTIONS. IMPROPER FEES. AND
INVOICES DISCRIMINATION AND POOR
MAINTENANCE WHICH GREATLY
AFFECTS THE QUALITY OF LIFE THE
MOBILE HOME PARKS. WE ON TEAM
LEYVA HAVE WITNESSED THINGS LIKE
TYPHUS OUTBREAKS AND THAT WAS
BECAUSE THE BULK OF THE MANAGER. DID NOT KNOW
THAT THE. ONE HUNDRED FERAL CATS
AT THE MOBILE HOME PARK HAD
FLEAS AND THE POLICE COULD
TRANSMIT TYPHUS THEY DID NOT
KNOW WHO TO CALL OR WHAT TO DO
IN THAT SITUATION. SO THEY
CALLED US TRAINING WOULD HAVE
HELPED. SUPER SEWAGE OVERFLOWING
AT THESE PARKS ON A REGULAR
BASIS PARK MANAGERS DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO AND THEY'VE CALLED
OUR OFFICE. ELECTRICAL WIRES
THAT ARE WRAPPED AROUND AND
TAPED TO TREES AND BECAUSE
MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS TO
ACTUALLY HAVE BURST OF
ELECTRICITY AND BURN OUT ALL OF
THEIR ELECTRIC. APPLIANCES AGAIN
THE PARK MANAGER HAD NO IDEA
WHAT TO DO. ARE WE HAD ONE PLACE
WHERE THE PARK MANAGER DID NOT
KNOW THAT HE ACTUALLY HAD TO
PROVIDE A SPACE FOR THE
RESIDENTS TO HAVE THEIR MAIL
DELIVERED BY THE POST PERSON. SO
S. B. EIGHT SIXTY NINE. WOULD
REQUIRE MOBILE HOME PARK
MANAGERS TO BE TRAINED AND
CERTIFIED ON THE MOBILE HOME
RULES AND REGULATIONS OF
MANAGING A MOBILE HOME PARK. AND
MANUFACTURED HOME COMMUNITIES I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO SAY
THIS BILL IS ACTUALLY ASKING FOR
CERTIFICATION WE'RE NOT
REQUIRING LICENSURE. I WOULD
LOVE TO HAVE THESE MOBILE HOME
PARK MANAGERS LICENSED. HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT H. C.
D. IN CONSULTATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
DEVELOPING THE TRAINING AND OF
FORCING THE CERTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS. OTHER STATES SUCH
AS OREGON AND NEVADA ALREADY
MANDATE SIMILAR TRAINING AND
LICENSING IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY. OF RESIDENTS
LIVING IN MOBILE HOME PARKS. AND
IT IS CERTAINLY TIME FOR US TO
FOLLOW SUIT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH ME TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT IS
BRUCE STANTON WITH THE GOLDEN
STATE MANUFACTURED HOME OWNERS
LEAGUE MEMBERS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
AND CENTER AYE AYE MAYBE I MIGHT
HAVE MISSED IT BUT IN TERMS OF
THE COMMITTEES AMEND YOUR
ACCEPTED THAT OKAY MY APOLOGIES
NOT A WORRY- OKAY WE WILL NOW GO
TO AND DOES HE REMOTE. HIS
REMOTE YES HIS CALLING OKAY SO-
WILL NOT HEAR FROM MR STEP. YES
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BRUCE STANTON
KHALKHAL CREEK YES- WELL IN
SUPPORT OF CAN YOU HEAR ME OK WE
CAN'T S. YOU SOMETHING ON THE
FOUR LINES. THE MOBILE OF
RESIDENCY LAW IS A WAY OF LOCAL
CONSUMER PROTECTION STATUTE
WHICH GOVERNS THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN OKLAHOMA RESIDENTS IN
OUR MANAGEMENT EXISTING SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT AND IF
THEY EXPANDED DURING THE LAST
FORTY YEARS TO INCLUDE OVER
NINETY DETAILED SUBSECTIONS.
COVERING ALL ASPECTS OF MOBILE
OF HANNITY'S THE SENATE SELECT
COMMITTEES ARE ALL PUBLICATION
WELL IT CAN'T THIRTY FOUR PAGES
OF STATUTORY TAX AND THERE ARE
MANY OTHER PROVISIONS OF LAWS
GOVERNING ALCOHOL PARKS IN BOTH
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE AND
TITLE TWENTY FIVE OF THE CODE OF
REGULATIONS. THE LAWS ARE
SPECIFIC THE MOBILE HOME PARKS
IT DIFFER GREATLY FROM LAWS
GOVERNING OTHER TYPES OF RENTAL
HOUSING AND ANYONE REALLY
PRESUMING TO COMPETENTLY MANAGE
YOUR MOBILE HOME PARK. SHOULD BE
WELL VERSED LAS. I UNLIKE
PROPERTY MANAGE. FOR TWO RENTERS
. MOBILE MANAGEMENT REQUIRE TO
UNDERGO TRAINING OR LICENSING
SURE THEY L. AND ACTORS YEAH EQT
CLAUSE. OR THAT THEY WILL
PROBABLY FOLLOW THEM SO AS TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
THEIR PARK RESIDENTS. AB AVERAGE
PARK DOES PROBABLY HAVE. OVER
TWO HUNDRED RESIDENTS WHERE
MANAGEMENT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
HEALTH AND SAFETY SO PARKS IT'S
OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED RESIDENTS.
J. ONE HUNDRED HIGH OF
COMPLAINTS OVER MANY YEARS BURKE
PARK MANAGEMENT EITHER DOESN'T
KNOW THE APPLICABLE LAWS THAT
CARE. WHETHER THEY'RE FOLLOWER
SIMPLY FLAUNTS THEM AND SOMEONE
EDUCATED MANAGERS USE YOUR
RELEVANT APARTMENT MARKET
PROCEDURES. OTHERS PROFESS TO
KNOW THE LAWS IF WE DON'T FOLLOW
THEM. IN ONE CASE MANAGEMENT
THAT IT LETTER TO THEIR
RESIDENCE STATING QUOTE IF YOU
CHOOSE TO NOT FOLLOW. THE RULES
AND REGULATIONS WE WILL EFFECT
DUMB **** OF QUOTES. THIS TYPE
OF CONDUCT REALLY REFLECTS THE
TOTAL LACK TRAINING IS A FEW
SEVEN REQUIRES IMMEDIATE
ATTENTION OF POLICYMAKERS. WE
EXTENDED WAIVER FOR. OR ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- WE WILL NOW GO.
SO IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC TESTIMONY HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM IN SUPPORT. SEE NOW
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES OF A
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY
SUPPORTIVE TESTIMONY AGAINST
PLEASE JUST STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION IF ANY AND THE FACT
OF YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
ZERO TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND
MISTER CHAIR WILL GO TO ONE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWENTY SIX YOU TOOK YOURSELF
ARGUE THESE PRESS ONE ZERO AGAIN
. YOU ARE BACK PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH MY NAME IS ROGER JOHNSON. I
AM A MOBILE HOMEOWNER IN
LAKEVIEW VILLAGE IN CITRUS
HEIGHTS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO LINE SEVENTY FIVE
YOU ARE OPEN. YES MY NAME IS
BRENDA FOR AND I AM INVESTED DEL
MOTE MOBILE HOME PARK AND
BANGOR AND I AM IN SUPPORT FOR
THE FOR SB. EIGHT SIX NINE.
LIVING ONLINE AB PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MICHELLE MONNING ADAM I AM
A MOBILE HOME OWNER AND I'M IN
CASE STATES IN ROSEVILLE IN
SUPPORT. LINE EIGHTY THREE YOU
ARE OPEN. EIGHTY THREE PLEASE ON
YOU. MY NAME IS MARLEY HACKETT.
AM I LIVING WITH HIM BRIDGE A
STATE CORNING AND I AM IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS TIM
SHEERAN I'M A HOMEOWNER AT
SPRINGDALE ESTATES MOBILE HOME
PARK IN SAN MARCOS AND I AM ALSO
IN SUPPORT. ONE EIGHTY SIX YOU
HAVE BEFORE. GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS MADELINE COOPER FROM
NELSON MARC MARK ON BEHALF OF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOUNG. THE FINAL REMINDER
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
ONE MOMENT WE HAVE A COUPLE
QUEUEING UP. ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS JEANNIE LOMBARDO I LIVE
IN CREEKSIDE MOBILE HOME
COMMUNITY IN SAN LUIS OBISPO AND
I'M STRONGLY IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU LINE EIGHTY ONE OF PLEASE GO
AHEAD- EXCUSE YES EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EIGHTY ONE
REASON YOU. YES MY NAME IS JULIE
AND I'M SURE S. H. E. A. R. I
LIVE IN THE NO SORRENTO SENIOR
MOBILE HOME PARK IN MARINO
VALLEY AND I AM IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE ADJUSTED
THE QUEUE. GREAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH WILL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION
WE HAVE NO- FORMAL OR LEAD
WITNESS IDENTIFIED IF THERE'S
SOMEONE WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY AS
THE LEAD WITNESS- ARE WE WILL BE
WITH US AT I BELIEVE SO OKAY
WILL THERE BE ANY OTHER LEAD
WITNESSES OR TO. MISTER SMITH
OKAY THEN YOU'LL EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES OKAY I THANK MAY TAKE
TWO THIRTY OKAY THEN THAT MEANS
YOU'RE EATING INTO HI I'M ROB
WHICH IS ALL GOOD SO AND MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS SAYS SENATOR-
CHRIS WYSOCKI- WMA. AND WE
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH A- SB
EIGHT SIX NINE WMA RT HAS A
TRAINING PROGRAM IN PLACE THAT
ALLOWS MEMBERS AND NON MEMBERS
ALIKE TO PARTICIPATE IN WE'VE
SUCCESSFULLY OPERATED. THIS
PROGRAM FOR OVER A DECADE. S.
EIGHT SIX NINE IS TRYING BUILD
AN ENTIRE TRAINING PROGRAM.
BUILT ON DATA FROM AND OVER
THREE AND A HALF YEAR OLD
PROGRAM TO ALLOW RESIDENTS TO
COMPLAIN TO THE STATE. AND THEN
THE STATE TAKES ACTION. ON MARCH
ELEVENTH OF THIS YEAR. HCV
RELEASED THEIR ANNUAL EMERALD PP
REPORT THAT CLEARLY SHOWS
EXISTING RULES AND REGULATIONS
ARE ALREADY WORKING. AT OF SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND RESIDENTS HCV
PROCESSED LAST YEAR SIXTEEN
HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT COMPLAINTS
OF THOSE ONLY THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY NINE WERE FOUND TO HAVE
SOME SUBSTANCE AND OF THOSE TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY WERE REFERRED
TO ANOTHER AGENCY DECIDES EIGHT
CD. ONLY SEVENTEEN COMPLAINTS
WERE REFERRED TO A LEGAL
SERVICES PROVIDER. THAT'S OUT OF
THE ENTIRE NUMBER OF CASES FILED
. MEETING A NEW PROGRAM UNDER
EACH CD WHICH IS ALREADY
OVERWORKED UNDERSTAFFED IN BASED
ON THE ISSUES SURROUNDING
SEVENTEEN COMPLAINTS DOESN'T
SEEM TO MAKE A LOT OF SENSE.
SHOULDN'T WE ENCOURAGE MORE
HOUSING STOCK IN INCENTIVIZE
MORE HOMEOWNERS TO DO THE RIGHT
THING. HCB CURRENTLY HAS FEWER
THAN FIFTY INSPECTORS STATEWIDE
TO CONTROL FIFTY FOUR. FORTY
FIVE HUNDRED MOBILE HOME PARKS.
THE AUTHORS STATED CASES IN
OREGON AND NEVADA THOSE EXAMPLES
OREGON AND NEVADA REQUIRE FOUR
HOURS OF TRAINING OVER TWO YEARS
THIS BILL REQUIRES EIGHTEEN
HOURS ON THE FIRST YEAR IN AN
UNDISCLOSED NUMBER OF HOURS TO
IN SUBSEQUENT YEARS THAT'S TWO
AND A HALF DAYS OF TRAINING.
WHO'S GONNA TAKE CARE THE PARTS
WHEN THEY'RE OUT TRAINING. THIS
BILL ONLY ALLOWS EACH CD THE
OFFER THAT TRAINING. OREGON
NEVADA ALLOWS THE REALTORS. THE
MOBILE HOME PARK ASSOCIATION OR
THE STATE TO OFFER THE TRAINING
. THE DATA SHOWS THAT MORE M. O.
R. P. P. PROGRAM IS WORKING. WE
ALSO NOTICED IN THIS BILL THAT A
THIRD OF THE PARKS IN THE STATE
AREN'T EVEN COVERED UNDER THE
BILL BECAUSE IF YOU'RE UNDER
FORTY UNITS. YOU DON'T HAVE TO
HAVE AN ONSITE ONSITE PERSON. SO
HAVE THESE REASONS AND OTHER
REASONS LISTED IN OUR LETTER WE
OPPOSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- YOU'RE A MINUTE FIFTEEN NO
PROBLEM MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
TRANSMETA BE AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA MOBILE HOME PARK
OWNERS ALLIANCE WE ARE ALSO
OPPOSE FOR MANY OTHER REASONS
PUT FORWARD BY MY COLLEAGUE AT
W. I MAY. THE ONLY THING I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO ADD AND I THINK IT
BECAME EVIDENT WITH MISTER WHAT
KOWSKI IS BILL WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE NEIGHBORS-
ESPECIALLY IN MOBILE HOME PARK
WHO LIVE IN CLOSE PROXIMITY
THERE ARE BOUND TO BE DISPUTES
AND AS A MANAGER YOUR THE
REFEREE. AND SO YOU'RE ALWAYS
GOING TO MAKE ONE PARTY UNHAPPY
ONE NEIGHBOR COMPLAINS ABOUT THE
OTHER NOT DOING SOMETHING YOU
TAKE ACTION YOU'RE MAKING OUT
ONE NEIGHBOR UNHAPPY M. THESE
ARE THE TYPES OF DISPUTES THAT
OFTEN ARISE AND LEAD TO
COMPLAINTS THAT MAY BE THE
MOBILE HOME SELECT COMMITTEE
RECEIVED BUT AS YOU'VE HEARD BY
FROM THE STATISTICS THAT HAVE
BEEN PUT FORWARD. FROM EIGHT C.
D. MOST OF THEM DO NOT RISE TO
THE LEVEL- THAT THEY NEED
ENFORCEMENT ACTION AND WE THINK
THERE FOR THIS PROGRAM IS ON
WARRANTED I NEEDED. THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH IS THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. OKAY SING NOW WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES OF THE MODERATOR
PLEASE QUEUE UP. ANY OPPONENTS
TO S. B. EIGHT SIXTY NINE AND A
AND PLEASE SAY YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION IF ANY AND THE FACT
OF YOUR OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO. SB
EIGHT SIX NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO. SB
EIGHT SIX NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. MISTER CHAIR NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP. OKAY ARE GREAT WE
WILL NUMBER. TO ME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES ANY
LIKE CAL SKI YEAH MISTER CHAIR
OF ON PAGE. SIX OF OUR REPORT AS
WE TALK ABOUT THIS IDEA OF
EIGHTEEN HOURS FOUR HOURS WHAT
STATES DO THE TALK ABOUT THE TV
NOW PROVIDES OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSES JUST WITH THE BUSINESS
TRANSACTION POR PART. BUT IT
SUGGESTS THAT MOVING FORWARD YOU
MIGHT WANT TO CONSIDER MODELING
PARTS OF THE TRAINING. OFFER THE
OTHER STATES PROGRAMS INCLUDING
THE NUMBER OF HOURS TO STANDARDS
AND ALL THAT SO MY QUESTION IS
THAT IF YOU RUN AN APARTMENT
COMPLEX. IN YOUR A SITE MANAGER
DO WE HAVE ANY IDEA HOW MANY
HOURS OF TRAINING DAY TO AND
WHAT'S THAT CONTINUING
EDUCATION. THAT IS A GREAT
SERVER RIGHT KELSEY I HAVE NO
IDEA I'M THE CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON MOBILE MANUFACTURED
HOMES- I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY DO
IN APARTMENT COMPLEXES- SO I
DON'T KNOW OKAY JUST BECAUSE
THEY SORT OF DO THE SAME THING
OF MANAGE THERE MAY BE A
DIFFERENT. AREA OF LAW BUT SORT
OF WHAT THE WHAT THE WORLD IS-
THIS IDEA. WHEN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CHANGE THE BANKRUPTCY
LAWS YOU HAD TO DO COUNSELING A
LOT OF SMALL INDIVIDUAL PEOPLE
DID EDUCATION COUNSELING
FINANCIAL COUNSELING THE WORK TO
GET THEIR DISCHARGE IN
BANKRUPTCY. THE COURTS ALLOWED
PRIVATE ENTITIES- THERE'S A
BATCH OF THEM THAT DO WITH THAT
THAT. THEY SET THE STANDARDS IN
IN THESE OTHER FOLKS DO IT. THIS
BILL SAYS EVERYTHING'S IN HOUSE
WITH EIGHT C. D. ALTHOUGH OTHER
STATES DO THAT DO YOU SEE ANY
BENEFIT OF ALLOWING. INDEPENDENT
EDUCATION GROUPS TO DO THIS.
TRAINING AND CERTIFICATION THERE
COULD BE- WE CHOSE H. CD BECAUSE
IT'S THIS IS A CALIFORNIA LAW
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT- HAVE
DIRECT OVERSIGHT OF THE MOBILE
HOME PARKS SO IT SEEMS THAT THEY
WOULD BE THE ONES THAT KNOW
WHAT'S HAPPENING. I WOULD BE THE
RIGHT ENTITIES TO BE IN CHARGE
OF THIS COULD A PRIVATE ENTITY
DO IT. POSSIBLY I KNOW I'M
ALWAYS WORRIED ABOUT CREATING
LITTLE COTTAGE INDUSTRIES WERE
THEY MIGHT POP UP IN CHARGE A
DIFFERENT AMOUNT- THEY MAY NOT
BE- THEY MAY NOT BE IN TUNE TO
WHAT HCD IS DOING EXACTLY. SO I
THINK A CD IS THE APPROPRIATE
ORGANIZATION OR DON'T I MEAN
THEY THEY WOULD. SET THE
STANDARDS AND WHAT THE HELL
CANNOT BE BUT WHAT WE FOUND IS
THAT SOME PEOPLE HAVE LANGUAGE
ISSUE SOME PEOPLE ARE. PHYSICAL
LEARNERS ARE VISUAL LEARNERS
VERSUS SITTING ON THE COMPUTER
THERE'S A WHOLE BATCH OF THE
PEOPLE THAT THE WINTER SO BY.
CREATING A COTTAGE INDUSTRY
ALLOWING PEOPLE TO DO THAT YOU
GET THAT CERTIFICATE THAT YOU
WANT BUT YOU RESPOND TO. WHAT
THAT MANAGER IS DOING SO THOSE
ARE JUST MY COMMENTS I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THAT. IN THE HOURS AND-
POSITIONS YES. RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS CENTER JOGO- I DO I
BELIEVE THERE'S SOMEONE HERE
WITH FROM THE APARTMENT
INDUSTRY. THAT COULD ANSWER THAT
QUESTION THE POSSIBLE- SURE WE-
WE DON'T TYPICALLY HAVE BILL BUT
IT IS A QUESTION I'M JUST
CURIOUS BECAUSE I WAS ACTUALLY
ALSO THINKING ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT JUST SUPER COMPARISON.
REPRESENTING YOUR QUESTION
BASICALLY IS WHAT I'M TRYING I'M
JUST TRYING TO GET MORE
INFORMATION AS TO THE BALANCE OF
THE NUMBER OF HOURS REQUIRED AS
A REAL TORE WE HAVE- A NUMBER OF
HOURS THAT WE HAVE TO YOU WERE
MANDATED TO. TO HAVE CONTINUED
EDUCATION AND I BELIEVE OURS IS
FORTY FIVE HOURS OUT OVER THE
COURSE OF FOUR YEARS SO THAT'S
YOU KNOW THAT'S SO WHEN I LOOKED
AT WHEN I LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF
HOURS FOR THIS I THOUGHT
EIGHTEEN HOURS FOR THE FIRST
YEAR AND THEN UNSPECIFIED. MONEY
BORDER MAYBE A LITTLE- AN EASY
BUT WE FOR YOUR PERSON ANSWERS
LET ME JUST SAY THIS AGAIN IT'S
NOT ABOUT APARTMENT COMPLEXES
WERE TALKING ABOUT YES FOR A
MANUFACTURED HOME PARKS AS A
REALTOR I BELIEVE YOU WILL
PROBABLY HAVE A LITTLE MORE
TRAINING THAN A PARK MANAGER. OF
PARK RANGERS ARE USUALLY CHOSEN
LIKE THIS WHO WANTS TO VOLUNTEER
OKAY I CHOOSE YOU SO THESE FOLKS
DON'T HAVE ANY TRAINING SO
THAT'S WHY THERE'S A LITTLE BIT
MORE. THAT'S WHY THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT MORE IT THAT'S BEEN
MY EXPERIENCE MISTER GOVERNOR-
THAT IS BEEN WHY YOU WOULDN'T
MAYBE NEED TO DO EIGHTEEN HOURS
IN THE FIRST YEAR JUST LIKE BOB
AND I WERE TALKING AFTER- AFTER-
IS THAT- SESSION TODAY AND HE
WAS SAYING THAT AS A WAR YOU'LL
HAVE TO DO TWENTY FIVE WAS A
LAWYER WHEN HE WENT TO SCHOOL
FOR HOW MANY YEARS. SO YOU HAVE
A LOT OF BACKGROUND YEAH THERE
YOU GO PARK MANAGERS DON'T HAVE
ANY KIND OF A BACKGROUND SO THIS
IS WHY WE THINK THAT HOURS AN
HOUR AND A HALF A MONTH THEY
HAVE TO DO IT OVER HERE IS NOT
CUMBERSOME. AND THAT'S WHAT
THOSE ARE THE QUESTIONS I JUST
WANTED TO COMPARED TO OTHER
INDUSTRIES BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL
REAL REAL ESTATE RELATED YOU'RE
ALL DEALING WITH WITH HOUSING
WHETHER IT'S MANUFACTURED OR AN
APARTMENT OR RESIDENTIAL- YOU
KNOW FREESTANDING BUILDINGS IT'S
ALL IN HOUSING AND THAT'S WHY I
JUST WANTED A VERY DEAREST
HOUSING BUT YEAH. YES BUT STILL
HOUSING FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO LIVE
IN SO THAT'S RIGHT THAT'S WHERE
I WAS TRYING TO GET INFORMATION
ON DESERVE MORE SPECIFIC- CENTER
TO A BOGUS ASKED FOR THOSE. OF
YOU YOUR BRIEFLY RESPONDS- OUR-
MISTER. MEMBERS RANKING. IRA
SEVERAL. OF IN HAVE DONE SO FOR
MANY YEARS. WHETHER THERE ARE.
DECREASE PROPERTIES FOR. NORMAL
PROPERTIES. IN ALL CASES- THE
MANAGER. IF IT'S AN IN HOUSE
MANAGER SIXTEEN UNITS OR MORE.
MUST BE ONSITE. IN ALL CASES-
THE MANAGER. HOW IF THEY'RE
MANAGING PROPERTIES FOR SOMEONE
ELSE. HOUSE TO FULFILL. A COUPLE
PREREQUISITES WHEN THEY HAVE TO
BE. HOLD A REAL ESTATE LICENSE.
IN A REAL ESTATE LICENSE AS YOU
POINT OUT SENATOR. HAS TO HAVE-
CONTINUING EDUCATION. SINCE THE
VERY BEGINNING OF TIME- ALL.
MANAGERS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
SELECT. FROM ALL SORTS OF THIRD
PARTY PROVIDERS. THOSE THIRTY
PARTY PROVIDERS HAVE A SYLLABUS.
THAT HAVE TO BE SUBMITTED TO THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF REAL ESTATE.
AND APPROVED BY THEM. THEY HAVE
A VERY RIGID SCHEDULE A VERY
RIGID SET OF GUIDELINES. AND
HAVE TO FOLLOW THOSE- AND IT
COVERS THE WHOLE PANOPLY OF REAL
ESTATE TRANSACTIONS. THERE ARE
SOME CASES. IN THE FORTY FIVE
UNITS. THAT HAVE TO BE FULFILLED
SOME OF THEM ARE OPTIONAL. SOME
OF OUR MANDATORY FOR EXAMPLE
FAIR HOUSING. THAT IS A MANDATE
THAT YOU HAVE TO FULFILL.
WHETHER IT'S THAT OR NOT BUT IN
NO CASE CAN I THINK OF WHETHER-
IT'S A- M. C. COURSE OF COURSE
OFFERED- TO DENNIS DOCTORS
WHATEVER IS IT REGULATED AND
ONLY PROVIDED BY THE LICENSE
SOAR. IT IS BY THIRD PARTIES.
AND THE LICENSURE REGULATES THE
ENTIRE PROGRAM SO IT'S VERY VERY
DIFFERENT INDEED. OMF FROM THE
MODEL THAT- YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU
TODAY HOPEFULLY THAT HELPS YOU
OUT THAT. OKAY THANK YOU ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE I'M
SORRY CENTER THAT'S OKAY SO ONE
LAST QUESTION HOW DID YOU COME
UP WITH THE EIGHTEEN HOUR
REQUIREMENT MANDATED AND- I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO KNOW- JUST
FOR THE RECORD WOULD YOU BE OPEN
TO. THIRD PARTY AND LOOKING AT
THE REQUIRED NUMBER OF HOURS WE
THOUGHT THAT EIGHTEEN HOURS
WOULD ENSURE THE PROPER TRAINING
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE READ
PERSONALLY ANY VIEW THE MOBILE
HOME RESIDENTS THE LOGBOOK IT IS
VERY LONG IT'S VERY COMPLEX- WE
KNOW QUITE WELL ONE TEAM LEYVA
AND SINCE LIKE I SAID I'VE BEEN
THAT. CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE
FOR EIGHT YEARS SO WE THOUGHT
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN HOURS WAS THE
APPROPRIATE NUMBER AND YOU KNOW
WE'RE ALWAYS OPEN TO WORKING ON
ANYTHING THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
HEARING- THE BILL'S BEEN A PRINT
FOR QUITE SOMETIME THIS IS THE
FIRST I'M HEARING THAT IF THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT SOMEONE WOULD
LIKE TO. HELP PUT IN THE BILL
ARE LOOKED AT IN THE BILL SO AS
THE BILL CONTINUES ON WE'RE
ALWAYS WILLING TO LOOK AT
ANYTHING. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS COLLEAGUES. OKAY THREE
NINE I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR. LONG STANDING WORK ON- ON
MOBILE HOMES. AND I'M
RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
BILL TODAY THANK YOU FOR
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENT AS
INDICATED IN THE ANALYSIS I KNOW
YOU CONTINUED TO BOOKED UP WHAT
OTHER STATES ARE DOING DIFFERENT
EXAMPLES- TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
THE BEST POSSIBLE. A TRAINING
PROGRAM- SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IS THERE MOTION. MOTION BY
CENTER LIKE CALCIUM CENTER LABOR
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU CENTER
WIENER. SO I JUST ONE RESPONSE
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT THE
OPPOSITION SAID- YES M. L. R. P.
P. DOES HAVE A GREAT TRAINING
PROGRAM IT'S NOT MANDATORY IT'S
NOT REQUIRED. SO IF WE COULD
MAKE THAT REQUIRED AND MAKE THAT
MANDATORY THAT WOULD BE
FANTASTIC BUT IT IS NOT REQUIRED
SO AGAIN YOU HAVE FOLKS. THAT
CHOOSE TO PARTICIPATE IN THAT
AND YOU HAVE TO THOSE WHO CHOOSE
NOT TO. THIS IS NOT ABOUT BEING
REFERRED TO LEGAL SERVICE THIS
BILL IS NOT ABOUT CAUSING
PROBLEMS THIS BILL IS ABOUT
PREVENTING PROBLEMS THINK ABOUT
ANY TIME IN YOUR LIFE WHEN YOU
RECEIVE TRAINING. WHAT DID IT DO
IT PROVIDED YOU WITH KNOWLEDGE
SO YOU CAN BETTER CARRY OUT YOUR
DUTIES. WE ARE NOT ASKING FOR H.
C. D. TO INSPECT THE PARKS WE
ARE ASKING FOR TRAINING TWO VERY
DIFFERENT THINGS HCD ALREADY
DOESN'T FICTIONS OF MOBILE HOME
PARKS. THIS BILL IS NOT
REQUIRING ANY FURTHER
INSPECTION. THE MANAGER IS THE
REFEREE YOU MAKE ONE PERSON
HAPPY AND ONE PERSON I'M HAPPY.
SO AGAIN THE NEED FOR TRAINING
SO IF I GO TO PEOPLE I DON'T
KNOW OF ANY VIEW OF THE DISPUTE
RESOLUTION I DID DISPUTE
RESOLUTION FOR TWENTY YEARS
BEFORE I CAME HERE. AND WHEN YOU
HAVE KNOWLEDGE YOU HAVE THE
POWER TO TALK TO TWO PEOPLE AND
SAY HEY. THIS IS WHAT WE HAVE IF
PARK MANAGERS DON'T HAVE THE
KNOWLEDGE THEN YES THEY'RE GOING
TO MAKE ONE PERSON BATTLE ONE
PERSON HAPPY BUT IF THEY HAVE
THE TRAINING THE AT LEAST HAVE
THE FACTS AND THEY CAN SAY TO
THE BIT. IN THE DISPUTE THESE
ARE THE FACTS YOU MAY NOT AGREE
WITH THEM BUT THESE ARE THE
FACTS IN THIS WHAT WE CAN AND
CANNOT DO. MEMBERS I APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATION AS I START OFF
SAYING I LOVE THIS BILL BECAUSE
I KNOW AS A FIFTY FIVE YEAR OLD
WOMAN WOMAN. YOU ARE BETTER WHEN
YOU WERE TRAINED AT ANYTHING
THAT YOU'RE DOING AND THESE PUT
MOBILE HOME PARK MANAGERS HAVE A
LOT OF PEOPLE UNDERNEATH THEM
THAT ARE COUNTING ON THEM. TO DO
THE RIGHT THING AT LEAST HAVE A
KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO SO I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING ON THE ISSUES THAT
FOLKS BRING UP. BUT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I'VE-
SO WE CAN PUT. MOBILE PARK
WHERE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
WILL CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
SENATE BILL EIGHT SIXTY NINE BY
SENATOR LEYVA THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY SENATOR WIENER.
AYE WIENER AYE BATES NO EIGHT
SNOW. HOW TO YOUR- CORTESE HI
WHAT HAS HE I REQUIRE. PHOTOBOOK
SKINNER. FIVE SKINNER HI NUMBER. CASKEY PART WHAT HAS THE I.
ONE FORTY ONE THE VOTERS FOR THE
ONE WILL PUT THAT BILL ON CALL
SO THAT ABSENT MEMBERS MAY VOTE
THANK YOU IN THE CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS OKAY WILL NEXT GO TO
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB NINE FORTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR BACKER CENTER
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- PATIENCE.
AND YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER SHARON
COLLEAGUES AT TODAY I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT SB NINE FOUR EIGHT THAT
IS A BILL THAT WOULD HELP CUT
THE COST FOR A HOUSING PROJECTS
IN CALIFORNIA. RIGHT NOW THE
PART OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT REQUIRES PROJECTS
THEY HAVE RENTAL ASSISTANCE
CONTRACTS LIKE HOUSING CHOICE
VOUCHERS. SET ASIDE ENOUGH MONEY
WHEN FINANCING THE PROJECT TO
COVER A YEAR OF RENTAL
ASSISTANCE FOR THE TENANTS. THIS
CALL TO TRANSITION RESERVE AND
INTENDED TO PROVIDE A BUFFER. IN
THE UNLIKELY EVENT THAT
DEVELOPMENT LOSES ITS RENTAL
ASSISTANCE FUNDING. TRANSITION
RESERVES RANGE FROM AS LOW AS A
FEW HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS. IN
A SMALL PROJECT TO SEVERAL
MILLION DOLLARS IN A LARGE
PROJECT. RESILIENT AS YOU ALL
KNOW EVERY DOLLAR COUNTS THESE
PROJECTS AND FUNDING IS REALLY
SCARCE. H. U. D. RECENT
COMMISSION A STUDY ON THE
SUBJECT. AND THEY FOUND THAT THE
USE OF THESE RESERVES WAS SO
LOW. AS TO BECOME ALMOST AS TO
BE ALMOST NON EXISTENT. TO AN
ESSENCE THIS POLICY REQUIRES
PROJECTS TO FULLY SELF INSURE
FOR AN EVENT THAT IS
REALISTICALLY NEVER GOING TO
HAPPEN. BASED ON ARE NOT BASED
ON THEIR ANALYSIS. SO WITH THIS
BILL WOULD YOU WOULD HAVE TO
LIMIT THIS REQUIREMENT FOR
INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS INSTEAD
ALLOW IT SHE'S HCD TO CREATE A
POLL RESERVE. LIKE INSURANCE
FUND. THIS SHOULD BE AVAILABLE
THE RARE OCCURRENCE WHEN RENTAL
ASSISTANCE MIGHT BE LOST BOTH
FREE UP A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
MONEY. IN HOUSING PROJECTS RIGHT
NOW THEY CAN SET THE YOU TO
DEEPEN THE AFFORDABILITY UNIT.
OR INCREASE THE OVERALL NUMBER
OF AFFORDABLE UNITS IN A PROJECT
. WITH ME TO FRY TESTIMONY OR
JACK AVERY OF THE HOUSING OF
HOUSING CALIFORNIA. AND MARK
STIVERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP. THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BAKER WE WILL
NOW GO TO OUR LEAD- WITNESSES
WHO WERE- HE MISSES STIVERS IS
HERE FOR BREAKING UP. OKAY WE'LL
START WITH MR AVERY FROM HOUSING
CALIFORNIA ON THE PHONE LINE.
AND AGAIN YOU EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES SENATE MR A REVIEW GO
OVER THAT WILL EAT INTO MR
STIVERS TIME JUST AS A HEADS UP
. UNDERSTOOD THANK YOU THE
CHAIR. AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU SENATOR BAKER FOR
OFFERING AN INFILL NINE FOUR
EIGHT- MY NAME IS JACK IF YOU
ALL DID VISION OF CALIFORNIA
BURKE BOTH PUMPING THE BILL
ALONG WITH CALIFORNIA THE-
PARTNERSHIP- READY TO.
COMPREHENSIVE SUMMARY THE BILL I
WILL BE. THREE AS YOU OFFER.
CALIFORNIA MAY OF THE HOUSING.
AND WE'RE NOT IN. EVERY BE MORE
LUCIEN OFF BALL. SB NINE THREE
WILL PROVIDE NEW OUR- BEFORE
HAVING DEVELOPMENT WHAT THE MANY
. THAT THE SHORT OF NEARLY ONE
BILL A FOUR HOMES AND FIFTY
BUCKS MAKE THE MOST AFFECT AND
IT USE VERY DIFFICULT FOR THE-
OKAY. A I'VE AND WILL HAND IT
OVER- MARC I REQUEST. THE
COMPANY HOLDEN PARTNERSHIP THANK
YOU SHE SERVED. OCTOBER FOR THE
HOUSING FOR OF MICHAEL WERE ON
THE FINING FOR MORE THAN TWO OF
RENTAL HOUSING TO THE EACH YEAR-
DEVELOPED BY NON OF FOR
DEVELOPERS- AND JUST PULLING
AMONG MY COLLEAGUES WE FOUND
EIGHTY DIFFERENT DEVELOPMENTS
ARE SUBJECT TO THESE- HIV
TRANSITIONS ARE THAT'S A TOTAL
OF FORTY MILLION DOLLARS IT'S
GOING INTO THESE RESERVES THAT
ARE PROBABLY NEVER GOING TO BE
USED AND SO. WHILE WE
APPRECIATED SHE'S CONCERNED
ABOUT THE LOSS RENTAL ASSISTANCE
WE DO THINK THE POOLED RESERVE
CONCEPT IS A MUCH BETTER USE OF
FUNDS AND ALLOW US TO DEPLOY
THAT FORTY MILLION DOLLARS INTO
ADDITIONAL AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS OR OTHERWISE WOULD
NOT GET BUILT SO WE THANK YOU
YOUR AUTHOR FOR OTHER IN THIS
BILL AND WE URGE COMMITTEE
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I'M WILL NOW GO TO
THIS CYNICAL COMMENT IS THERE
ANYONE PRESENT HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SEEING NOW WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES MISTER
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP SUPPORT. THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
FOR SB NINE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED. BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. IN ONE FELL FIVE
ZERO. AND WE WILL ALIGN NINETY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
TURN SENATORS WITHIN ON BEHALF
OF HOUSING ACTION COALITION IN
SUPPORT. AND AS A REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. WHICH CARE
NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING UP. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW GO TO
OPPOSITION. TO SB NINE FORTY
EIGHT WE HAVE- NO- REGISTERED
OPPOSITION AS FAR AS I KNOW- IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM ABOUT. ONCE SPEAKING
OPPOSITION ST NINE WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES CAN YOU PLEASE
ASK FOR OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
THE TEST BY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
NINE FOUR EIGHT PLEASE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY A PRESS STAR ONE AT
THIS TIME STAR ONE. ONE MOMENT
MISTER SURE ONE PARTICIPANT IS
QUEUING UP FOR ANYBODY ELSE
THOUGH IT HELPED ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO.
AND WE WERE LINE NINETY TWO AND
AGAIN ONE ZERO IF ANYBODY ELSE
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION AND YOU TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU TO PLEASE- MAKE
YOURSELF. NINETY TWO YOU ARE
OPEN. OKAY IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE. NOBODY ELSE IS
QUEUED UP OKAY WILL BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE VAN- SO- IS
THERE A MOTION ON THIS BILL. BY
CENTER CORTEZ THE ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS COLLEAGUES. OKAY
SING NINE ONE THANK THE AUTHOR
MARK FUHRMAN AND I BOTH- ON THIS
BILL AND YOU MAY CLOSE. SHECK
WES FOR AYE VOTE THANK YOU WE
WILL CALL THE ROLL THIS IS
SENATE BILL NINE FORTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR BACKER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR WIENER AYE WIENER AYE
BATES. CABALLERO WHAT HAS HE HI
FOR BECAUSE HE AYE MCGUIRE.
MITCHELL BOOK I. TROUBLED BY
SKINNER. SKINNER I AM BURKE WITH
CASKEY HI CASKEY I. AND FOR THE
HASN'T OPPOSE WILL PUT ON CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND ALSO I APOLOGIZE
THAT I NEGLECTED TO STATE THIS
IS THE BEGINNING OF THE HEARING
BUT ITEM NUMBER SIX. SB TWELVE
NINETY TWO BY CENTER STERN ON AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR THAT
HAS BEEN PULLED FROM THE AGENDA
SO THAT WILL NOT BE HEARD- TODAY
OKAY WILL NOW GO TO ITEM NUMBER
FOUR- S. B. NINE SEVENTY ONE- BY
SENATOR NEWMAN. SENATOR WELCOME
. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER
IN MEMBERS. I'M HERE TODAY TO
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF SB NINE
SEVENTY ONE WHICH WILL EXPAND
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
FOR CALIFORNIA'S LOW INCOME
RENTERS WHO HAVE PETS. IN
TODAY'S VERY CHALLENGING HOUSING
MARKET TOO MANY CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES FREQUENTLY FIND
THEMSELVES FORCED TO MAKE A
CHOICE BETWEEN SECURING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND KEEPING.
A CHERISHED PET EVERY YEAR A
STAGGERING NUMBER OF OTHERWISE
HEALTHY LOVING AND LOYAL FAMILY
PETS ARE SURRENDERED TO
CALIFORNIA'S ANIMAL SHELTERS.
WHERE THE MOST FREQUENTLY CITED
REASONS FOR RELINQUISHING A PET
IS BECAUSE OF A HOUSING MOVING
FOR A LANDLORD ISSUE. DESPITE
THE FACT THAT THREE QUARTERS OF
RENTERS ARE PET OWNERS HAD
INCLUSION HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA
REMAINS REMARKABLY SCARCE
BETWEEN THE COMBINATION OF THE
LACK OF PET FRIENDLY HOUSING
OVERALL. AND EXPENSIVE OR
RESTRICTIVE PROVISIONS WITHIN
AVAILABLE PROPERTIES IT IS LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIA'S WITH PATCH
WERE MOST IMPACTED IN RECENT
YEARS THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE'S TAKEN IMPORTANT
AND ENCOURAGING STEPS. IN
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANT BOND
BETWEEN PEOPLE AND THEIR PETS AS
WELL AS THE NEED TO INCREASE
ACCESS. TO HOUSING RESOURCES TO
ACCOMMODATE FOR PET OWNERSHIP.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE BEST AB ELEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN WHICH REQUIRES
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT. FINANCE FOR
THE DEPARTMENT HOUSING COMMITTEE
DEVELOPMENT. TO PERMIT A
RESIDENT OF THE HOUSING GOING TO
OWN ONE OR MORE COMMON HOUSEHOLD
PETS. NOT WITHSTANDING THIS
PROGRESS RECENT RESEARCH HAS
FOUND THAT PET POLICIES AND
STATE SUBSIDIZED HOUSING
PROPERTIES. CONTINUE TO LIMIT
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
RESOURCES FOR MANY PET OWNERS A
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF RENTAL
PROPERTIES APPLY STRICT
LIMITATIONS AND BREED AND SIZE
AND OR TYPICALLY CHARGE.
EXPENSIVE MONTHLY FEES TO
FAMILIES OR INDIVIDUALS WITH
PETS. SB NINE SEVENTY ONE BUILDS
UPON PREVIOUS LEGISLATION TO
ALSO REQUIRE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
FINANCED WITH LOW INCOME HOUSING
TAX CREDITS TO BE PET FRIENDLY.
THE BILL DIRECTS THESE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS AS WELL AS THOSE
FINANCED THROUGH DEPARTMENT
HOUSING COMMITTEE DEVELOPMENT.
FUNDING TO HAVE HAD INCLUSIVE
POLICIES THAT ARE FREE FROM
GREATER WEIGHT RESTRICTIONS AND
TO NOT REQUIRE TENANTS. TO PAY
MONTHLY PET FEES ON TOP OF
REGULAR MONTHLY RENT AND
SECURITY DEPOSITS. PEOPLE LIVING
IN OR SEEKING AFFORDABLE RENTAL. HOUSING SHOULD NOT BE FORCED
INTO A THE ANGUISH H. ENTRY
RELATE A BILL PET SB NINETY
SEVEN ONE WHICH- THAT MORE CAL.
FAMILY WILL BE ABLE TO BRING
THEIR CANINE FELINE OR OTHER
ANIMAL BEST FRIENDS ALONG AS
PART OF ACCESS. TO SAFE
AFFORDABLE AND CAN INCREASE
HOUSING I'D LIKE TO THANK ALISON
HOUSTON COMMITTEE STAFFER
DETAILED ANALYSIS AND
SUGGESTIONS. ON HOW TO IMPROVE
THE BILL THE BILL IMPRINT
REFLECTS EARLY CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE COMMITTEE. AND THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE TO DRESS
THEIR CONCERNS WITH THE APPROACH
OF THE ORIGINAL LANGUAGE THE
BILL. THE BILL NUMBER IS NO
LONGER INCLUDES A TAX LEVY
PROVISIONS ARE REQUIRED. TO VOTE
I STAFF AND THE SPONSORS ARE
CURRENTLY ENGAGED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION. REGARDING THEIR
CONCERNS WHICH RECEIVED LATE
TUESDAY AFTERNOON GLAD TO
CONTINUE THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
WITH ME VIRTUALLY TODAY TO
TESTIFY IS JESSICA SIMPSON.
PUBLIC POLICY SPECIALIST WITH
THE HUMANE SOCIETY THE UNITED
STATES AND DIæN PRODUCT WAS
EXACTLY DIRECT FOR HEART LA. A
NONPROFIT PUBLIC INTEREST LAW
FIRM THAT PROVIDES TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE EDUCATION AND POLICY
ADVOCACY TO KEEP PEOPLE AND
THEIR COMPANION ANIMALS HOUSE
OUR SPECTRUM ASTRAEA. I VOTE
THIS AFTERNOON. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WILL NOW TO SLUR. IN ORDER
TO SUPPORT OF- S. B. NINE
SEVENTY ONE AND- ONCE AGAIN. AND
WE'LL HEAR FROM OUR- BOTH OF
EARLY WITNESSES OR BY PHONE WILL
START WITH JESSICA SIPSON FROM
THE HUMANE SOCIETY FOLLOWED BY
THEM PRODUCT FROM HARD LA. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME'S JESSICA AND- SENIOR
PUBLIC POLICY SPECIALIST FOR
COMPANION ANIMALS FOR HUMANE
SOCIETY OF THE UNITED STATES.
UNITED STATES AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY. ON
BEHALF OF OUR CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTERS I RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT ON SENATE BILL NINE
SEVEN ONE WHICH ON PROVE ACCESS
TO AFFORDABLE RENTAL HOUSING FOR
CALIFORNIA'S LONG COMPETITORS.
WHAT FOR THE HOUSING IS NOT A
NEW ISSUE THE PANDEMIC HAS
GREATLY EXACERBATED. THE HOUSING
INSTABILITY AND HAVE LONG
CONTENDED SPECIALLY HARD.
TOWARDS THE HIGH HOUSING COSTS
AND SUPPLIES SHORTAGE HAS MADE
PET OWNERSHIP AN OBSTACLE FOR
COUNTLESS TENANTS MEDICAL PLEASE
CONDITIONS WITH FAMILIES TORN
APART AND SHELTERS UNNECESSARILY
OVERBURDENED. 45% OF CALIFORNIAN
HOUSEHOLDS ARE RENTERS NEARLY
THREE FOURTHS OF RENTERS HAVE
PASSED. RECTIFIED AMANDA
MAJORITY SAY THEY HAVE TROUBLE
FINDING PET FRIENDLY PROPERTIES.
BUT TO GET ALL MY DEVELOPMENT
REPORT PRESS AND LANE THEY OFTEN
HAVE ARBITRARY RESTRICTIONS AND
BREED AND WEIGHT AN ADDITIONAL
COSTLY PET FRIENDS. PERSONALLY
IMPACT LOW INCOME. AND
MARGINALIZED. UNARY RESEARCH
REVEALED PAULA'S AND TECH AND
EACH CITY ARE IN CAN AND
DIFFICULT AFTER. THANK MANAGER
POINT OUT THE THEY ALLOW DAHLE
FROM A SUPPORT ANIMALS THE
THERE'S A COMBINATIONREQUIRED
FEDERAL LAW. WHAT RESIDENTS TO
RECEIVE. REASONABLE ACT TO
ASSISTANCE ANIMALS HAS BECOME.
DIFFICULT FOR YOUR EXPERIENCE
HOUSING. THE BARRIERS MAKE NOT
ALL. RIGHT GREAT STRIDES HEALTH
MAJOR TECH BOND WITH PEOPLE IN
THE PETS AS WELL AS INCREASE AND
STRENGTHEN INVESTED IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SUPPLY. THEY
CAN IN TO BE THINKING SORT OF
UNITS FOR LONGER FAMILIES EVEN
FEWER AVAIL FOR TEN WITHOUT
WITHOUT WITHOUT. FEES OR POLICY. PEOPLE LIVING IN OR SPEAKING
FOR RENTAL HOW. SHOULDN'T HAVE
TO EXPERIENCE THE HARPER ENGLISH
OF RELINQUISHING APACHITA A LACK
ACCESS. THE TANK OF HOUSING. AND
SENATE BILL HELP ADDRESS. NOT
ONLY THE OF A- AND ISSUES BUT
ALSO HELP CREATE A FOR OWNERSHIP
KEEP FAMILIES. THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND WE
RESPECTFULLY AND I. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I NOT SURE IF OUR
SECOND WIN THIS IS PROUD IS ON
THE PHONE LINE. SHE'S NOT A I'M
BEING TOLD. OKAY SO WE WILL NOW
GO TO ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE SEVENTY
ONE IS THERE ANYONE. IN THE
HEARING ROOM IN SUPPORT. SINGLED
OUT OF THE PHONE LINES GOD
MISTER MODERATOR COULD YOU
PLEASE QUEUE UP SUPPORT FOR SB
NINE SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR S. B.
NINETY SEVEN ONE. PLEASE PRESS
STAR A ONE OH BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONE OH BY ZERO TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE SEVEN ONE.
MY NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY NINETY NINE YOU ARE OPEN.
WHAT WE WANT WE WILL TO LINE
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE OREGON NATIONAL MANAGER OF
HOUSING INITIATIVES FOR BEST
FRIENDS ANIMAL SOCIETY IN FULL
SUPPORT S. B. NINE SEVEN ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE TWENTY
THREE YOU ARE OPEN. I COULD
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE STUDENT
GREG SENIOR DIRECTOR OF HOUSING
POLICY FOR THE SPCA CALLING AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE
ONE ANOTHER PURCHASE THE QUEUING
UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE MISTER
CHAIR. ANYBODY ELSE BUDGET ONE
ZERO TO TESTIFY. MY SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. KAREN MEMBERS
OFTEN WEPT WITH RELIEF ADDED ON
BEHALF OF ANIMAL LEGAL DEFENSE
FUND IN SUPPORT. AND THE OTHER
ONE SHOULD BE WITH US JUST
MOMENTARILY THANK YOU. I SIXTY
Q. YOU ARE OKAY. HELLO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS YET IN MY YOUNG WITH
POLITICAL SOLUTIONS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF MARS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE ACOSTA THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE A
WILL NOW GET A OPPOSITION. IS
THERE ANYONE WE HAVE A- MR
KING'S TIMES HERE IN OPPOSITION-
I THINK THE ONLY ONE SO YOU HAVE
A FEW MATT FOR MINUTES. I WILL
TAKE THAT WATER. A MISTER. THIS
IS SENATOR KNOWS ME TOO WELL I'M
RUNNING- REPRESENT THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATIONS- COVERING ALL OF.
CALIFORNIA THEY PROVIDE
EXCLUSIVELY NOTHING BUT- HOUSING
FOR THE EXTREME LOW INCOME
SENIORS AND- DISABLED. THEY HAVE
ONE PROBLEM WITH THIS BILL WE'VE
BEEN ACTIVELY ENGAGED WITH THE
SENATOR SENATOR STAFF WE TOTALLY
BELIEVE THAT- WE WILL GET THERE.
EVERY HAT POLICY CONTRACT THAT
EXISTS IN RENTAL HOUSING HAS
SOME ESSENTIAL ELEMENTS WHICH
WERE ASKING THE SENATOR INCLUDE
HE GRACIOUSLY. HI HAS AGREED TO
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF LANGUAGE
ONE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE ANIMALS ARE AT LEAST- WHEN
THEY'RE OUT OF TE PREMISES THAT
THEY DON'T. DISTURB THE QUIET
ENJOYMENT. FOR OTHER TENANTS SO
. GIVE ME A FACT WHAT HAPPENS AT
THE TENANT LEAVES LEAVES AND THE
DOG IS LEFT IN THE PREMISES AND
IT HOWLS ALL DAY LONG. THEY WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE- THAT THEY
CAN ADDRESS THAT TYPE THING
COMMISSION OF WASTE AND CLEAN
UP. THE WE'VE ASKED THE CENTRE
TO INCLUDE THAT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. THERE IS A RESPONSIBLE
TENET HAVING THE PAT I TO CLEAN
UP AFTER THEIR PETS AS THE CASE
MAY BE SO THESE ARE VERY
PRACTICAL AMENDMENTS THAT THE-
THE SENATOR IS GENERALLY
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH US AND
WE'RE PRETTY CONFIDENT WE'RE
GOING TO GET THERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- IS THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION HERE
IN THE ROOM. SEEING NOW WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES COULD YOU UP
ANY OPPOSITION. TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE SEVEN ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE
FOLLOWED BY EUROPE THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIR NOBODY IS GOING UP
OKAY WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- IS THERE ANY ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS CENTER
SKINNER. I WAS JUST STRUCK BY
THE TESTIMONY BECAUSE- I THINK
CERTAINLY. MOST PEOPLE DO NOT
WANT TO HAVE A NEIGHBOR WHO HAS
A DOG THAT MIGHT HELP ALL DAY
LONG HOWEVER I CAN ATTEST TO THE
FACT THAT THERE ARE MANY.
HOMEOWNERS FOR WHOM THEIR DOGS
HOWL ALL DAY LONG AND SO YOU
COULD BE A NEIGHBOR. OF THAT
PERSON AND HAVE A- DOG HELPING
HOLD THE LONG SO I GUESS. THE
POINT I'M MAKING IS THAT WHILE.
WE WOULD IDEALLY LIKE ALL
OCCUPANTS TO BE RESPONSIBLE PET
OWNERS WE IS THERE IS NO
GUARANTEE WHETHER ONE IS A
HOMEOWNER OR TENANT AND SO I
GUESS. TO ME THE THEN THE
PRINCIPAL COMES DO WE LIMIT.
PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY ARE LOW
INCOME AND LIVE IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FROM YOU KNOW BEING PET
OWNERS AND- WHILE AT THE CURRENT
TIME I AM NOT A DOG OWNER AND
PARTLY BECAUSE- YOU KNOW I'M
HERE I'D HAVE TO MY POOR DOG
WOULD I KNOW I'M HAPPY TIME
HEARING HALFTIME. SO YOU KNOW I
WOULD BE AN IRRESPONSIBLE PET
OWNER FROM MY POINT OF VIEW IF I
WERE A DOG OWNER FACT. THAT
SAID. I THINK THE- WHAT YOUR
BILL IS TRYING TO DO. IS GIVE
YOU SAID THAT YOU SHOULD NOT BE
ONCE INCOME THAT DETERMINES-
WHETHER YOU CAN BE THAT PET
OWNER OR NOT- WELL AGAIN. I'D
LOVE TO SEE SOME KINDS OF- YOU
KNOW MEDIATIONS OR SOMETHING UP
THERE THERE'S A PROBLEM THAT I
DON'T I DON'T THINK THERE SHOULD
BE ANY RESTRICTIONS. JUST DUE TO
AND I KNOW YOU'RE JUST GIVING
ONE ARE OPPOSITION WAS JUST
GIVING ONE EXAMPLE AND I DON'T
NEED TO. TO YOU KNOW BUT BLOW IT
OUT OF PROPORTION BUT I'M JUST
SAYING THAT HEY. PEOPLE ARE
SUBJECTED TO THINGS THEY DON'T
WANT TO BE SUBJECTED TO
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY LIVE.
OR THE STATUS OF THE PERSON NEXT
DOOR ON EITHER SIDE OF THEM SO.
ON THE BILL. YOUR COMMENTS TEAM
NINE- WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR SKINNER AND I'M
RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE- CENTER
NEWMAN YOU MAY CLOSE- DAD THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I AM I'M
ALWAYS DISAPPOINTED CENTER
WORKERS GONNA HAD A LONG
CONVERSATION. ABOUT HAD BILLS-
AND I WAS FULLY PREPARED TO
OFFER AS AN INDUCEMENT THE
PROMISE OF A PUPPY FOR HIS
BIRTHDAY- BUT NOW I THINK I'LL
GIVE IT TO SENATOR SKINNER
INSTEAD. AB SO THIS IS A REAL
PROBLEM- AND WE CAN MAKE LIGHT
OF IT BUT TO SENATOR SKINNER'S
POINT ALSO THAT MISTER JACKSON
IS ACTUALLY CHARACTERIZED. OUR
CONVERSATIONS- THE OWNERSHIP OF
A PATCH OF BE A PRO IN- FOR. AN
OUT TO ACCESSING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUT- STEPS. RENTAL
HOUSING- EVERY TENANT HAS THE
SAME OBLIGATION TO YOU KNOW TO
THE PRESERVATION OF QUIET
ENJOYMENT OF A PROPERTY AND I
THINK. PET OWNERS. SHOULD AND
WILL BE HELD TO THAT STANDARD
UNDER THIS LEGISLATION- GLAD TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION BOTH
WITH- MISTER KINKS AND ALSO THE
APARTMENT. WITH THAT I RESPECT.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE
A MOTION BY CENTER SKINNER WILL
CALL THE ROLL. THE SENATE BILL
NINE SEVENTY ONE BY SENATOR
NEWMAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR WIENER AYE WIENER AYE
BATES. CABALLERO CORTESE HI FOR
TEDDY I MCGUIRE. PHOTOBOOK I BUT
TROUBLED AYE SKINNER. SKINNER I
AM BURKE WITH CASKEY NOT VOTING. FOUR ZERO. IT IS CURRENTLY
FOUR ZERO WILL PUT ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. WHEN IT WAS
SENATE DOC IN THE BACKGROUND ON
THE VICTOR- WAS THE DUCK ON A ON
A LEASH. YOUR FAMILY LIKES YOUR
BILL- OKAY THE YOU CENTER. WE
WILL NOW GO TO THE- FIVE S. B.
ELEVEN OH FIVE BY SENATOR HUESO
SENATE HUESO YOU MAY PRESENT
YOUR BILL. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING CHUCK CHAIRMAN- MEMBERS-
I'M VERY PROUD OF PERCENT. S. B.
ELEVEN OH FIVE A BILL THAT WOULD
ESTABLISH TO SEND YOU ORIGINAL
EQUITABLE. AND ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY HOUSING AGENCY. WROTE
SAN DIEGO IN ORDER TO TACKLE
THE- HOUSING SHORTAGES IN THIS
COUNTRY. THIS IS A BILL THAT IS
SPECIFIC TO SEND YOU A COUNTY.
THAT IS SPECIFIC TO AN
ORGANIZATION THAT'S BEEN- VERY
IMPORTANT I'M PLANNING. THE
INFRASTRUCTURE DEVELOPMENT THE
COUNTY. SANDAG AS MANY OF YOU
ARE AWARE OF OUR ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS ACROSS THE- STATE
THERE ARE DIFFERENT AREAS OF THE
STATE THAT ASSOCIATION
GOVERNMENTS IN SAN DIEGO. WE ARE
VERY PROUD OF OUR ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENT WHICH IS PRETTY MUCH
A CONGLOMERATION. OF DIFFERENT
CITIES. FROM THAT THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO. THEY'VE BEEN IN
CHARGE OF- THE TRANSPORTATION OF
PLANNING- IN- IN RESOLVING
DISPUTES AMONG BORDERS BETWEEN.
CITIES AND HELPING TO MAINTAIN
ENVIRONMENTAL RESOURCES-
ASSOCIATE WITH THE COAST. AND
ALL ALL SORTS OF PLANNING ISSUES
AND ALTHOUGH THEY HAVE HAD SOME
ROLE. IN A PLAN IN HOUSING THEY
HAVEN'T REALLY HAD- DIRECT ROLE
IN ENSURING THAT THAT HOUSING IS
BUILT. CALIFORNIA A IN IN
TOTALITY HAS GENERALLY FAILED TO
MEET- IT'S- ANNUAL HOUSING
PRODUCTION GOALS AND FOR THAT
REASON WERE CONSIDERED ONE OF
THE- LEAST AFFORDABLE STATES TO
LIVE IN AND HOUSING PRODUCTION
HAS BEEN LACKING IN WE ALL KNOW
THAT THAT'S AN ISSUE ALL OF YOU
THAT SERVE ON THIS COMMITTEE ARE
VERY WELL AWARE OF THOSE ISSUES
. IN SAN DIEGO. WHERE A FACE
FACING A HOUSING SHORTAGE OF
ABOUT NINETY THOUSAND UNITS.
AND- THERE WOULD BE ANOTHER
NINETY THOUSAND THAT WOULD BE
EXPECTED TO BUILD BY TWENTY
THIRTY SO WE'RE LOOKING AT SOME
VERY DAUNTING GOALS IN THE NEXT
DECADE TO MEET. AND OF THE SAN
DIEGO COMMUNITY TOGETHER WITH
VARIOUS LEADERS OF COME TOGETHER
AND- THOUGHT HOW HOW CAN WE
ADDRESS THIS WHAT DO WE HAVE TO
DO TO GET A BETTER JOB OF
FINDING THIS AND ONE OF THE
STRUGGLES IS NOT ONLY GONNA BE
TO PRODUCES BUT HOW CAN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY ABSORB THAT MANY
UNITS IN A WAY. THAT'S GONNA BE
FRIENDLY ON THE ENVIRONMENT
THAT'S GOING TO BE FRIENDLY TO
WORKERS TO ENSURE THAT WORKERS-
CAN LIVE CLOSE TO WHERE THEY
WORK- TO ENSURE THAT- THE
HOUSING IS BUILT IN THE BEST
LOCATIONS- IN- IN- REGARDS TO
THE NEEDS OF THE ECONOMY SO
OFTEN TIMES WHEN A CITY DOES
THAT THEY DO IT WITHIN THEIR OWN
BOUNDARIES. BUT IN A COUNTY LIKE
SAN DIEGO THAT IS- SO BIG AND SO
DIVERSE ONE OF THE N. STREET SEE
INTERESTING FACTS ABOUT SAN
DIEGO'S THAT HAS THE LARGEST
AMOUNT OF MOM AND POP FARMS. AND
THAT'S BEEN ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES AND SAN DIEGO TO
PROTECT THOSE FARMS IN THAT
PRODUCTION AND THAT LAND USE
FROM ENCROACHMENT OF HOUSING.
AND IT BECOMES HARDER IN SAN
DIEGO WHEN YOU HAVE COMPETING
GOALS LIKE THAT. AND SO- THIS
BILL- I THINK WOULD BE A GREAT-
SOLUTION TO HAVE SANDAG BE
INVOLVED IN. THE FUTURE VISION
IN AND THE ALLOCATION OF
RESOURCES. AND MAKING SURE THAT
THEY WORK CLOSER WITH CITIES. TO
IDENTIFY. WHERE THOSE RESOURCES
ARE GOING TO BE INVESTED TO GET
REALLY THE BIGGEST BANG FOR THE
BUCK TO ENSURE. THAT HOUSING
INCREASE IS CREATE IT WHERE IT'S
NEEDED SO WE DON'T PUT AN OVER
BURDENED ON TRANSPORTATION. SO
OF THIS BILL IS YOU'VE SEEN IT'S
QUITE A LENGTHY BILL. AND IT
SPEAKS TO THE LENGTHY PROCESS
THIS BILL HAS UNDERGONE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. TO COME UP WITH
THIS POLICY THAT'S BEFORE YOU
TODAY AND WE'RE GONNA BE WORKING
THIS THROUGH THIS- PROCESS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET THIS BILL
RIGHT THROUGH THE PROCESS BUT
ALREADY A CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF
WORK. HAS BEEN PUT INTO THIS
BILL AND I ASK OF THE COMMITTEE
BYE I THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR VERY THOROUGH.
ANALYSIS OF THE BILL. AND I
ASKED FOR YOU TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY I KNOW WE HAVE- A CHAMPION
OF THIS BILL AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
SERVICE SUPERVISOR TERREL LAWSON
REAMER. THERE'S BEEN CHAT
CHAMPION IN THIS ISSUE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND SHE'S BEEN VERY
EFFECTIVE. I BRING IN A TOGETHER
OF VERY VERY IMPRESSIVE LIST OF
STAKEHOLDERS TO PROVIDE
INTERPRETANT TO THIS PROCESS OF
COURSE AS IT GOES THROUGH THIS
PROCESS THROUGH LEGISLATION.
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE WE'RE
GOING TO BE CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS AND I
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
PROCESS MISTER CHAIR. AND I I'M
SURE THAT- SUPERVISOR LOS
RUMORES ONLINE TOO HI SO MORE TO
THIS DISCUSSION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CENTER HUESO. WE WILL NOW
GO TO- I BELIEVE- SUPERVISOR
LAWSON MEMORIES ON THE LINE AS
OUR MAIN- SUPPORT WINDOWS SO.
WILL NOW HEAR. FROM THE
SUPERVISOR. THANK YOU KAREN
WEINER AND MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. I CENTER WHERE THEM
INTO WE HAVE A- HOUSE SHORTFALL
IN SANDY COUNTY. EVEN THOUGH
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
CREATE MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WE'RE STILL ONLY BUILDING ENOUGH
TO MEET ABOUT 13% OF THE NEED
AMONG WORKING MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES. ADD WHEN I TALK TO
LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS SAN DIEGO I
THINK IT'S PRETTY. BROADLY
RECOGNIZE THAT WE'RE NEVER GOING
TO MEET THE SHORTFALL GIVEN OUR
CURRENT LEVEL OF RESOURCES AND
ARE FRAGMENTED HOUSING APPROACH.
WE NEED A REGIONAL STRATEGY TO
TACKLE THIS PROBLEM. AND THE- SB
REEF- IDEAS COME UP REPEATEDLY
IN MY CONVERSATIONS THIS IS AT
THE SAN DIEGO REGIONAL
EQUITABLE. AND ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY FRIENDLY HOUSING
AGENCY. AS A SOLUTION THAT HAS
BEEN RAISED BY MANY STAKEHOLDERS
WITH AND CONSTITUENTS IMPACTED.
INDIVIDUALS AND ELECTED
OFFICIALS- SB RE IS ALLEGED TEND
TO STARTING THE CONSTRUCTION OF
ACT IN ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY
HOUSING. THE INTENT EAGLE COUNTY
WHICH IS ONE REASON I CREATED
AND NOW CHAIR SANDBAGS REGEL
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SUB COMMITTEE
I TO FORMALISE THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING AND REFINING THAT HE
REFER TO POSTAL. I'M ARE
EQUITABLE HOUSING SUB COMMITTEE
IS COMPRISED OF ELECTED
OFFICIALS WITH SUBREGIONAL
REPRESENTATION AND WE'VE
CONVENED A TASK FORCE OF FORTY
LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS FROM A WIDE
VARIETY OF SECTORS IN
PERSPECTIVE TO INFORM AND GUIDE
OUR PROCESS IS WE FINALIZED THE
PROPOSAL. THE STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDE GROUPS I THINK SUCH AS
SAN DIEGO HOUSING FEDERATION SAN
DIEGO BUILDING TRADES AND THE
SAN DIEGO REGIONAL CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. I SHOULD KNOW THAT OUR
APPROACH- YES YOU READ AND IS
NOT IDENTICAL TO THE PROCESS IN
THE BAY AREA OR LOS ANGELES- WE
HAVE WORKED HARD WITH LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVELOP A SET OF
GUIDING PRINCIPLES. THAT ARE
LOCALLY ROOTED AND REFLECT THE
VALUES IN REVISION OF THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY REGION. THESE
INCLUDE AFFORDABILITY
SUSTAINABILITY LIVABILITY EQUITY
AND QUALITY JOBS. SO I THINK THE
COMMITTEE FOR CONSIDERING THE
SPELL AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH CENTER
AWAY SO ALL OF OUR STAKEHOLDERS
ACROSS SAN DIEGO COUNTY REGION.
AND ALL OF YOU ON THIS IMPORTANT
EFFORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- WILL NOW GO TO ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT SUPPORTED PUBLIC COMMENT
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. MISTER
SMITH THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH YOUR
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SAME GONE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES WITH THE
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY
SUPPORT FOR S. B. ELEVEN OH FIVE
. THANK YOU. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR S. B. ELEVEN
OH FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE ZERO EXPRESSED
SUPPORT FOR S. B. ELEVEN OH FIVE. MISTER CHAIR NOBODY IS QUEUING
UP. OKAY WHEN I GOT OPPOSITION-
MR STIVERS COME MARCH DIVERSE OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP OF THIS BILL CAME
INTO PRINT A MERE SEVEN DAYS AGO
SO WE DO NOT YET HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION- NOR WOULD BE
ABLE TO COMMUNICATE WITH THE
AUTHOR BUT I JUST WANT TO ADD A
COUPLE COMMENTS ARE PARTNERS IN
SAN DIEGO WILL BE REACHING OUT
THE AUTHOR AND THE SUPERVISOR
TALK ABOUT THIS MORE. IN GENERAL
WE DO LIKE THE IDEA OF A
REGIONAL ENTITY THAT'S A GOOD
THING- BUT AS WE CONSISTENTLY
EXPRESSES COMMITTEE OF THE LAST
TWO YEARS WE ARE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE SKILLED AND TRAINED
PROVISION IN THE BILL THAT WILL
ACTUALLY MAKE IT HARDER TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BY REDUCING
THE COMPETITION AMONG AND THE
CONTRACTOR SPACE WE HAVE A HARD
TIME NOW HAVE A GETTING MORE
THAN. ONE OR TWO APPLICANTS TO
BID A CONSTRUCTION JOB IN A
PREVAILING WAGE JOB AND IF WE
REDUCE THAT POOL BY MORE THAN
HALF IT WILL BE HERE DON'T BE A
LOT OF MARKET POWER AMONG THE
CONTRACTORS AND INCREASE THE
COST SIGNIFICANTLY SO WE THANK
YOU FOR THAT BUT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
ON THIS GOING FORWARD. THANK
VERY MUCH AND THE ADDITIONAL-
SUPPORTIVE WERE. IN BETWEEN-
PUBLIC COMMENT. HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM SINGLE MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANY OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
JUST PLAN OPPOSITION TO- S. B.
ELEVEN OH FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO ONE ZERO. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
THIS MOMENTARILY ANYBODY ELSE
WHERE ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
THAT'S WHY IN OPPOSITION. NINE
ONE ZERO SIX YOU ARE OPEN. WHY I
COULD NOT REMEMBER FIRST TIME
AND WE WOULD JUST ECHO THE
REMARKS WITH MY COLLEAGUES TO
THANK AS WELL. THANK YOU. SURE
SURE NOBODY ELSE QUEUING UP AT
THE SKY GRAY THANK YOU WILL NOT
ABOUT THE COMMITTEE CALLING IN
QUITE ARE. CENTER LOCALES AND
THEN CENTER CORTEZ I'M FOR OF US
LIVE IN THE BEAR SO WHY THIS
ISN'T AN EXACT COPY. OF CHOOSE
BILL AND IT'S YOU KNOW THERE'S
SO MANY THINGS AND THERE. ARE
I'M GONNA SUPPORTED TODAY- BUT-
A BAG HAS EXISTED AS LONG AS
I'VE BEEN ALIVE I THINK IN THE
IN THE BAY AREA AND IT WAS A
REGIONAL PLANNING- AGENCY THAT
WAS MERGED WITH MTC SO WE HAD
THIS. IS WEIRD THING WORK RATHER
THAN DO A J. P. WE DID THE
SPECIAL LEGISLATION TO TRY TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF. YOU KNOW.
NEIGHBORS FIGHT ALL THE TIME AS
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT HERE IN
CITIES REALLY FIGHT OVER. THIS
PROJECT AND THAT PROJECT SO.
THIS IS. AS THE OPPOSITION HAS
INDICATES ONLY SEVEN DAYS OLD
HERE SO HARD TO GET IT TO US
WELL GET IN BUT IT'S A- I'M
GOING TO GIVE YOUR MY COLLEAGUE
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU THE VOTE
TODAY UT- BUT THERE IS- YOU
KNOW DECADES OF WORK THAT THE
BAY AREA DID. IN ORDER TO GET TO
THAT LEVEL AND I'D LIKE TO SEE
SAN DIEGO. ACHIEVE THAT BUT
THERE WAS A LOT OF GROUND WORK
THAT HAD TO GET DONE BEFORE WE
GOT TO THE- END OF A- ABOUT FIVE
SO. THAT'S JUST MY COMMENT
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU ANOTHER
QUESTION OF CENTER THAT'S IN MY
CALL YEAH THANK YOU SURE BE-BRIEF- JUST WANT TO- COMMITTEE
AUTHOR BRINGS FORWARD A- A SUSHI
MY COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF CENTER
WORKOUTS SKI ON THE- THE MODEL
IN THE BAYAREA I WAS. THERE
WORKING ON THAT- WHEN SOME
MEMBER CHU WAS BRING THAT
LEGISLATION FORTY. WORK REALLY
REALLY CLOSELY WITH REGIONAL
FOLKS TO THE- YOU KNOW TO
ESSENTIALLY AMEND THAT BILL
ALONG THE WAY TO MAKE SURE WORK
FOR EVERYBODY I'M SURE YOU'LL DO
THE SAME THING WITH SAN DIEGO.
ON THE SKILLED AND TRAINED
ISSUE- A WANTED TO AFFIRM YOU ON
THAT IS WELL IN. ME IS KIND OF
HEARTBREAKING FOR ME TO HEAR OF
FOLKS WERE BUILDING. HOUSING FOR
POOR PEOPLE. A TALK ABOUT NOT
PAYING. POOR PEOPLE ENOUGH MONEY
TO FOR THE HOUSING THAT THEY
NEED TO MOVE INTO AN- AS A
FORMER BUILDER MYSELF I DON'T
BUY INTO THE FACT THAT. A YOU
CAN'T ENTER PEOPLE IN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS YOU KNOW
WITHOUT BANKRUPTING. JESSICA I
DONE IT THE BILL WITH IMAGES YOU
STICK TO YOUR GUNS- YOU KNOW ON
THAT ISSUE AS WELL SO. HAPPY TO
CONTINUE. SUPPORTING THE BILL ON
THE WAY THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL. OR COME CENTER. OF
JUST WANT TO COME RELEASED. AND
SAYS SOMETHING. TO THIS LAST
YEAR WHICHWAS BROUGHT FORTH
WITH SENATORS COME LOCKER.
HOWEVER I DID NOT RECEIVE ANY
LETTERS OF SUPPORT FROM LOCAL-
ENTITIES ON ON THAT AND SOME ON
THAT FRONT I'M GOING TO STAY
OFF. THE STRONG I WILL BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY BECAUSE I
THINK- WITH SPECIALLY. AS I SAY
YOU KNOW ONE STATE. ONE ONE SIZE
FITS DOESN'T AT ALL OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SO I'M VERY VERY
LEERY TO. SUPPORT BILLS- THAT
OUR REGIONAL- WITHOUT HEARING
FROM MANY OF THE LOCAL- ELECTED
ON THAT FRONT SO I'M I'M GOING
TO STAY- I'M NO VOTING FOR THIS
ONE SELF CARE PALLETIZING. ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- SEEING NONE- SENATE
HUESO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AS NOTED THIS IS A
NEARLY- THE BILL NEWLY PUT IN
PRINT I PRESENT YOU WORKING WITH
ERIC- COMMITTEE ON A AND- I TOO
WAS- WHEN WE DO THIS FOR THE BAY
AREA. I REMEMBER- WHEN WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU AND-
SENATOR MCGUIRE TO ONE OF HIS
FAVORITE RESTAURANTS IN MARIN
COUNTY TO MEET WITH THEM TO SEE
BOARD MEMBERS AND WORKED WITH.
IT WAS A VERY VERY EXHAUSTIVE-
PROCESS AND SO- I KNOW THAT
YOU'LL DO THAT WORK IN ENGAGING
LOCAL. I STAKEHOLDERS IN THIS
BILL WILL BE A WORK IN PROGRESS-
THE JURISDICTION OF THIS
COMMITTEE IS IN TERMS OF THE-
SPEND THE JURORS AND THE TYPES
OF. HOUSING AND SO WILL CONTINUE
TO ENGAGE WITH YOU ON THAT OF
COURSE THE GOVERNANCE PROVISION.
WILL BE HANDLED BY THE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE-
COMMITTEE- SO- I DO. RECOMMEND
THAT I VOTE- TODAY AND I CAN
HAVE SOMEONE OF THE BILL ALREADY
I DON'T THINK SO OKAY CENTER
COULD HAS REMOVED THE BILL AND
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS OF SUPPORT INNER AND
THE COMMENTS OF CONCERN- JUST A
NOTE- THAT YOU BILL IN THE- OF A
REAL DEFINITELY- MODELS FOR THIS
PHYLLIS WELLS. THEY A LOT OF
WHAT'S IN THAT BILL- OR THE
MAJORITY OF WHAT WAS IN THAT
BILL WAS R. AS IN THIS BILL SO
THERE'S NO REASON WHY. YOU
SHOULD HAVE CONCERNS AND SUPPORT
ESPECIALLY EARLY ON IN THIS
PROCESS. YOU KNOW A- GREAT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS NOT A
PARTISAN ISSUE IT'S- IT'S A
BIPARTISAN ISSUE AND- WE HAVE
ENGAGED ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. LABOR LOCAL GROUPS-
THE SAN DIEGO FOUNDATION A OR P.
THE NEIGHBORHOOD HOUSE
ASSOCIATION BIO COM SEMPRA. MAC
PROJECT B. I. A. EVERYBODY IS
SITTING AT THE TABLE TO THIS
PROCESS AND- THAT YOU'RE NOT
GETTING OVERWHELMING AT.
OPPOSITION SPEAKS THAT TO. OF
PEOPLE WILLING TO GO THROUGH
THIS PROCESS TO ENVISION. A BILL
THAT IS RIGHT FOR SAN DIEGO AND
AS I MENTIONED SAN DIEGO IS. A
VERY UNIQUE COUNTY AND THERE ARE
MANY VERY UNIQUE COMPANIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND THERE REALLY
ISN'T A ONE SIZE FITS APPROACH
AND THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT. THIS BILL DOESN'T REMOVE
ANY- HOUSING AUTHORITY
RESPONSIBILITIES IF THEY ALREADY
CREATED AND SEND YOU WHAT'S
THERE SOME AND I'VE SERVED ON ON
THOSE. AND THEY JONES- TAKE AWAY
ANY RESPONSIBILITIES FROM THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO ACHIEVE
THEIR GOALS SO THIS IS NOT A
FIGHT. BETWEEN THE COUNTY AND
SANDAG AND LOCAL CITIES THIS IS
AN ADDITIONAL RESOURCE
ADDITIONAL PLANNING GIVING THEM
RESPONSIBILITIES TO ENVISION
WHERE WHEN AND HOW THESE
INVESTMENTS ARE GOING TO MAKE
THE MADE IN THIS IS AN
ORGANIZATION. THAT'S NOT ONLY
GOING TO BE TASK PLANNING AND
MAKING REPORTS AND HAVING BALLOT
INITIATIVES BUT- TO DRAW FROM
MONEY DOWN FROM THE STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND MAYBE THE
LOCAL LEVEL OR ANY WHICH WAY
THEY CAN AT. BECAUSE WITHOUT
THESE FUNDS A HOUSING CAN BE
BUILT. IT'S THAT PLAIN AND
SIMPLE. WE NEED THESE FUNDS WE
NEED THIS THIS HOUSING AND
ADDING AN AGENCY THAT'S WILLING
TO DO THIS WITH THE- I MEAN.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE GOING TO
BE SITTING. ON THE CHAIR MAKING
THE DECISION SO THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT'S A PART OF THIS
BE TAKEN AWAY FROM THEIR
DIRECTION OR THEIR CONTROL.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE SITTING ON
THE BOARD MAKING DECISIONS IN
TERMS OF HOW THE APPROACHES THIS
IS DONE AND WHETHER ANY BALLOT
INITIATIVES ARE PUT ON THE-
TABLE OR SPECIFICALLY HOW THIS
IS DONE SO. I WOULD APPRECIATE-
GIVEN US YOUR SUPPORT AND
SENDING A SIGNAL. THAT BUT YOU
KNOW I HAVE THE SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO GO THROUGH THIS
PROCESS. AND WORK WITH MY
CONSTITUENTS TO DEVELOP. A BILL
THAT MEETS THEIR NEEDS THAT
ACHIEVES OUR GOALS AND
ULTIMATELY ACHIEVE THE GOALS OF
THE STATE. TO PROVIDE THE
HOUSING THAT WE DESPERATELY NEED
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL CALL
THE ROLL. THE SENATE BILL ELEVEN
OH FIVE BY SENATOR WAS SO THE
pREFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE SENATOR
WIENER AYE WIENER AYE BATES.
CABALLERO HOW TO YOUR AYE
CORTESE BUT WHAT HAS HE AYE
MCGUIRE. PHOTOBOOK NO. PHOTOBOOK
NOW SKINNER. SKINNER HI I'M
BURKE WHAT KASKY HI MY CASKEY I
. TWENTY ONE OKAY FIVE TO ONE
WILL PUT THAT ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU CENTER HUESO-
WE WILL NEXT- GO TO ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN SB FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN BY
CENTER HERTZBERG- SERVICE FOR
YOU MAY COME FORWARD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN THANKS
WILLINGNESS TO STEP IN FOR ME
THAT I WAS ABLE TO GET A LETTER
PLANES ARE. AND STILL DO WITH MY
OTHER ISSUES. ON. I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS BILL FOR- YES
AND- WELL OVER A YEAR. AND THE
POINT WHERE YOU KNOW WHEN YOU
DEAL WITH LEGISLATION IN IN THIS
AREA WHAT WAS THE PROBLEMS WHAT
ARE THE ISSUES I WAS TRYING TO
SOLVE IN COMING UP WITH THIS.
THE FIRST PRODUCTION. WE JUST
HEARD FROM THE- LAST AUTHOR
ABOUT THE ISSUE OF NOT HAVING
ENOUGH HOMES IN CALIFORNIA HOW
DO WE- INCREASE PRODUCTION OF
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
ESSENTIALLY. SO MANY LEVELS
QUESTIONS WHAT KIND OF HOUSING
IN LIKE THAT STARTING WITH THE
ISSUE PRODUCTION. SIX SECOND.
THE ISSUE OF THE RICH POOR
DIVIDE. WHEN WE BILL HOUSING
WHAT WE DO OFFICE LEGAL
DEPARTMENT. AND WHAT HAPPENED TO
THE APARTMENTS WERE SPENDING TAX
DOLLARS MONEY THAT WE COULD USE
FOR FOSTER KIDS OR FOR A
PRESCHOOL OR FOR OTHER SERVICES
THAT WE NEED TO PROVIDE FOR
GOVERNMENT RIGHT NOW WE GET A
BUNCH OF MONEY BUT I'VE
CERTAINLY LIVED IN LIFE WHEN
THAT HASN'T ALWAYS BEEN THE
CASE. AND SO YOU KNOW HOW CAN
YOU DO SOMETHING WE GIVE SOMEONE
A ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD BUT GIVEN
THAT OPPORTUNITY CRAIG
GENERALIZED GENERAL A
GENERATIONAL WEALTH TO BE ABLE
TO ACTUALLY OWN SOMETHING AND
YOU KNOW AS WE DO WITH THE RICH
POOR DIVIDE WE SEE IN THE
NEWSPAPER OF THE LAST. YEAR HOW
MANY RICH PEOPLE THAT RICHARD
RICHARD WE'RE FIGHTING FOR
EXAMPLE AFTER EXAMPLE IN
COMMITTEE AFTER COMMITTEE OF
DEALING WITH FOLKS WHO DON'T
HAVE RESOURCES AND SO HOW YOU DO
THAT. THIRD HOW DO YOU DO
WITHOUT TAX DOLLARS HOW DO YOU
DO THAT GREEN CROUCHING IN
CROWDING IN THE WITH ALL THE
OTHER OBLIGATIONS THAT WE HAVE
AND GOVERNMENT AGAIN NOW WE'VE
GOT MONEY BUT THAT IS NOT THE
CASE I GUARANTEE IT WE'RE GOING
TO SEE THE PENDULUM FOR ALL OF
US HAVE BEEN AROUND A WHILE WE
SURE THAT WORKS. AND SO WHAT
WE'VE DONE IS WE'VE PUT TOGETHER
A GROUP OF FOLKS FORMER DIRECTOR
OF FINANCE TO ENGAGE. FORMER
CHIEF ECONOMIST OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE LAWYER WHO
REPRESENTS- THE- THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING AUTHORITY AND- OR
CARRINGTON AND HEAD OF PUBLIC
FINANCE IT AT OR CARRINGTON AND
- HIS IS AT BAY THE FOREMOST
EXPERT ON HOUSING AND WE SAT
DOWN KIND OF WITH A BLANK SLATE
SO THAT WE FIGURED OUT. AND SO
WE'VE DONE IS WE'VE. KIND OF
REVERSE ENGINEERED. HOW TO GET
TO GO. BECAUSE THESE ISSUES BY
HOUSING. AND ALLOW THE PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT WHETHER IT'S KILLED
IN TRAIN. WELL THAT'S A QUESTION
OF IT WHAT IS IT GOING TO THE
RENT. WILL OWNERSHIP GOES INTO
THE PURCHASE PRICE. AND WHERE DO
YOU GET THE MONEY AND HOW TO
MAKE IT WORK SO BASICALLY THE
IDEA IS THIS AND THERE'S SOME
CHALLENGES AND- I WANT TO. JUST
FOR THE RECORD MAKE SURE WE
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS. AND APPRECIATE YOUR
YOUR IMPORTANT COMMENTS HERE
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO
BE DONE WE DON'T WITH THE
FINANCIAL FRAMEWORK. BUT AS I
SUGGESTED YOU CHAIRED TO THE
CHAIR OF THAT. THEY HOUSING
COMMITTEE THE OTHER HOUSE WE CAN
HELP. WITH YOUR HELP. SO THERE'S
MORE WORK TO BE DONE. BUT THE
BASIC FRAMEWORK IS HERE. SO WHAT
HAPPENS WE'RE GOING TO GO OUT
AND- PUT ON THE BALLOT WITH A
TWO THIRDS VOTE. THE TWENTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR BOND ISSUE. THAT
BOND ISSUES GOING TO HAVE TWO
COMPONENTS TO IT. THE FIRST IS
EIGHTEEN BILLION DOLLARS WITH
YOUR AMENDMENTS. WHICH IS GOING
TO GO FOR DOWN PAYMENT
ASSISTANCE AND THE OTHER SEVEN
BILLION IS GOING TO BE TO. HELP
IN UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES TO BE
ABLE TO PAY FOR OFF SITE.
IMPROVEMENTS WHY IS THAT
IMPORTANT. BECAUSE LOTS OF
TENSION PEOPLE DEVELOPERS GO TO
DEVELOP. THAT THERE'S THEY DON'T
HAVE SIDEWALKS OR
INFRASTRUCTURES YOU NEED TO
FIGURE OUT A FINANCIAL MECHANISM
WE USE THAT FINANCIAL MECHANISM
OVER THE YEARS. IN BELARUS OTHER
THINGS BUT WE NEED A FINANCIAL
MECHANISM HERE. SECOND THE IDEA
BEHIND THE BONDISSUE IS NOT TO
HAVE THE STATE PAY LIKE REDUCE.
WITH PART BONDS OR HAVE THE
STATE PAY LIKE REDUCE HOUSING
WITH WITH WITH SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION. THE IDEA HERE IT'S
CALLED WHAT'S CALLED THE SELF
LIQUIDATING BOND. SO WHY WE
DOING A GENERAL OBLIGATION BOND
WITH THE FULL FAITH AND CREDIT.
WELL EUROPE UPWARD PRESSURE
BECAUSE OF INFLATION UPWARD
PRESSURE BECAUSE OF COSTS. YOU
NEED TO FIND PLACES YOU CAN SAVE
MONEY WHEN YOU MAKE AN ECONOMIC
MODEL. IN THIS HOUSING SITUATION
IF WE CAN USE THE BORROWING
POWER AND THE GUARANTEE OF THE
STATE. AND BASICALLY THE
MORTGAGES ARE GOING TO PAY BACK
THE LOAN. THAT REDUCES INTEREST
COST IF YOU REDUCE INTEREST
COSTS. GIVES YOU MORE LATITUDE.
FOR BE ABLE TO GET PEOPLE TO
HAVE HOMES. SO BY HAVING THE
FULL FAITH AND CREDIT IT'S
CALLED THE SELF LIQUIDATING
BOND. AND SO THEY'LL BE A LITTLE
BIT THE INTERESTED WE CAN CHARGE
WILL BE LOT SMALLER ON THE
SECOND TRY STAY. ARE HERE'S
BASS. HOW IT. IN THE SAME. TERMS
SO. UP I WANT TO GO OUT. AND I
MAKE A QUALIFYING AMOUNT OF
MONEY IN THE FIRST TIME HOME
BUYER. AND I WANT TO BUY A HOUSE
I GO TO THE BANK. WE'RE GONNA
GIVE THE BANK BOARD OF A POINT
OR SOMETHING GIVEN COMMITTEE WE
INVEST MATT CREDIT. AND THEY'RE
GONNA GO TO. CALAIS JEFF FAY AND
THEY'RE GONNA GET A LOAN OF TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR YOU. YOU HAVE TO PUT
1% DOWN. BECAUSE WHAT WE LEARNED
FROM ALL THE DATA AND TALKING TO
ALL THE EXPERTS IS THAT THERE'S
NO DOWN PAYMENT WHATSOEVER. THAT
THE DEFAULT RETIRED. SO IF IT'S
A SEVEN FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
HOUSE. YOU KNOW YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE TO COME UP WITH
757-700-0500 DOLLARS. BUT THE
HUNDRED FIFTY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLAR DIFFERENCE FOR THE DOWN
PAYMENT. WILL COME FROM. THIS
FUND. NOW WHAT HAPPENS. THAT
THAT MONEY THAT COMES FROM THE
FUND. GETS RECORDED AS A SECOND
TRUSTEE WE CALLED A SILENT
SECOND. AGAINST THE HOUSE SO
BANK OF AMERICA OR WELLS FARGO
YOUR CREDIT UNION HAS THE FIRST
TRUSTEE. FOR WHATEVER IT IS THE
SECOND TRUST DEEDS RECORDED. NOW
HOW DOES THAT GET PAID. WHAT'S
GOING TO BE IT'S GOING TO BE A
FORTY YEAR LOAN. WITH FIFTEEN
YOUR PAYOFF DATE. SO THE ARAB
WHAT WE KNOW FROM THE DATE AS
THE AVERAGE PERSON CELLS ARE
HOUSE AND NINE YEARS WE RUN ALL
THE NUMBERS WITH THE EXPERTS.
DETERMINE WE CAN PAY THIS OFF.
AND MAKE SURE THAT THE SELF
LIQUIDATING FUND WORKS. AND AT
THE END OF THE DAY IF YOU WANT
TO SELL THE HOUSE SOONER. LIKE
WE SEEN BEFORE WITH THREE
FINANCES. YOU HAVE TO PAY OFF
SECOND TRUSTEE. IF YOU. KEEP
YOUR HOUSE FIFTEEN YEARS WILL BE
A BALLOON PAYMENT YOU'LL PAY IT
OFF. THE STATE'S PROTECTED. WHAT
HAPPENS THE BORROWER HOW DOES
THE- THAT OF THE INVESTORS WHO
ARE BUYING THESE BOND GET PAID
BACK. WELL THEY'LL BE TEMPTED
INTEREST OF. WHATEVER SMALL
PERCENTAGES SMALLEST PERCENTAGE
WE CAN DO WELL RUNNING AND THE
NUMBERS ON THAT. AND IT'LL YOU
COULD PAY ALONG THE WAY IF YOU
WANT TO. OR IF YOU DON'T HAVE
THE CASH FLOW. YOU'LL PAY IT OUT
OF THE SALE. SO HOPEFULLY
THERE'S AN INCREASE IN VALUE OF
THE HOUSE. YOU PAY OFF THAT LOAN
ELIZABETH HAPPENING IF YOU HAVE
EQUITY. YOU'LL BE ABLE TO BUILD
WEALTH AND MORE IMPORTANTLY IF
YOU'RE THERE FOR TEN YEARS.
GUESS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU'RE A
RENTER. WHEN YOU'RE A RENTER AT
THE END OF TENURE HERE'S- WOULD
YOU HAVE HIRING HERE YOU HAVE A
RATE MORTGAGE IT NEVER UP WHEN
YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH MINIMUM WAGE US FOLKS
WHERE'S THE MONEY GO GOES TO
PLACES ARE UTILITY BILLS AND
HIGHER RENT ALL OF A SUDDEN NOW
YOU HAVE LESS PRESSURE ON THE
RENT SO IT'S ALL ABOUT
HOMEOWNERSHIP IT'S AN ELEGANT
WAY TO USE THE GOOD THE FULL
FAITH AND CREDIT OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO REDUCE COSTS WE'RE
PUTTING IN FOR SKILLED AND
TRAINED PEOPLE ARGUE IN THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WORLD IN THE
RENTAL SITE WILL THAT COST MORE
MONEY. WILL GOING TO CENTER
CRETACEOUS POINT WE'RE NOT GOING
TO SUPPORT A SYSTEM THAT GETS
PEOPLE CAN AFFORD TO LIVE THERE
WITH THEM EIGHT PEOPLE
REASONABLE WAGES WITH ALL THE
VARIOUS BELLS AND WHISTLES ARE
NECESSARY AND WITH THAT
INCREASES THE COST AT THE END OF
THE DAY WE'RE NOT WORRIED IT FIT
ROLLS INTO THE PRICE WHICH IS
THEN PAID WHEN YOU DO THE
ECONOMICS AND WE HAVE THE
ANALYSIS WHICH I CAN SHARE WITH
YOU WHAT THOSE NUMBERS LOOK LIKE
AND SO BASICALLY IT IS A PRETTY
ELEGANT WAY. TO CREATE
EXTRAORDINARY ECONOMIC FEEDBACK
AFFECT THE PROPERTY TAX IMPACTS
GREAT THE CHALLENGES THAT THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE CHAIRMAN
RAISED WHICH I THINK APPROPRIATE
IS WE'RE NOT QUITTING LEVITTOWN
THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE A PLACE
WHERE WE'RE JUST WE'RE GONNA
HAVE COULD TAKE SOME CONTROL ON
THIS FALL WILL BE A LOT OF PARTS
OF THE STATE WITH US WE REALLY
REALLY GREAT. FIRST TIME
HOMEBUYERS GUESS WHAT THEY GET A
NEW HOUSE WITH NEW APPLIANCES
WITH NEW EVERYTHING YOU'RE NOT
BUYING GRANDMA'S HOUSE WITH A
LEAKY ROOF AND LEAKY PIPES AND
ALL OF A SUDDEN YOU BOUGHT IT
NOW YOU GOT AN EXPENSE TO FIX
THE EIGHT THE HVAC SYSTEMS OR
SOMETHING ELSE WE GOT A BRAND
NEW PLACE WITH WARRANTY PARTS
AND DONE THROUGH SKILLED AND
TRAINED SO THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THAT IT IS IT IS A WAY I THINK
PRETTY ELEGANTLY AS I USE THAT
TERM TOO MUCH TO MEET ALL THE
GOALS AND I'M DEEPLY CONCERNED
AS WE- LOOK AT ALL THE
LEGISLATION THAT WE TALK ABOUT
AND IN THIS CHAMBER. AND ISSUES
THAT WE FACE BECAUSE OF THIS
RICH POOR DIVIDE HOW DO WE
CREATE A SYSTEM WHERE WE ALLOW
PEOPLE TO BUILD WEALTH HOME IS
WHERE THE WEALTH. IS MOST PEOPLE
HAVE WELL FOR THE WHOLE WE'VE
GOT A- OF THE GAME WE'VE GOT TO
MOVE AWAY. ALL THIS. I HAVE
IN MY COMMUNITIES WHERE THERE'S
A SEVEN EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR RENTAL HOUSE FOR A LITTLE
SMALL FOR STILL GOING TO NOTHING
THING. AND IT'S A RENTAL. LEVEL
GETS THE OPS. HEADED GETS THE
HEADACHES AND THE INCREASE
BILLS- CENTER CUBBY EUROS IS A
JOINT AUTHORS CENTER PORTANTINO
IS- CENTER ROTH WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERS HAVE SIGNED
ON. BY OBJECTIVE IF ANYBODY
WANTS TO HELP WE'RE HERE WE
STILL HAVE A LOT MORE WORK TO DO
THIS. BILL IS TRIPLE REFERRED.
TO IN TERMS OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO. SO ALL I CAN SAY IS THAT.
ARMED WE GOTTA CHANGE UP THE
GAME AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE. AND THE- THE
REASON THAT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS OF THIS MONEY IS DODO
DEVOTED TO WHAT WE CALL
MEZZANINE FINANCING OFFSITE.
IMPROVEMENTS IS AGAIN. WE DON'T
WANT THIS JUST TO BE IN CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES WE WANT COMMUNITIES
THAT DON'T HAVE ACCESS. TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THE REVENUE. AND
THEN THE DEVELOPER WILL PAY OFF
THAT DEBT LOAD. FROM THE SALE OF
THE PROPERTY. AND SO. WE THINK
IT WORKS PRETTY WELL WE'VE DONE
A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT ANALYSIS ON
IT. AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS WE'VE GOT- THE
BUILDING TRADES HERE. THE
JOURNEY WOULD GO. ALWAYS OVER
THERE AND THEN ALSO I BELIEVE
MATT CALLAHAN. I DON'T KNOW IF
WE CAME INTO YOU GUYS BUT I KNOW
HE'S WANTS TO TALK ABOUT IT
FROM. HOME OWNERSHIP GROUP IN IN
LOS ANGELES TO- TESTIFYING
BEHAVE. ON BEHALF OF US MEASURE
GREAT THANK YOU CENTER HERTZBERG
I WILL NOW GO TO A SUPPORT
TESTIMONY FOR SB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN AND- SO WE HAVE TO THE
WITNESSES. OF FIRST- MISTER
SMITH IN THE BUILDING TRADES-
AND YOU'LL EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES
TO CENTER HER TREATED SEVEN OF
THE SECOND. MADE WITH US. YES
OKAY SO. TWO MINUTES THIS IS A-
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE. SOME YOUR BEHALF
OF THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION COUNCIL- IN SUPPORT
OF SB FORTY SEVEN. I'D BE REMISS
IF I DID TAKE A COUPLE SECONDS
HRE- TO LET EVERYBODY KNOW
REMIND EVERYBODY THAT THE ROOM
WERE IN THE BUILDING WE'RE IN
WAS BUILT. BY SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKERS APPRENTICES AND
JOURNEYMEN AND WOMEN. FROM THE
BUILDING TRADES- I HOPE YOU ALL
LIKE THE BUILDING- WE- I THINK I
THINK IT'S WONDERFUL LOOKS
BEAUTIFUL BUT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE- POINT OUT THE FACT
THAT. OUR MEMBERS BUILT THIS
BUILDING. OF THE WAGES AND
BENEFITS THEY'VE EARNED ALLOWED
THEM TO CARE FOR THEIR FAMILIES
AND- HELP LOCAL ECONOMY. AND
THOSE WAGES AND BENEFITS NO
DOUBT HELP MANY OF THEM BY
MAINTAIN THEIR OWN HOMES. WHICH
IS WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY AND WHAT
WE BELIEVE AS SB FORTY THIRTY
SEVEN WILL ALLOW. THOUSANDS OF
OTHER FAMILIES TO DO. ON THE
AMERICAN DREAM. AS THE TO THE
ANTENNAS. TO ADDRESS THE HOUSING
CRISIS AND BUILD MORE HOMES FOR
THE MIDDLE. AS WELL AS ALL OF
OUR MEMBERS RESIDE. IN THE
MIDDLE. EVERYBODY EARNS MONEY IN
DOWN PAYMENT ASSISTANCE TO
WORKING CALIFORNIANS WHO
OTHERWISE WOULD BE TRAPPED IN A
VICIOUS CYCLE OF RUNNING.
FOREVER LIKELY INCLUDING MANY OF
OUR MEMBERS THAT WE THAT I
REPRESENT. WHO DREW BEING FIRST
GENERATION HOMEOWNERS AN
INNOVATIVE IDEA. WITH MANY OF
OUR MEMBERS ENTER THEIR
FRIENDSHIP THEY DO SO HOPING.
THAT THEY WILL BE ABLE TO EARN
ENOUGH TO BUY THEIR OWN HOME.
WITH THE YARD IN A NICE
NEIGHBORHOOD CLOSE TO GOOD
SCHOOLS IN MANY OF THEM ARE ABLE
TO DO THAT BECAUSE OF POLICIES
LIKE MODEST BUILDING THE CAPITAL
BECAUSE THE PREVAILING WAGE.
BECAUSE OF THEIR TRAINING. SB
FORTY FIFTY SEVEN WILL PROVIDE
THAT CHANCE TO THOUSANDS OF
OTHER CALIFORNIA'S AS WELL. ON
TOP OF THE INNOVATIVE WHETHER
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE FUNDING
TO WORKING. FAMILIES IT IS THE
CONSTRUCTION WORK THAT WILL COME
FROM THIS BILL. GONZALEZ WORK
THAT WILL GO TOWARDS THE PRE
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS. THAT WILL
ALLOW THE CONSTRUCTION WORKERS.
ON THESE PROJECTS TO EARN A
MIDDLE CLASS NEIGHBORHOOD. WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT SENATOR HERTZBERG
AND MANY OF YOU IN THIS ROOM
THANK YOU SENATOR CORTEZ HE- OF
YOUR COMMENTS- AGREE WITH THIS.
PREMISE AND THAT CENTER
HERTZBERG IS INCLUDED LANGUAGE
IN THE BILL THAT WILL ENSURE THE
WORKERS DOING THE PRE
DEVELOPMENT WORK. NEEDED TO
BUILD THE HOMES WILL COME FROM
CALIFORNIA STATE APPROVED.
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS AND WE
PAY THE PREVAILING WAGE. THOSE
WORKERS WILL GET THE JOB DONE
RIGHT THE FIRST TIME WE DON'T
BELIEVE. ANY OF THAT HE WAS
REQUIREMENTS INCREASES COSTS.
THE AMOUNT TIME DEVELOPER SAVE
ON THE BACK END BY HAVING WORK
DONE RIGHT THE FIRST TIME. WE
THINK MORE THAN. MORE THAN MAKES
UP ON ANY ON ANY INCREASED
COSTS- THE BILL PROVIDES
MORTGAGE ASSISTANCE NEW HOME
CONSTRUCTION. OPERATIVE ON THE
WORKING AND MIDDLE CLASS WHICH
IS A BENEFITS OF THE WORKERS
BILLION HOUSING. CAN AFFORD TO
BUY. WE BELIEVE THAT WE CAN
BUILD OUR WEATHER'S HOUSING
CRISISBUT THAT IT SHOULD NOT BE
DONE. ON THE BACKS OF EXPLOITED
IN LOW WAGE WORKERS. AGAIN WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT SENATOR HERTZBERG
REASON YOU CAN'T HAVE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WITHOUT PROTECTION FOR
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS. WERE
PLEASE NAY POOREST REPORTING
PARTIES. THANK THANK YOU RIGHT
NOW CENTER WHO THE SECOND WHEN
THAT REALITY MIGHT JUST BE
CALLING IN ON THE REGULAR YEAH
SO- THE MODERATOR- YEAH WHAT
WILL PROBABLY HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THE NORMAL THANK YOU- AND THEN
MISTER CALLAHAN CAN CAN SPEAK-
HELLO ABOUT MINUTES TWENTY
SECONDS- SO IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM- WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OF SB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN. SAME NUMBER OF THE PHONE
LINE- MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE. TO UP- SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MR. GOOD FOR SUPPORT FOR SB
ONE FOUR FIVE SEVEN THESE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME GET- PRESS
ONE ZERO FOR SB ONE FOUR FIVE
SEVEN. AND NINE FORTY YOUR OPEN
. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MATT
CALLAHAN WAS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
PARTNERS AND HOMEOWNERSHIP
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN.
HOMEOWNERSHIP IS A WEALTH
BUILDING POWER HOUSE FOR LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
TO PROVIDE THE PREDICTABLE
MONTHLY HOUSING EXPENSE THAT
ACTUALLY BECOMES MORE AFFORDABLE
AS A HOMEOWNERS ICOME RISES.
HOMEOWNERSHIP OFFERS BETTER
HOUSING PRESERVATION WITH
FAMILIES FACE DIFFICULT
FINANCIAL TIMES IT PROVIDES
SUPPORT FOR FUTURE FINANCIAL
GOALS LIKE RETIREMENT AND IT'S
THE MOST DIRECT PATH PROVIDING
GENERATIONAL WEALTH.
HOMEOWNERSHIP GROSS ATTACK SPACE
CREATES COMMUNITY STAKEHOLDERS
IT STIMULATES THE ECONOMY AND
THE NEIGHBORHOODS WITH HIGH
HOMEOWNERSHIP RATES WE SEE LOWER
CRIME RATES AND IMPROVE SCHOOL
TEST SCORES. HOWEVER WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
LANDSCAPING CALIFORNIA WE SEE
THAT THE STATE'S OVERWHELMING
INVESTMENT PRIORITY HAS BEEN AND
CONTINUES TO BE HIGHLY
SUBSIDIZED RENTAL HOUSING
PROJECTS THAT GENERATE BIG FEES
FOR DEVELOPERS AND PROPERTY
MANAGEMENT- BUT DO NOT HELP LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS ACCESS THE
TYPE OF HOUSING THEY REALLY
WANT. AND THAT'S HOMEOWNERSHIP
S. B. OF FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
GOES A LONG WAY PROVIDING
BALANCE TO THE STATE HOUSING-
AFFORDABLE HOUSING STRATEGY. THE
DOWN PAYMENT ASSISTANCE
FINANCING OF WILL PROVIDE AS A
CREATIVE WAY TO FILL THE
AFFORDABILITY GAP LOW INCOME
HOMEBUYERS FACE AND IT ALSO
EFFECTIVELY REMOVES THE SAVINGS
BARRIER. SB FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
WILL LEVERAGE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND PRIVATE MORTGAGE
CAPITAL SIGNIFICANTLY EXPAND THE
STATE HOUSING STOCK CREATE HIGH
PAYING JOBS AND IT DOES ALL THIS
WITHOUT HITTING THE TAXPAYERS
WALLETS. FOR ALL THE REASONS-
JUST STATED WE SUPPORT SB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN AND THANK
CENTER HURTS HERTZBERG CHRIS
LEADERSHIP IN EXPANDING
HOMEOWNERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES. IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE
TELEPHONE MR MURRAY IN SUPPORT.
I NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME GREAT WHEN I GO TO
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM MR CYRUS- MARC STATUS OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP THIS BILL BENNETT
PRINT A FEW MORE DAYS IN THE
LAST ONE SO WE ALSO DON'T HAVE
AN OFFICIAL POSITION. BUT WE
HAVE COMMUNICATED SOME COMMENTS
TO THE AUTHOR- WE ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE EFFORT TO
PROMOTE HOMEOWNERSHIP THAT IS
ALWAYS A GOOD THING TO STABILIZE
HOUSING COSTS AND BUILD WEALTH
WE HAVE EXPRESSED A FEW CONCERNS
ONE. THAT IF WE'RE GOING TO PUT
A GENERAL OBLIGATION BOND ON THE
BALLOT PARTICULAR ONE OF THIS
SIZE IT'S LIKELY TO CROWD OUT
OTHER BACK OTHER MEASURES- IT
SHOULD INCLUDE BOTH RENTAL
HOUSING AND HOMEOWNERSHIP THERE
ARE MANY LOW INCOME PEOPLE IN IN
VERY LOW INCOME PEOPLE. WHO HAVE
NO HOMES AT ALL WHO ALSO NEED TO
BE SERVED AND OUR STATE OF
PROGRAMS TO SERVE THOSE
POPULATIONS ARE ACTUALLY-
AWARDING ALL THE LAST OF THEIR
FUNDS FROM THE LAST GENERAL
OBLIGATION BOND. SECOND IS JUST
THAT- THERE A COUPLE PROVISIONS
IN THE BILL THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
UNDERMINE EXISTING OCC
AFFORDABILITY PROVISIONS IN SB
THIRTY FIVE AND IN LOCAL
INCLUSIONARY ZONING ORDINANCES
WE BELIEVE THAT WILL ACTUALLY
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF AFFORDABLE
HOMES THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
LOWER INCOME FOLKS SO WE WILL
CONTINUE WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
BUT WE'VE SHARED THOSE CONCERNS
AND WE'LL WE'LL- HAVE MORE
COVERAGE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY IN THE HEARING ROOM
SINGLE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES WILL THE MODERATOR PLEASE
I ASK FOR OPPOSITION. TESTIMONY
FOR PEOPLE TO STATE THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION IF ANY. AND THE FACT
OF THEIR OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
MISTER. IF YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY
OPPOSITION TO SB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN. AND WE
WILL LINE ONE OH SIX ONE OF SIX
EURO. RIGHT AWAY WITHTHE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM
AGAIN WOULD ECHO THE REMARKS.
VETERANS YEAH. AND A FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION SB.
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN. NOBODY
ELSE WAS QUEUING UP THE
STRUCTURE GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BRING THIS BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS CENTER
BY CAL SKI. YEAH I GUESS. WHAT
HE TALKED ABOUT- LOW INCOME
PEOPLE HIGH INCOME PEOPLE I
THINK THIS IS REALLY. A MEASURE
ON THE MISSING MIDDLE I MEAN IT
CALL IT WHAT IT IS I MEAN IT'S
NICE. MY UNDERSTOOD MY READING
OF IT IS SB THIRTY FIVE ONLY
KICKS IN. IF PEOPLE WANT TO USED
TO STREAMLINING BENEFITS OF SB
THIRTY FIVE OTHERWISE THIS IS
JUST A REGULAR. HOUSING PROJECT
THE GOES AND GETS ENTITLED THIS
AM I WRONG ON THAT YEAH I KNOW
YEAH I THINK IT IS THE IDEA HERE
BEHIND THIS IS THAT. IS THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO OFFER AN
INCENTIVE TO DEVELOPERS THAT
WILL COME IN AND BULD. THE
COMMITTEE ADDED ON TO A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE FOR- MIXED USE WHICH
I THAT'S KIND OF COOL BECAUSE
YOU GET AT THAT IN. TERMS OF THE
YOU GET THAT FINANCED WITH
COMMERCIAL SIDE BUT IT'S REALLY
MODEL ON A PRIVATE SECTOR MODEL
IN A SENSE OKAY. BECAUSE YOU
GOTTA MAKE THE RATE OF RETURN
FROM INVESTORS I KNOW THE POINT
STRIVERS ABOUT. ABOUT MENTAL BUT
THEN THAT MEANS IF IT'S RENTAL
THAT MEANS TACKLE USING TAX
DOLLARS TO PAY FOR THIS WE GO TO
THE L. A. ONLY ASK THE L. A. O.
TO MODEL THIS WE WANT TO SHOW
IT'S A LOW RISK TO TAXPAYERS
OBVIOUSLY AT SOME POINT BECAUSE
THEY'RE GOING TOWARD. WITH THE
WHOLE THEORIES TO MOVE AWAY FROM
THAT AND MAKE IT A PRIVATE
SECTOR MODEL NOW. THE PUT IT
WHAT WILL PROBABLY DO IS THE
RESULT OF HOW THE LANGUAGE OF
THE COMMITTEE PUT IN WHICH IS
IMPORTANT I GET IT. WILL
PROBABLY HAVE SO A DEVELOPMENTS
IF CONDOS A ROW HOUSES OR
SOMETHING IN. IT AND- CENTER
CARPIO'S DISTRICT AND MAYBE
DEDICATE SOME OF THOSE FOR LOWER
PRICED. BUT THE DELTA HAS TO BE
MADE UP WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO WORK OUT THAT FINANCE OUR
FINANCE PEOPLE TO TELL US.
THAT'S WORKABLE. BUT IT'S NOT IN
THE NORMAL CONTEXT OF. AS WAS
INDICATED BY MISTER CALLAHAN THE
TRADITIONAL SUBSIDIZED RENTAL
MARKET. THIS IS THE MISSING
MIDDLE IT IS THE POLICE OFFICER
AND THE NURSE. AND THE AND THE
WORK RATE IS THE TEACHER. WE ARE
THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE TO EVERY
SINGLE DAY. ARE SPENDING EVERY
NICKEL THEY HAVE TO LIVE AND
THEY CAN NEVER COME UP WITH THE
SCRATCH. FOR A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR A DOWN
PAYMENT FOR SEVEN FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR HOUSE. WE'RE GONNA WRITE
IN THAT CHECK. THEY COME UP WITH
SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
AND THEY CAN GET A HOUSE. GET ON
THE ROAD TO START MAKING MONEY.
AND HAVING ALL THE BENEFITS THAT
WORK TO KILL ANYBODY. REALLY IS
NOT. DESIGNED FOR THAT BECAUSE
IT'S A FINANCIAL MODEL. THE I
DON'T THINK ANYTHING PRECLUDES.
ONCE THE PROJECTS. WELL WE CAN
DEAL WITH. YOU HAVE TO THE MODEL
HAS TO BE THAT MISSING MIDDLE
AND WHAT. IF THE PRICE OF IT IS
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY AND THEY
GOTTA. PUT ALONG TOGETHER FOR
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND THAT GETS A
LOT OF PEOPLE OUT YOU KNOW. AND
IF IT GOES UP TO MILLION IN SOME
AREAS. HE GIVE A 1-005-000-0800
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. SO THAT
PUTS A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT SO IT
MAY BE. PEOPLE WITH THAT WORK
FOR US NO THAT DISCONTENT
DISCONNECT DISTRACTED IT'S TRUE
IT'S TRUE IT'S NOT ESSENTIAL
IT'S A GROWING PROBLEM. WHAT DO
YOUR ECONOMIST SAY ON THE
FIFTEEN- YOUR BALLOON WHILE I
KNOW THAT THAT GIVES US COMFORT
IF I'M HOLDING. THE LOAN BUT-
TELL ME HOW THAT WORKS
ECONOMICALLY BECAUSE- BECAUSE-
IN THE LAST THREE YEARS WE'VE
SEEN THE PRICES GO UP.
ASTRONOMICALLY IT'S A NOTHING
BURGER IT'S EASY PEOPLE GET THAT
BUT I DON'T KNOW GOING FORWARD.
IF WE'RE GOING TO SEE THAT
APPRECIATION. OF THAT'S GOING TO
MAKE THESE REFINANCING DEALS.
SIMPLE WELL TWO POINTS THE
GENERAL CASKET WHAT NUMBER ONE
IS WE ANALYZE A HUNDRED FIFTY
FOUR YEARS OF THE GROWTH HOUSING
IN TERMS OF WHAT IS THE REASON
QUITE FRANKLY. WITH ALL THESE
INVESTORS ARE COMING IN BUYING
UP HOUSING EVERYWHERE BECAUSE TO
UNBELIEVABLY GOOD MODEL NUMBER
ONE. NUMBER TWO IS WE'VE WRITTEN
IN THE FLEXIBILITY FOR CALLAGY
FAYE TO THE EXTENT CHANGE MODIFY
SO BECAUSE AGAIN. WHAT ARE WE
DOING HERE EVEN IN TERMS OF
THESE NUMBERS IT HAS TO BE
BALANCED BY OUR PUBLIC POLICY
IDEAS. WITH A FINANCIAL MODEL
THAT WORKS. BECAUSE THE REASON
FINANCIAL MODELS WORK ON SOME OF
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS
BECAUSE THE GOVERNMENT USES TAX
DOLLARS. INSTEAD OF PAYING FOR
PRESCHOOL OR FOSTER CARE
WHATEVER AND THEY PAY THE
DIFFERENCE AND SO THIS IS A
PRETTY INTERESTING WAY. TO
ACHIEVE THAT THAT THAT SPREAD
HOW DO YOU LIKE OKAY OUR COSTS
ARE HIGHER BECAUSE WE'RE GETTING
WANT TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE GET
FAIR WAGES WHAT WE'RE GONNA OVER
HERE REDUCE INTEREST COSTS
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE
STATE. FIGURES THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WE WANT TO
INCENTIVIZE DEVELOPERS WITH HIS
SB THIRTY FIVE WITH THE LATENT
DEFECTS WITH OTHER THINGS BUT
GET I DON'T THINK ACTUALLY
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION WHICH IS.
YOU IF YOU WANT THE BENEFITS OF
THIS PROGRAM YOU HAVE TO BUILD
UNDER THIS PROGRAM. NONE OF
THESE BENEFITS AND NONE OF THE
MONEY GETS ACCESSIBLE TO YOU OR
THE BANKS THAT CALIPERS OR TO
ANYBODY UNLESS WHEN YOU START A
PROJECT YOU AGREE TO. CONFORM TO
THIS PROGRAM YOU CAN FOR THE
PROGRAM. NOW. SOMEBODY GOES TO A
LOCAL BANK. THEY IN THEIR SEVEN
DOLLARS SEVEN DOT FIVE ZERO. AND
THEIR CREDIT REPORT AND WHATEVER
THEIR NUMBERS ARE. AND THEY GET
A HOUSE YEAH AND THEN THEY CAN
SELL IT TO SOMEBODY ELSE
AFTERWARDS WENT OUT OF THE
SYSTEM. BOTH ITS REVOLVING IT
CREATES ABOUT WE THINK ABOUT A
HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND HOUSES
WHAT WE BEST ESTIMATE. AND WE
SAY FOR EVERY MILLION IT BILLION
HALF DOLLARS THAT WE SPEND. IN
THIS DEVELOP AND WE GET TO A ONE
BILLION AT ONE ELEVEN BILLION
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY. THE LOAN THE
PROPERTY TAX INCREASES LEVEL OF
THE OTHER ECONOMIC ACTIVITY. THE
END LET ALONE ALL THE IN INCOME
TAX AND STUFF THAT HAPPENS
RESULT OF THE BUILDING. BUT IS
AN EXTRAORDINARY ECONOMIC MODEL
I JUST WANNA TELL YOU. THAT THIS
IS REALLY IMPORTANT NOT JUST FOR
BUILDING HOUSES BUT SOME YEARS
AGO WE DID A NUMBER OF SCHOOL
BONDS. AND WHEN YOU TALK TO THE
FOLKS IN THE CONSTRUCTION TRADES
THEY SAID THAT THEY SAVE THEM
WHEN WE GOT TO THE DOWNTURN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT. BUILDING ALL
THOSE SCHOOLS WAS ABLE TO KEEP
MONEY IN THE SYSTEM TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE COULD STILL WORK. AND WE
DID THAT SO THIS TO ME IT HAS A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT BENEFITS- BY
THE COR. GIVING PEOPLE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO OWN A HOME AND
UNFORTUNATELY CENTER WE DON'T
THINK MANY OF MY GONNA FIND
HOMES IN YOUR PLACE. YOU KNOW
BUT TO AT THE CENTER CABALLERO
SHE'S GONNA HAVE A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY HER COMMITTEES. AND
SENATE ROTH AND OTHERS AND JEFF
IN A VALLEY FOR ME AND THINGS
LIKE THAT SO IT'S UNFORTUNATE WE
HAVE A LOT OF SPACE TO BUILD
HOUSING IN SAN FRANCISCO. TRUST
ME. UP SO SORRY BUT THANK YOU
GREAT ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS COLLEAGUES THE
OFFENDER JOGO I DO HAVE A COMMON
NIGHT. SO UNDER THIS PROGRAM-
PREVAILING WAGE IS PRETTY MUCH A
SET DEAL ON IRAQ CORRECT SO
THERE WAS A CONCERN OR COMMENT
NOT THINK IT'S ARE MORE OF A
COMMENT ABOUT. MAKING SURE THAT
PEOPLE RECEIVE LIVING WAGES
CORRECT RIGHT SO. BY YOUR
ASSERTION IT DOES INCLUDE A
PREVAILING WAGE WHICH DOESN'T
MEAN OR SHOULD I SAY LET ME ASK.
ME FRIEDMAN A LITTLE DIFFERENT
THE PREVAILING WAGE BEING IN
THERE. MEANING YOU DON'T HAVE TO
OR PEOPLE THAT ARE NON LABOR. AT
COMPANIES HAVE TO PAY THAT
PREVAILING WAGE YEAH THE FISCAL
BETWEEN WORKERS THAT'S CORRECT
ALL THEY HAVE TO BE WHAT SAYING
ISN'T I'M NOT SAYING THEY ARE
NOT. YET WOMEN FROM NINE EIGHT
SO JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT I
CLARIFY YOU DO NOT HAVE TO BE A
UNION. THE COMPANY TO. THE TO
PAY THAT PREVAILING WAGE CORRECT
I. JAMIE YEAH MISTER SMITH FOUR
CORRECT REFORM WRONG THE SKILLED
WORKFORCE VERSIONS DON'T MANDATE
UNION MANDATES THE WAGE LEVEL
AND THE MANDATES THAT A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE OF THE WORKERS HAVE
TO COME OUT OF A START STATE
CERTIFIED APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM- AND THAT CAN BE UNION
OR NONUNION AND PRACTICE IT WILL
TEND TO BE MORE LIKELY TO BE A
UNION BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT THE
LAW REQUIRES OKAY SO JUST MAKING
SURE SO- FOR THE BIDDING PROCESS
FOR THIS PARTICULAR PROJECT DOES
THAT INCLUDE ANYONE THAT IS NOT.
CONSIDERED A LABOR. AB COMPANY A
CONSTRUCTION COMPANY TO BE ABLE
TO BID ON THIS JOB AND THE
REASON I ASK IS THAT I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THERE WAS A COMMON IN
THE PREVIOUS SPELL THAT. WE ARE
VERY LIMITED I'M NOT SURE IF IT
WAS ON FORMALLY OR INFORMALLY
BUT- COMMITTEE OR I CAN MEET
BUT- THERE'S A LIMITED AMOUNT OF
CONSTRUCTION COMPANIES IN
CALIFORNIA THEY CAN CONSTRUCT.
AND SO WHAT THAT DOES IS IF YOU
LIMIT THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE THE COMPANIES THAT CAN BID
ON THOSE PROJECTS ME IS THE
PRICE OF THE PROJECTS GO OUT. IF
WE OPEN IT TO EVERYONE AND
ANYONE HERE THAT IS LICENSED
UNDER THE STATE DO YOU HAVE A
CONSTRUCTION COMPANY AND HAVE
THE ABILITY TO WORK. BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF. DAVID NON
LABOR. AT TRAINING
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THAT CAN
ALSO- PROVIDE SKILLED AND
TRAINED. LABOR BUT I'M JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT. IF WE'RE
GOING TO SUPPORT PROJECTS IN THE
STATE THAT WE TALK ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING AN ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY AND HAVING- DIVERSE
OUT POOLS OF PEOPLE COMING AND
HAVING THAT CAN MAKE OPPORTUNITY
IS BEING- NON DISCRIMINATORY I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE- AT THE STATE CREATING
PROGRAMS THAT ALLOWS ANYONE.
THAT IS LICENSED UNDER THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WITH THEIR OWN
PRIVATE- TRAINING- FOR THEIR
THEIR EMPLOYEES TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BID ON
THIS PROJECT AND WORK ON THESE
PROJECTS ANSWER MY GOVERNMENT
MR. THE GERMAN SUGGESTED GETTING
HIS THOUGHTS IN THE NASCO
HELPLESSNESS THAT'S OKAY MR YES
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR THANK YOU
SENATOR WINNER- THE PROJECT
REQUIRES A VENDOR FOR REALLY
WAGE- ANYBODY THAT DOESN'T
PRECLUDE ANYBODY BIDDING ON A
PROJECT IF SOMEBODY BUT PERSON
OWNS A BUSINESS AND THEY DON'T
WANT TO BID ON THE PROJECT
BECAUSE OF PREVAILING WAGE THAT
IS THEIR CHOICE- BUT MOST STATE
FUNDING AS AS- CUT PUT UNDER
THIS BILL MOST A FUNDING
REQUIRES A PANDER PREVAILING
WAGE. THERE ARE ALSO A LARGE
NUMBER OF NON UNION STATE
APPROVED APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
THE I. DIVISION OF A PERSON'S
STANDARDS- CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP COUNCIL THEY BOTH
KEEP THOSE NUMBERS AND KEEP THAT
DATA BUT THERE ARE THERE ARE
JOINTLY- MANAGEMENT UNION- SAID
BUT PROGRAMS AND THERE ARE NON
UNION UNILATERAL CITIGROUP
PROGRAMS. SO FOLKS WHO ARE NON
UNION- WOULD BE ABLE TO QUALIFY
TO BID. ON THE PROJECTS
CONTEMPLATED BY THIS BILL. A
CORRECTED ONE OF THE THING THAT
THINKS IMPORTANT. YOU MIGHT MY
VIEW. IS THAT WHEN YOU TRY TO
SOLVE A PROBLEM WHICH IS THE
SAME REASON OF SAYING- BUT JUST
GO GET PRODUCTION EACH I TRY TO
DO A WHOLE HOST OF THINGS IN A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT LEVELS. AND
WE'RE ECONOMIC REPORTS GOING TO
SHOW IS THAT CALIFORNIA'S THE
HIGHEST RENTS IN THE NATION OKAY
THE AVERAGE WAGES STATEWIDE IN
CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY FOUR DOLLARS
AN HOUR AND HOUSEHOLDS MUSTARD
THIRTY NINE DOLLARS AN HOUR. I
TO AFFORD AN AVERAGE TWO BEDROOM
PLACE SO THE IDEA IS IT WOULD BE
HOLY AND JUST TO BE IN A
SITUATION WHERE YOUR BILL THE
HOUSE FOR SOMEONE SAY WHO IS A
TEACHER OR A FIREFIGHTER OR
WHATEVER. TO GO AND THAT THE
HOUSE BUT THE WORKER COULDN'T
SUPPORT SO IT REALLY IS A
HOLISTIC VIEW IT'S NOT OBVIOUSLY
YOU SAW IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE A
UNION BUT IT HAS TO BE PEOPLE
TRADE. AND THE OTHER PART OF THE
SKILLED AND TRAINED PIECE IS THE
QUALITY OF THE WORK. OFF ON YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE REASONS WHY WE
HAVE A TEN YEAR LAKE DEFECT LAW
IS BECAUSE THE QUALITY OF THE
WORK OF WE'RE NOW WE'RE GOING TO
SAY WE'RE GOING TO FIVE YOUR
WIFE BECAUSE YOU'RE GOING TO
BUILD FOR THE GOLD STANDARD AND
REALLY DO IT RIGHT WITH PEOPLE
ARE SKILLED AND TRAINED. AND NOT
HAVE HE'S SAID SUB STANDARD
SITUATIONS THAT HAVE OCCURRED
OVER THE TIME SO I JUST THINK
IT'S REALLY KIND OF IN A
SITUATION AS TO HOW WE'RE
DEALING WITH THIS OFFER THAT I'M
I'M JUST A- WE WISH BUT WE WILL
LITERALLY MEET EVERY FRIDAY
MORNING IN THE SPENDING. SHORT
AMOUNT OF TIME TRYING TO THINK
IT THROUGH IN A NON POLITICAL
WAY TO A BUT BY THE WAY THAT
SAYS HOW DO YOU SOLVE THESE
MAJOR PROBLEMS THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH. IN CALIFORNIA GIVE
OPPORTUNITY REALLY TO THE MIDDLE
AND LOWER MIDDLE AND TERMS WITH
THOSE. NUMBERS ULTIMATELY ARE
SOME PRETTY EXCITED ABOUT IT.
JEFF HAD LEFT A YOU. AS A- SO MY
CONCERN IS THAT THE PREVAILING
AND- FINE WITH THE PRE WAGE AND-
ON THAT I DO UNDERSTAND IT'S MY
IT'S BEEN MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
ANYTHING THAT IS STATE FUNDED IS
AND QUALIFIES FOR PREVAILING
WAGE THAT IS NOT AT ALL MY
CONCERN I THINK MY CONCERN IS.
MOSTLY AND I PROBABLY THE NUMBER
ONE PRIORITY IS THE FACT THAT I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T
PUT IN STATUTE WHO CAN AND
CANNOT- HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BID ON THESE PROJECTS FOR ANY
COMPANY THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THAT. I WON I DO BELIEVE IN
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY AND I THINK
THAT IS VERY VERY POOR THAT IS
THE AMERICAN DREAM AND NUMBER
TWO THAT- WHEN WE WHEN WE
SPECIFY THE TYPE OF LABOR THAT
WE WANT OR WHO CAN AND CANNOT
WORK WE REALLY DISCRIMINATING
ACTUALLY. FOR THAT OF EACH AB
FOR THAT ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY
AND SO THAT THAT IS MY BIGGEST
BIGGEST CONCERN AND USUALLY-
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT WHEN
WE DO PUT THESE ARCHELAUS IN
PLACE IT REALLY AT DESCENT OF
ISIS PEOPLE FROM BIDDING ON THE
PROJECTS BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT
THE CHANCES OF THEM GETTING
PICKED UP. AS THE CONTRACTOR
ACTUALLY DIMINISHES THEIR
OPPORTUNITY FROM ACTUALLY
PURSUING THESE THESE CONTRACTS
AND SO THAT TO ME IS OF A
CONCERN BECAUSE ONCE AGAIN.
BASED ON MY PREVIOUS COMMENTS I
WANT EVERYONE TO FEEL THAT THEY
HAVE THE RIGHT IN THE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY TALK ABOUT EQUITY
THIS IS EQUITABLE TALK ABOUT
EQUITY. EVERYONE HAS AN EQUAL
CHANCE OF GETTING THESE
CONTRACTS- AND AS FAR AS THE
NOTION OF SKILL AND TRAIN
BECAUSE IT MAY- YOU ARE
GUARANTEED A BETTER PRODUCT I
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE THE FREE
MARKET- IN PLACE. THE COM. THAT
DON'T PROVIDE A QUALITY GOOD.
WILL NOT BE CHOSEN OR SELECTED
ON ANY OF THESE FACTORS NO
MATTER HOW LOWER OR HOW HIGH THE
PRICES THEY WILL NOT BE IT THEY
WILL NOT BE SELECTED BECAUSE OF
THE REPUTATION THAT YOU HAVE OF
NOT BEING A- QUALITY CONTRACTOR
OR PRODUCING A QUALITY PRODUCT
SO I THINK THE NATURAL AT
TENNESSEE WOULD BE THAT ANYONE
THAT DOESN'T NEED A STANDARD
WILL AUTOMATICALLY BE EXCLUDED
FROM CONSIDERATION FROM
CONTRACTS SO. I'M VERY MUCH OF
THE OF THE MINDSET THAT YOU
BETTER HAVE A GOOD QUALITY
PRODUCT EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE AN
EQUITABLE AMOUNT OF OPPORTUNITY
TO BID ON THESE PROJECTS WE
SHOULD PUT IN PLACE SOMETHING
THAT WILL BE SENT TO VICE PEOPLE
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT YOU KNOW
WHAT. WE'RE NOT OUR CHANCES OF
GETTING BIT WE'RE NOT EVEN GOING
TO GO TO THE PROCESS AND THE
EFFECT THAT HAS ON THE COST OF
THOSE PROJECTS BECAUSE WHEN YOU
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
BIDDING ON THESE PROJECTS THEN
YOUR COST YOU KNOW EVERYBODY
THAT IS CURRENTLY ABLE TO BID ON
THESE PROJECTS CAN INFLATE THE
PRICE A LITTLE- YOU KNOW HIGHER
BECAUSE- THIS IS GOING TO BET ON
IT. YOU'RE LIMITED ON HOW IT WAS
TO I MUST HAVE BEEN A NET IT
INADEQUATE IN HOW I EXPLAIN THIS
THERE IS NO VETTING PROCESS
THERE IS NO SELECTION THE NEW
MAKES THE SELECTION EXACTLY A
FREE MARKET THE CUSTOMER SO NOW
THERE'S THREE DEVELOPERS WHO GO
OUT AND SAY- FREMONT CALIFORNIA
AND EACH BUILDING FIFTY UNITS
OKAY. EACH BUILDING AND THEY'VE
QUALIFIED IN THIS PROGRAM THEY
HAVE SB THIRTY FIVE THEY. MET
ALL THE PROGRAM'S REQUIREMENTS
THAT ARE THERE. DEVELOPER ONE
DOLLAR PER A DEVELOPER FOR. CAN
WHO MAKES THE CHOI. THE
DETERMINATION OF COSTS ARE. THE
COST OF THEIR MATERIALS WHAT ARE
LABOR COSTS DON'T HAVE LABOR
COSTS THE SAME IMAGE ACROSS TO
THE SAME WILL DOUBLE MODEL THIS
IN A WAY THAT THEY CAN MAKE
MONEY BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO DO THIS AND SHE GONNA MAKE
MONEY. AND THEN IF ONE MAKES A
BETTER PRODUCT GET THE ONLY
THERE'S NOBODY ALSO MAKES A
CHOICE THE PERSON MAKES THE
CHOICE OF THE CUSTOMER I DECIDE
TO BUY MR MAKOWSKI SAID
DEVELOPERS BECAUSE HE'S RATHER
RATHER MISTER CORTESE'S PRODUCT
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S QUALITY IS
BETTER AND THEY MAKE THE CHOICE
THERE'S NO BIDDING CONTEST IN
THAT SENSE. AND EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF THE CONTRACTORS ARE GOING TO
HAVE THE SAME PRETTY MUCH THE
SAME COSTS FOR LABOR COSTS SO
YEAH AND SO THE ARGUMENT IS WILL
INCREASE COSTS BUT THAT'LL BE
ABSORBED OVER TIME IN TERMS OF
THE AMORTIZATION. OF THE PAYMENT
BECAUSE THE HOUSE MAY COST A
LITTLE BIT MORE BECAUSE LABOR
COSTS WITH MORE SO THE DOWN
PAYMENTS AT A BIT MORE THE
MORTGAGE PAYMENT COSTS ARE LESS
BECAUSE INTEREST RATES ARE LESS
AND IT WORKS IT'S LIKE WHEN YOU
GO TO LISA TOYOTA. AT THE STORE
YOU DON'T LOOK AT WHAT THE COST
OF THE ALTERNATOR IS THE TIRES
YOU SEE WHAT'S MY MONTHLY
PAYMENT THIS IS BASICALLY THE
SAME THING WAS THE QUALITY
PRODUCT I LIKE IT AND WHAT'S MY
MONTHLY PAYMENT THOSE ARE THE
THINGS TO THE DEVELOPER NEEDS TO
MAKE A PROFIT. THE BANK NEEDS TO
MAKE PROFIT TO MAKE IT WORK THE
OWNERS GOT TO HAVE SOMETHING
THAT THEY CAN THAT THEY CAN.
THAT THEY LIKE SO NOBODY ELSE IS
MAKING THE DETERMINATION OF
PRICE OTHER THAN THE AND THE
QUALITY OF THE WORK OTHER THAN
THE CUSTOMER AND THAT. AT THE
CORE IS CAPITALISM. OKAY SINGLE
. COME OR QUESTION- THROUGH
MOTION. CORRECT SO- CENTER
HERTZBERG THANK YOU FOR
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE MEMONS
FRAMEWORK ON THE WORK US OUT IF
WE SHOULD TO HELP- WE NEED HELP
ABSOLUTELY THE- OF COURSE THE
YOU KNOW THIS BILL BEING UP
TWENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL OBLIGATION BOND THAT IS.
AN ISSUE FOR- FURTHER COMMITTEES
ON THE GOVERNOR AND PROTON IN
THE SPEAKER AT CETERA AND GOT ON
IT SOMEWHERE BUT WE WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE HOUSING
POLICY ITSELF WAS AS GOOD AS IT
CAN BE COME OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE I APPRECIATE YOU
INCLUDING SB THIRTY FIVE
STREAMLINING- WHICH HAS- WHICH
DOES DOES HAVE PREVAILING WAGE
AS WELL AS A SKILLED WORKFORCE
AND HAS BEEN. VERY SUCCESSFUL
AND STREAMLINING TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF HOMES IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS IN CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU FOR INCLUDING THAT- ALSO-
WHAT I LIKE ABOUT THIS BECAUSE
IT'S NOT LIMITED TO SINGLE
FAMILY YES I GREW UP WITH AND
WITH THE BACKYARD WILL LOVE
BACKYARDS- BUT OUR MOST
CALIFORNIANS ARE MANY
CALIFORNIANS DO NOT A PRIVILEGE
OF FORTY IN BACKYARD- AND AS A
MATTER OF SAVING MOTHER EARTH
FROM CLIMATE DESTRUCTION- WE
CAN'T- SINGLE FAMILY HOMES AND
BACKYARDS ARE NOT GOING TO BE
THE SUSTAINABLE FUTURE WE HAVE
TO ALSO. FOCUS ON MULTI UNIT IN
SUSTAINABLE LOCATIONS ARE
SPEAKING OF WHICH I'M ONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS HOW DOES LIMIT THE
BILL TO NON SPRAWL AREAS SO- THE
DEFINITION OF INFILL SO THAT
WE'RE NOT- EXACERBATING OTHER
CLIMATE FOR WILDFIRE CRISIS- IN
ADDITION- ALLOWING A MIXED USE
FOR MULTI UNIT WHICH IS
IMPORTANT- AND HAVING AN INCOME
CAP TO INCLUDE THE BROAD MIDDLE
CLASS. ARE AND SO APPRECIATIVE
OF THAT- SO- I SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND THE MARKET RUNNING AND I
VOTES- AND WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A FROM CENTER CORTEZ C. ABROAD.
FLETCHER KILEY OF COVER YOUR I'M
SORRY RIGHT THANK THEM VERY
CONFUSED THAT I JUST I DON'T
CABALLERO MOVED AND- YOU MAY
CALL. AND IT'S JUST VERY- EIGHT
MADE BY AND IT ALSO ADAPTIVE
REUSE. THE ADAPTIVE REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT CAME FROM THE
CITY BY THE FOR GOVERNMENT. GET
A WHOLE THIRTY WAS NEW BUT IF
SOMEONE LIKE LIVES IN IT- A
COMMERCIAL BUILDING GETS
CONVERTED OR A SHOPPING CENTER
GETS CONVERTED BUT IT IT'S A NEW
PRODUCT. FOR PEOPLE IT'S
HOUSING. IS FINE IT'S NEVER TRY
TO BE AS EXPANSIVE POSSIBLE IN
STRAIGHT IT IS POSSIBLE TO MAKE
THAT WORK SO. OFTEN ON THE
BALLOT I AM WORKING ON THAT HAVE
BEEN. TASKED WITH THE BOOK FROM
THE PROJECT TO WORK ON THE
BALLOT WE HAVE NO THE BOND
ISSUES AT THIS POINT THEY MIGHT
BE SOME COMING UP. IN TERMS OF
THAT BUT THE WHOLE IDEA IS NOT
TO BE NOT TO IMPOSE THE
OBLIGATION OF THE CHECK ON
TAXPAYERS. AND TO REALLY SHOW
THE PUBLIC THAT WE'RE DOING
SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY GOT SOME
CREATIVITY TO IT AND GIVE PEOPLE
HOPE BUT A LOT OF HOUSES AND
IT'S AN ONGOING PROGRAM WITH A
LOT OF FLEXIBILITY. AND SO WITH
THAT I CERTAINLY WOULD ASK DR
VOTE AND IF ANYBODY'S INTERESTED
IN JOINING AS AN AUTHOR CO
AUTHOR ON THIS. AT THE MORE THE
MERRIER BECAUSE MANY TWO THIRDS
VOTES IN BOTH HOUSES TO GET THIS
ON THE BALLOT. BETTER LOVE IT
AND WOULD LIKE AS MANY IDEAS AS
POSSIBLE BECAUSE IT'S- IT'S HARD
NOT HARD BUT IT'S A RIGHT THING
TO DO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OF
CENTER HERTZBERG WE WILL CALL
THE ROLL. THIS IS SENATE BILL
FORTY. FIFTY SO. PERCENT
HERTZBERG. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE. SENATOR
WIENER. AYE WIENER AYE BATES.
CABALLERO CABALLERO I CORTESE.
RETIRES HE AYE MCGUIRE.
PHOTOBOOK NO. A CHAU BOOK NOW
SKINNER. THE NUMBER. WE CASKEY
HI MAKOWSKI I THIRTY ONE THE
BILL HAS ENOUGH- OR NOT HAS FOUR
VOTES I WILL PUT ON CALL FOR UP
TO MEMBERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OUR ABOUT THE CAR LESS BILL-
COULD WE PLEASE- NOTIFY CENTER
MAGUIRE'S OFFICE ANSWER SCHEMES
OFFICE THAT WE ARE STARTING A
LOS BILLS WE CAN OUT ON MORE
WORK DONE- OUR LAST BILL- IS S.
B. 1482% OR ALLEN CENTER THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- PATIENCE AND YOU
MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL. RIGHT AND
THE AND BY THE WAY- I DON'T KNOW
THE BEGINNING OF THESE ARE
UNBELIEVABLY SHORT PODIUMS AND
SO YEAH- YOU SHOULD PROJECT
BECAUSE YOU'RE A TALL LIKE I AM
IT WILL NOT NATURALLY CUT YOUR
VOICE. STATURE OKAY. RIGHT WE'RE
WORKING ON A BY THE WAY YEAH IT
IS A- YOU DO OKAY. SECOND THAT
READ- WELL OKAY SO THIS BILL-
REQUIRES NEWLY BUILT MULTI
FAMILY RESIDENCES IN OUR STATE
TO PROVIDE ELECTRIC VEHICLE
READY CHARGING ACCESS FOR EVERY
HOUSING UNIT THAT IS ALLOCATED
TO PARTIES. I'M NOT SHOULD I
SHOULD POINT OUT THAT IT DOESN'T
REQUIRE CHARGING BOX IT DOESN'T
EVEN REQUIRE A PLUG- IT DID JUST
REQUIRES THE CAPABILITY OF THE
SOMEBODY WANTED. TO MOVE FOR
WITH WITH WITH CHARGING THAT
THAT THEY BE ELECTRICITY THERE
FOR SOME OF THE CHARGE- YOUR-
EXCELLENT COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT. A NUMBER OF KEY
THINGS ABOUT THE HISTORY AND HOW
IT GOT TO THIS POINT- TALKS
ABOUT GOVERNANCE AND EXECUTIVE
ORDER THAT. CALLS FOR A PHASE
OUT OF THE SALE OF NEW INTERNAL
COMBUSTION ENGINES BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE. THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION JUST DID A BIG
STUDY ON THIS AND- IF YOU HAVE.
QUINCY SEE WE'VE GOT OUR TIRE
STATE HAS JUST SEVEN PERCENT. OF
THE V. CHARGING POINTS THAT THE
COMMISSION ESTIMATES THAT WE'RE
GONNA NEED TO SUPPORT THIS
TRANSITION. SO WE NEED A ONE
POINT TWO MILLION OR SEVENTY
NINE THOUSAND. SOMETHING LIKE
THAT SO- THE- ONE THING IS CLEAR
POWERING UP AT HOME. IS THE
CHEAPEST MOST CONVENIENT AND
MOST RELIABLE FORM OF FUELING AN
EEVEE- BUT THOSE BENEFITS ARE
FAILING TO REACH COMMUNITIES
THAT NEED THE MOST. I IN OF
FOLKS YOU'VE GOT AS SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES GOT THEIR OWN
GARAGE IS ALMOST ALWAYS A- PLUG
THEIR- YOU YOU KNOW IF I'M ABLE
TO CHARGE MY AB FOR EXAMPLE- BUT
A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
MULTI FAMILY UNITS. ARE NOT SO
LUCKY. HI RETROFITTING CONDOS
AND APARTMENT BUILDINGS AFTER
THEY HAVE BEEN CONSTRUCTED. IS
NOT JUST COMPLEXITY IT'S ALSO
INCREDIBLY EXPENSIVE. A LOT OF
FOLKS HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
AND THEY RUN INTO BRICK WALLS
BECAUSE THE EXPENSE. R. BUT IF
YOU INSTALL THE EEVEE READY
CHARGING FROM THE VERY BEGINNING
WHEN YOU CONSTRUCT- IT'S A
CREDIT IT'S SIGNIFICANTLY LESS
EXPENSIVE I'LL TALK A BIT MORE
ABOUT THAT. SO THEY DIDN'T THE
NEWLY IT UPDATED TWENTY TWENTY
TWO CAL GREEN BUILDING CODE ONLY
REQUIRES GIVING 40% OF MULTI
FAMILY PARKING SPOTS. ACCESS TO
SOME FORM OF YOU CHARGING.
MEANWHILE THE PATCHWORK OF ONLY
OVER THREE DOZEN LOCAL BUILDING
CODES IS CREATING CONFUSION FOR
BUILDERS. IT'S LEAVING BEHIND
MANY COMMUNITIES SUCH AS FIRE
FOLKS AND FIRED IF DEVASTATED
REGIONS AND RURAL AREAS- THESE
ARE FOLKS. THEY TYPICALLY LACK
THE CAPACITY TO DO ALL. SO MY
STAFF IN THE BILL'S SPONSORS.
HAVE BEEN IN TOUCH WITH SOME OF
THE FOLKS WHO RAISED CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL- I AM VERY
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THEM.
I TO FIND AS MUCH COMMON GROUND
IMPLEMENTING THIS FRAMEWORK AS
POSSIBLE. THERE'S THREE KEY
TOPICS THAT WE'VE BEEN FOCUSING
ON FIRST OF ALL MAKING A VERY
CLEAR THE BILL ONLY APPLIES. TO
NEW CONSTRUCTION. TWO
SPECIFYING- THAT PROVIDING EVEY
READY CHARGING ACCESS DOES NOT
OBLIGATE A LANDLORD OR BUILDING
MANAGER TO PAY FOR THE
ELECTRICITY. TO CHARGE ANY
RESIDENTS VEHICLE. I UNDERSTAND
THAT ARE YOU KNOW YOU DON'T
THERE'S AN EQUITY ISSUE THERE.
BETWEEN THOSE WHO DO HAVE ANY
YOU KNOW THE DON'T. AND FINALLY
ENSURING THAT THE LEGISLATION IS
WORKABLE. IN INCIDENCES WHERE-
PARKING SPACES ARE NOT PRE
ASSIGNED TO RESIDENCES AND THIS
IS A CONCERN WE'VE BEEN TALKING
TO FOLKS IN THE APARTMENT
HONORED COMMUNITY. ABOUT OUR
STATE CLEARLY HAS A LOT OF WORK
TO DO TO MAKE THE V. CHARGING
TRULY ACCESSIBLE TO CALIFORNIANS
FROM ALL WALKS OF LIFE IT'S NOT
DEMOCRATIZES THEM YET
UNFORTUNATELY. WE KNOW AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER THE UP FRONT
COST OF ADDING TV READY CHARGING
ACCESS FOR ALL NEW UNITS
REPRESENTS. OUR ONLY POINT 003%
OF A TYPICAL BUILDINGS COSTS AND
HERE'S WHAT'S IMPORTANT FOR
FOLKS TO NOTE. IT'S JUST 10% OF
THE PRESS TO INSTALL THE SAME
CONSTRUCTION RETROFIT. SO A LOT
OF OUR COLLEAGUES HAVE PUT FORTH
BILLS TO. REQUIRE WE BE
DISCUSSING THIS IN THE- IN THE
CLIMATE WORKING GROUP YOU KNOW.
PUTTING IN. YEAH REQUIRING EVERY
ABILITY TO PUT IN THE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE BACKSTAGE- GREAT
IDEA SEARCH BUT SO EXPENSIVE- AT
THE VERY LEAST WE SHOULD BE
STARTING WITH ALL THE NEW
CONSTRUCTION WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING MAYBE SOME OF THE NEW
CONSTRUCTION ALL HAPPEN UNDER. A
CENTER HERTZBERG BOND- IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO GET THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING SO MUCH MORE.
COST EFFECTIVE. SO THIS IS A- AN
IMPORTANT WAY FOR US TO REACH
OUR- GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
TARGETS AND DEMOCRATIZE ACCESS
TV CHARGING. AND I'VE GOT TO
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE TODAY-
REPRESENTING THE BILL'S CO
SPONSORS THE FIRST LINDA
HUTCHINS KNOWLES. WHO THE SENIOR
MANAGER BACK TERRACE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM AND THEN
ALSO- CERVANTES AND WHO'S THE CO
FOUNDER OF THE EEVEE CHARGING
FOR ALL COALITION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR ODD OKAY SO
WE'VE TO. SUPPORT WITNESSES-
BOTH BY TELECOM- IN THE HEARTS
AND SOULS AND THEN SPEND THAT
ST- YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES OF
THE FIRST WITNESS GOES LONGER
THAN TWO MINUTES IT WILL COME
OUT OF THE SECOND WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES SO. THE MINDFUL- YOU MAY
PROCEED. GOOD MORNING OR GOOD
AFTERNOON NOW SENATORS. I'M
LINDA HUTCHINS KNOWLES AND ON
BEHALF OF ACCURATE AND EASY
CHARGING ACCESS FOR ALL
COALITION PROUD CO SPONSORS OF
THE SPELL I URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THE PURPOSE IS SIMPLE TO PROVIDE
RESIDENTS OF NEW APARTMENTS AND
CONDOS THE SAME ACCESS TO AT
HOME EASY CHARGING THAT NEW
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES HAVE HAD
SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN. HERE'S A
TRUE STORY AND TWENTY NINETEEN
REBEKAH LUCKY PERSONS TO BEEF.
SINCE HER APARTMENT MAX CHARGING
SHE DROPPED AN EXTENSION CORD TO
THE GROUND BELOW TO CHARGE AT
THE CURB. THE MANAGER DE IN THE
COURT OF TRIPPING HAZARD SHE WAS
OR THE PUBLIC TURKEY BUT
IMPROVED A WORKABLE QUOTE. I
THINK AN HOUR IF YOU TO STOP IN
CHARGE IS A DEAL BREAKER FOR OUR
FAMILY THE KIDS ENDED UP PLAYING
IN THE PARKING SPACES A SAFETY
HAZARD. AND ACOSTA FAST PARKING
ARE TO ME HI. THERE ABOUT THE
TURNED RETURNED HER ET AND
RECEIVE DRIVING A GAS CAR.
REBEKAH STORY OF. THE FACT THAT
BACK TO BACK. TO AFFORDABLE
SPEAKERS MEDIA TURKEY. PUT
EDIE'S OUT OF REACH FOR MOST
RESIDENTS OF APARTMENTS AND
CONDOS. ENSURING THEY GET THIS
ACCESS IS ESSENTIAL TO REACH OUR
CLIMATE GOALS. BY TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE ALL NEW CARS SOLD IN THE
STATE. SB ZERO EMISSION. SO WHY
IS IT ACCEPTABLE TO BUILD NEW
HOUSING BUT PARKING SPACES THEY
CAN'T CHARGE THOSE FEES. AND
THAT'S WHAT OTHER AGENCIES LIKE
CARBON XTC HELLO HOPE FOR USING
BILLIONS OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO
RETROFIT HE'S VERY. STATE
BUILDING IN JUST A FEW YEARS. IT
MAKES LITTLE AND FOR IT
NEGLIGENT. HELLO MUST STOP TO
GET A HOLD DEEPER. THE QUOTE
FIND IT NUMBER GC YOU MUST BUILD
HOUSING NOW THAT'S PREPARED FOR
THE QUICK MOBILITY FUTURE EVENTS
STUCK IN THE FOSSIL FUEL PASSED.
EQUITY IS ALSO AT STAKE HERE THE
MAJORITY OF MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
RESIDENTS ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR IN
COMMUNITIES HEAVILY BURDENED BY
AIR POLLUTION. FOR TOO LONG THE
CALGARY COATIS PERPETUATED
INFRASTRUCTURE RACISM LUCKY MANY
BLACK AND BROWN RESIDENTS OUT OF
THE U. B. REVOLUTION. VOTING
AGAINST OUR BILL IS A VOTE TO BE
6270% OF RESIDENTS OF NEW MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING WITHOUT ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE AT HOME CHARGING.
SUPPORT EQUITY CLMATE CLEAN AIR
VOTE I. N. S. T. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THAT ARE SECOND THIS. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M SPEND THIESSEN AN
ENGINEER WITH EIGHTEEN YEARS OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLE EXPERIENCE AT
PG&E AND FOR CLEAN ENERGY AND MY
OWN ET CONSULTANT FOR OUR
COALITION IS DEDICATED TO
EXPANDING ACCESS TO EASY
CHARGING WHILE MINIMIZING COST
AND COMPLEXITY FOR BUILDERS
RESIDENTS AND THOSE WHO OPERATE
THESE BUILDINGS. WE ACKNOWLEDGE
THE HIGH COST OF HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION IN CALIFORNIA BUT
ANY CLAIM THAT THIS BILL IS A
COST PROHIBITIVE MANDATE IS
INACCURATE IN FACT THERE ARE
SEVERAL PROVISIONS THATACTUALLY
KEEP BUILDING COSTS AS LOW AS
POSSIBLE FIRST BILL DOES NOT
REQUIRE THAT EVERY PARKING
SPACE. IN A MULTI FAMILY COMPLEX
BE WIRED FOR EASY CHARGING
INSTEAD IT PROVIDES THAT EVERY
NEW UNITS WITH PARKING HAS
ACCESS TO ONE E. V. READY
PARKING SPACE. FOR EXAMPLE IF A
ONE HUNDRED UNIT COMPLEX HAS TWO
HUNDRED PARKING SPACES ONLY ONE
HUNDRED NEED ELECTRIFICATION NOT
ALL TWO HUNDRED. SECOND THE BILL
MINIMIZES BUILDER COMPLEXITY AND
COSTS BY ELIMINATING CAL
GREENSTREET. IBV CHARGING
CAPABLE ASSEMBLY LOW POWER TV
READY. THIRD THE BILL REDUCES
OPERATIONAL COSTS BY ENCOURAGING
RUNNING THE WIRING D. A. EACH
UNITS METER RATHER THAN THE
COMMON METER THIS ELIMINATES THE
NEED FOR OVERSIGHT BY APARTMENT
MANAGEMENT OR THE H. AWAY WHILE
ENABLING RESIDENTS ACCESS TO
THEIR UTILITIES LOWEST ELECTRIC
RATES. AN EXPERT REVIEWED
ECONOMIC ANALYSIS DETERMINED
THAT THIS BILL WILL ONLY
INCREASE NEWBUILD COST BY ZERO
POINT ZERO THREE PERCENT.
FURTHER IT IS PROJECTED THAT
BETWEEN TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND. TWENTY TWENTY FIVE NINETY
THOUSAND BRAND NEW UNITS WILL
REQUIRE FULL RETROFITTING AND A
UTILITY PROVIDE A COST OF ONE
POINT FIVE. BILLION DOLLARS
VERSUS ONLY. TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION TWO WHY ARE THEM AT THE
OF INITIAL. THANK YOU FOR MUCH
OF A COULD- ONE OF. IF LESSONS
YEAH THIS BILL WILL FURTHER
ACCELERATE EASIEST OPTION AS
OTHER STATES FOLLOW OUR-LEADERSHIP. BOOSTING OUR LARGEST
EXPORT ELECTRIC VEHICLES B. Y.
STEWARDS OF OUR RESOURCES AND
EQUITABLE THE MULTI FAMILY
RESIDENCE APPROVED S. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY I
IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SEEING NONE WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINE WHICH
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY SUPPORT AND
OF A PLEASE JUST STATE YOUR NAME
YOUR AFFILIATION IF ANY AND THE
FACT OF YOUR SUPPORT. I THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR ANYBODY ON
THE PHONE LINES THAT WISHES TO-
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT. OF SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TO PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE
WERE LIKE ONE OF THREE YOU ARE
OPEN. THE BILL MURPHY FOR ELDERS
CLIMATE ACTION NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS FOR THE
THOUSAND MEMBERS IN SUPPORT.
NEXT IS LINE ONE FOURTEEN YOU
ARE OFTEN. HI DR CRAVEN
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY
ENVIRONMENTAL PROFITS AS WELL AS
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DEMOCRATIC
PARTY ELECTED MEMBER AND MEMBER
A FEMINIST IN ACTION AND THE
ELECTRONIC COLLECTIVE STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO. FIVE ONE TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
SEAN ARMSTRONG WITH REDWOOD
ENERGY ONE THE NATION'S LEADING
ENVIRONMENTAL CONSULTANCIES FOR
ALL ELECTRIC CONSTRUCTION
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU. BY NINETY NINE YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO THIS IS GERRY JOHNSON
SENIOR MANAGER OF ALL THE SENATE
RELATIONS AND APPAREL. RIGHT NOW
ALL THE VISION STRONG SUPPORTER
SB FOURTEEN NINETY TWO.
EXCELLENT ONE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS DR WINDY
RAIN FROM CLIMATE NINE ONE ONE-
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT STILL. ONE
ONE TWELVE YOU HAVE THE FLOOR.
HELLO MY NAME IS LEGAL OR
MILLIGRAM GARTNER I LIVE IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND I'M WITH
CALIFORNIA INTERFAITH POWER AND
LIGHT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
ONE ONE TWENTY ONE RURAL. HELLO
MY NAME IS ABOUT THE MILITANT
AND I REPRESENTS THE NINE
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT NUMBER
BERKELEY CLIMATE ACTION
COALITION ON THE LEFT THE
POSITION WORKING GROUP AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT SB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO. PLEASE GO
AHEAD ONE THIRTEEN YOU ARE OPEN
. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. K. THIS IS
THE NOT THE WAR HIGH I AM
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF TWO
ORGANIZATIONS TODAY AT MOST
FINANCIAL- IS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO I
AM ALSO SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
PLUG IN AMERICA REPRESENTING
EVEY DRIVERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. WHEN ONE TWENTY FOUR YOU
ARE OPEN. FOR TWENTY FOUR FEET
ON YOU. FINAL SHOT ONE TWENTY
FOUR WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY.
LIVING ON ONE WILL GO TO ONE
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROGER DICKINSON
ON BEHALF OF CIVIC WILL FORMALLY
BILLION LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE ONE FIFTEEN YOU ARE UP.
HELLO THIS IS DEBBIE MY CELL
PHONE HELLO ALSO AND I REPRESENT
PENINSULA INTERFACE CLIMATE
ACTION WERE A GROUP OF ABOUT
FIFTEEN CONGREGATIONS ON THE SAN
FRANCISCO PENINSULA AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU. NIX'S NINE
ONE THIRTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN. I'M
THIRTY ONE PLEASE ON YOUR. ONE
THIRTY ONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TESTIFY HELLO. THE PREVAILING
MARKET PRESIDENT OF THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ATHLETES
WORKING EIGHTY SEVEN. AND WE
WILL GO TO ONE EIGHTEEN YOU ARE
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS. ALL OF US
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. FIND ONE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SH
HI MY NAME CRISTINA HERNANDEZ.
AND I AM A RESIDENT OF BAMA TELL
COUNTY AND THE STUDENT AT RYLAND
COLLEGE AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. B- FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU. ONE SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SANTIAGO
WITH CALIFORNIAN BY MENTAL
MOTORS COMING IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ONE ONE TWENTY THREE YOU ARE
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS EMILY TRIBE
I'M MORE INTRODUCED HER FUTURE
IN TERMS TO GO ANYWHERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SD FORTY TWO.
THANK YOU ARE THE FINAL REMINDER
ONE ZERO TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
FOR SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TO NINE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON KATHY SHAPER FOR THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY CLIMATE
REALITY PROJECT IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE ONE
TWENTY NINE YOU ARE OPEN. HI
THIS IS ON THE CALIFORNIA FROM
SAN RAFAEL REPRESENTING COOL THE
EARTH WE ARE A STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE S. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO.
ONE ONE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON ERIN
RODRIGUEZ THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS IN SUPPORT OF US THE
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
AND WE WILL GO TO ONE THIRTY
FOUR YOU ARE OPEN. OKAY HI MY
NAME IS JIM THOMPSON I'M WITH.
THIS IS WHAT WE DID AND WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT SB FORTY MILLION
. PROJECT THANKS TO KOREAN AGL
ONE MORE PATRISTIC UP ONE MOMENT
MISTER CHAIR. ONE TWENTY THAT
YOU ARE OPEN. I FELT BETTER. I
THINK WILL BE I WILL GO LINE ONE
THIRD THAT. JANET CAR FOR THREE
FIFTY THOUSAND VALLEY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AFFECT.
SENATOR ALAN. MISTER CHAIR THERE
NOR THE PARTICIPANTS CUED UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOW GO
TO OPPOSITION- WE DON'T HAVE
ANY. OFFICIAL LEAD UPON A
REGISTERED IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WOULD HAVE THOUGHT GOING TO
TESTIFY AS A LEAD OPPONENT.
NATALIE JUST TO ME TOO OKAY WHAT
I'M MORE HAPPY THAT ME TOO SO
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM PLEASE COME FORWARD- CHRIS
FOR SAKE WITH WESTERN
MANUFACTURED HOUSING COMMUNITIES
ASSOCIATION WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR- WE DON'T HAVE A LETTER
IN ON THIS YET BUT WE HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT IT SO. I WILL
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
BUT RIGHT NOW WE ARE OPPOSE THAT
RIGHT. BUT WILL WORK WITH YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SIGNAL GOT OF THE PHONE
LINES ANY OPPOSITION. BY PHONE
IF YOU COULD PLEASE QUEUE UP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION FOUR SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
ANYBODY ELSE GOING AT ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND WE WILL LINE
THIRTEEN YOUR OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THE CHAIR COMMITTEE
BRADY GARDEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING OFFICIALS
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
WHY ONE HUNDRED- PLEASE GO AHEAD
. YES HI GOOD AFTERNOON FILL
THE- FOREVER IN BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSE
POSITION TO LOOK FOR TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR. WHERE THERE IS
ONE MORE QUEUING UP. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. ONE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GET YOUR MEMBERS THAT
BRAND WITH THEIR AND READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING A SEVEN
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THERE'S NO MORE OPPOSITION
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE COGS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOR THE AUTHOR. OF
SENATOR- SHOW BOTH DID YOU
REVIEW OR SEMI CAL. I THINK I DO
HAVE SOMETHING THAT I WILL BE
WORKING RECURSOS CENTER MICHAEL
WITHIN OUR HOUSE YOU. FOR THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M I'D LIKE TO
MOVE THE BILL- I HAVE I'D LIKE
TO REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR WORK ON
THE ACTUAL COSTS BECAUSE- YOU
ALWAYS HAVE BEEN DOING SOME
CALCULATIONS AND 3% OR POINT
003% OF A MILLION IS ONLY LIKE
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS I CAN'T
BE RIGHT SO MAYBE IT'S THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS BUT IF IT'S
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS JUST TO
PUT THE PLUG AND JUST RUN THE
WIRE OVER HUNDRED UNITS THAT'S
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOES THAT
THAT CAN'T BE RIGHT THAT THAT'S
JUST WAY TOO MUCH MONEY FOR THE
TOTAL OUT ADDITIONAL ELECTRICAL
WORK THAT WOULD BE DONE. ON THE
SITE TO NOT INSTALLING THE UNIT
SO I THINK IT'S A GOOD BILL I
THINK HE HAD A BETTER IT'S A
BETTER SAILING SOMEONE IF THAT
THAT PRICE GOES DOWN BUT- YEAH
THAT'S THAT'S IT. THANK THANK.
RABBIT SAID. YEAH 10% SO 30% OF
A MILLION IS THREE THOUSAND
RIGHT SO 3% IS THIRTY THOUSAND.
POINT 003% IS THREE THOUSAND.
WHEN YOU AGGREGATE DEBT FOR A
HUNDRED UNITS IF YOU'RE IF
YOU'RE BUILDING EIGHT HUNDRED
UNITS THE ORIGINAL I KNOW THIRTY
THOUSAND THERE'S GOT TO BE SOME
BENEFIT IS AT A RATE OF THE DAY
THE PARKING SPOTS RIGHT NEXT TO
EACH OTHER I CAN'T BE A VERY
CRUDE- HAVE AVERAGE THAT IS IN A
ALSO IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT IF
YOU ARE ALREADY WIRING YOUR
GARAGE ANYWAY. THE CLASSES
ACTUALLY NEGLIGIBLE BECAUSE IN
THE END OF THE DAY ALL WERE
REQUIRING IS ELECTRICAL ACCESS
ENOUGH OUT OF AN OUTLET SO- I
YOU KNOW WE'LL WE'LL GO BACK TO
THAT THE SPONSOR AND- TO GET
MORE CLARITY BUT I GREW THEIR
CENTERPOINT WILL SEE YOU IN
APPROPRIATIONS. YES HOME. I
WOULD SOONER SHOW- SO IT'S
REALLY. WE JUST STAFF WERE JUST
DEBATING IN OUR HOUSE WHAT TYPE
OF VEHICLE TO PURCHASE WE NEEDED
TO PURCHASE A VEHICLE IN OUR
CHILD WAS GOING TO TRY IT AB
BACK AND FORTH TO UTAH IN THE
THOUGHT HE WANTED TO PURCHASE
THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE AND GREAT
SUPPORT OF ELECTRIC VEHICLES I
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THE ABILITY
FOR HER TO BE ABLE TO CHARGE
FEES SO I UNDERSTAND THE MERITS.
OF THE BILL. HOWEVER I DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF CONCERNS WITH REGARDS
TO. MANDATING THAT AB APARTMENT
COMPLEXES HAVE THESE BUILT IN
PRIOR TO THE I RESPECT AND I
AYE. AYE SHE COMMEND THE FACT
THAT IT IS. AB LESS EXPENSIVE TO
PUT IT IN BEFOREHAND AND
AFTERWARDS AB MUCH MUCH LESS SO
I RESPECT THAT THE CONCERNS THAT
I HAVE HAVE TO DO MORE WITH-
THEY WERE FOCUSING ON THE
LECTERN VEHICLES THERE ARE SOME
CONCERNS RIGHT NOW THAT ARE
STARTING TO RISE ON. OUT WE'RE
WE'RE GOING TO DO WITH ALL OF
THESE- BATTERIES AND WHETHER OR
NOT THESE ARE ACTUALLY
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY MEANS
THAT RIGHT NOW IT'S ONE OF THE
BEST WAYS THAT WE KNOW HOW TO-
YOU KNOW. AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO
A- TO IN A LETTER TO- OIL
POWERED VEHICLES BUT- GAS
POWERED VEHICLES. RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE RISING CONCERNS ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO IN THE FUTURE
WITH REGARDS TO THESE BATTERIES
AND WHETHER OR NOT YOU KNOW THIS
WOULD BE AN ENVIRONMENTALLY FOR.
FRIENDLY OPTION IN THE NEAR
FUTURE. SO MY CONCERN. WITH THAT
IS THAT. BY MANDATING- NEW
CONSTRUCTION CALIFORNIA TO
ACCOMMODATE THIS AS AN
ALTERNATIVE- OR IS IT AS A COME
AS A I GUESS A COMMODITY COULD
BE A- WHAT DO YOU CALL IT NO
COMMODITY BUT IF I GO WHAT THE
WORD IS EVASIVE. AND- AND THEN I
MADE EIGHTY AMENITIES AS AN
AMENITY- THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THAT THE STATE MIGHT BE-
UNINTENTIONALLY CREW BEING
INNOVATION AND OTHER
ALTERNATIVE. TO GAS POWERED
VEHICLES- INTO ELECTRIC VEHICLES
FOR THAT MORE- AB. IN ADDITION
TO THAT I'M AND ALSO- YOU KNOW
WE JUST TOWARD- A HYDRANT BUT
FACILITY IN OUR DISTRICT IN MY
TWELVE ACTIONS ON MY DISTRICT MY
BORDERING DISTRICT AND- THERE'S
A LOT GOING ON IN RESEARCH GOING
ON WITH WITH THAT SPACE AS WELL-
WHICH ALSO HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
REVOLUTIONIZE THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR SO. THERE'S A LOT OF
INNOVATION COMING INTO WITH ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES ARE MOVING
FORWARD AND IF THE STATE IS
GOING TO COME AND JUST SAY OKAY
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE GOING WHAT
WE'RE PUTTING A VALUE TO THEY
WERE PRIORITIZING ELECTRIC
VEHICLES INSTEAD OF ALLOWING.
PER SE THE AB. I'M JUST A
CONCERNED ABOUT THE CURBING THE
INNOVATION THAT'S COMING
THROUGH- WITH OTHER MEANS OF
TRANSPORTATION ASIDE FROM FROM
ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND FROM WHAT
I UNDERSTAND THERE'S ALSO
CONCERN ON WHETHER OR NOT OUR
GRID WILL BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THIS INCREASE IN ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING STATIONS AND
HOW THAT WILL AFFECT OTHER
CUSTOMERS ON THE AGING
ELECTRICAL GRID- IS THERE IS.
INTERPLAY ON THAT BIGGEST AT. ON
THAT END AND- AND- AND I THINK
WE SHOULD BE WE SHOULD BE DOING
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN TO
INCREASE INNOVATION IN ALL
ALTERNATIVE SECTORS OF
TRANSPORTATION AND JUST THIS
SORT OF FOCUSING ON ELECTRIC
VEHICLES BECAUSE THEY ARE THERE
ARE CONCERNS THAT ARE STARTING
TO RISE AND MANY MANY PEOPLE TRY
TO DISCUSS THAT AND IS A
PERMANENT OF LOCAL CONTROL- I
BELIEVE THAT EACH MULTI FAMILY
COMPLEX OWNER AB SHOULD EVALUATE
THE NEEDS OF THOSE COMMUNITIES I
WHICH YOU MIGHT NOT INCLUDE-
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
STATIONS- AND ANY MEASURE THAT
POTENTIALLY INCREASES THE COST
OF HOUSING IS CONCERNING TO ME.
SPECIALS IS WE'RE IN THE MIDST
OF A SIGNIFICANT HOUSING CRISIS
SO- I CAN'T SUPPORT THIS BILL
BUT I REALLY DO COMMEND THE
MERIT OF TRYING TO INCREASE MORE
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY-
OPTIONS FOR PEOPLE AND- YOU
KNOW. IT IS FIRST I JUST WANT TO
LET YOU KNOW. I WE HAD CONCERNS
ABOUT BUYING AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE
BECAUSE OF THE INABILITY FOR MY
DAUGHTER TO BE ABLE TO CHARGE
THE STATION SO I GET THAT THAT
PORTION FOR IT AS WELL. BUT I
AM. BUT I AM OVERALL CONCERNED
ABOUT THE STATE COMING IN IS
SAYING THIS IS WHAT WE WANNA
ENCOURAGE BECAUSE IT MAY
UNINTENTIONALLY CURB INNOVATION
IN OTHER AREAS. ON THAT SEVEN.
YEAH I KNOW THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE
TOUCHING UPON SOME OF THE BIG
DEBATES THAT ARE HAPPENING IT A.
R. B. AND R. CLIMATE WORKING
GROUP AND WE'VE BEEN HAVING ALL
THESE DISCUSSIONS I KNOW
ACTUALLY IN PREPARATION FOR
THIS- LINDA. HUTCHINS I WAS ONE
WITNESSES OUT AN INTERESTING
ANALOGY ON THIS ISSUE I ASSUME.
THAT THAT. WE DID YOU WANT TO.
DO IT IF YOU WANT TO SPEAK TO
THE SENATE QUESTION. YEAH JUST A
BRIEF. THANK YOU SENATOR RIDLEY
PLEASE. OKAY BREAK. UP I REALLY
WANTED. TO REALLY GREAT. ABOUT
BY THIS YEAR THE END DATE. I
WANT TO SHARE THE KNOWLEDGE. I
THINK OF REALLY IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND. BACK IN THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES. AND OUR COUNTRY WE HAVE
SUCH A THING CALLED COLDWATER
FLATS. AND THAT MEANS THAT
APARTMENT IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. DID NOT ACTUALLY
HAVE COLD WATER. THE BUILDERS
WANT TO SAVE MONEY. AND THEY
SEEM TO THINK LOWER INCOME
RENTERS COULDN'T AFFORD TO.
DEMAND HOT WATER SO THEY BUILT
THESE BUILDINGS WITH NO. WITH NO
HOT BETTER ACCESS. RESIDENTS HOW
TO BOIL THE WATER ON THE STOVE.
AND IT WASN'T UNTIL THE
GOVERNMENT GOVERNMENT STEPPED IN. AND SAID THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE.
NOT FAIR WE MUST SURE ALL THE OF
YOUR- HAVE HOT WATER. BILL IN
BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO BE A PART
OF COST THE BILL. THAT THAT
BECAME. MANY MANY YEARS CITIES
WERE FOR RESIDENTS TO HAVE TWO
THE WATER ON THE STOVE. THIS AN
EQUIVALENT. WHAT WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO PURCHASE. IT- GAS
POWERED CAR INTERSTATE IN TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE. THEY NEED A PLACE
TO CHARGE ELECTRIC VEHICLES. SO
PLEASE STOP READING THE BUILDING
INDUSTRY TRY TO BILL COLD WATER
FLAT AND WALK OUT LOW INCOME
NEED THE COLOR FROM ACCESS TO BE
CHARGING AT HOME WHERE IT'S THE
MOST AFFORDABLE. IF I COULD.
AGREE THE CAN ABOUT THE CELL ARE
. AND NOT WANTING TO- MAYBE
PRIOR ONE OVER THE OTHER I JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT. FOR
THREE REASONS BATTERY POWERED
ELECTRIC VEHICLES ARE MUCH
BETTER THAN FUEL CELL VEHICLES.
NUMBER ONE THEY'RE EXTREMELY
MORE EFFICIENT. SO THEY ARE MUCH
MORE AFFORDABLE FOR EXTRA
DRIVERS. AND THEY ARE MUCH LESS
EXPENSIVE TO CHARGE DID YOU KNOW
THAT IT TAKES ONE TO TWO MILLION
DOLLARS TO INSTALL A HYDROGEN
FUEL PUMP. THAT IS A HUGE AMOUNT
COMPARED TO THE COST OF THE
PHONE WHICH- THANK YOU THANK YOU
VEHICLE PARKING. I WOULD AFFECT
THEIR THANK YOU THANK YOU. OKAY
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
COLLEAGUES. OKAY TERRIFIC
DELIVER I'M SORRY TO SOMEONE
MOVE THE BILL I CAN'T REMEMBER.
OUR MOTION BY CENTER BY CAL SKI-
CENTER ON THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I WHICH IS
CALLED PASSED LONG TIME AGO- IT
IS. IT'S LIKE A TEACHER CAUSES
ALL PSYCHIC PAIN EVERY TIME AN
APARTMENT BUILDING OR CONDO
BUILDING GETS BUILT AND THEN.
PEOPLE CAN'T CHARGE MTV AND EVEN
ALREADY DOES EVERYTHING YEAH HI-
EVEN THOUGH- YOU KNOW WE NEED
TO. AGGRESSIVELY INVEST IN
TRANSIT- BUT WE KNOW THAT IN
TERMS OF CLIMATE THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING ONE OF THOSE
FOUR THINGS WE CAN DO IS TO HAVE
A LOT OF DENSITY NEAR TRANSIT
AND JOBS- HAVING A MORE
SUSTAINABLE VEHICLE FLEET IS
DEFINITELY PART OF THE- SOLUTION
AND- IT'S JUST. IF WE REALLY
REALLY REALLY MEAN IT WHEN WE
SAY THAT WE WANT TO ELECTRIFY
RIGHT. TRANSPORTATION PLEA. YOU
HAVE TO GIVE PEOPLE THE OPTION
OF ACTUALLY DOING THAT AND I
WILL SAY THAT YOU'RE FOR ME
WHERE I LIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO
WHERE I LIVE IN IN SACRAMENTO I
HAVE. NO ABILITY- TO CHARGE- IS
AB AND SO WE'RE TELLING PEOPLE
TO DO SOMETHING THAT ONE DO
SOMETHING RIVER GIVING
SUBSIDIES. AND THEY CAN'T.
CHARGE AND THEY HAVE TO STRUGGLE
TO DO THAT IS THERE ANYONE THERE
WHITE PEOPLE ARE HESITANT TO DO
THAT IN THE UPTAKE OF BEEN. ON
NOT NEARLY WHAT WE WANT SO THIS
IS IMPORTANT AND I SUPPORT THE
BILL AND I'M RECOMMENDING AN AYE
VOTE- WE HAVE A MOTION AND YOU
MAY CLOSE YEAH I THINK YOU. WE
ARE WORKING HARD TO ALSO MAKE
SURE WE REALLY MINIMIZE THE
COMPLEXITY FOR BILL FOR- FOR
APARTMENT OWNERS AS WELL. AS
THAT NEGOTIATION CONTINUES BUT-
YOU CAN I CAN SET BETTER- MISTER
CHAIR. MISTER FRESHMAN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I WILL CALL THE
ROLL. THE SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO BY SENATOR ALAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION SENATOR WIENER
AYE WIENER HI BATES. CABALLERO
SENATOR KABIR. SENATOR CORTEZ
CORTEZ HE AYE MCGUIRE BY REQUIRE
I WOULD CHAU BOOK NO BUT CHAU
BOOK NOW SKINNER. FIVE SKINNER I
AM BURKE CASKEY BY THE CASKEY I
FIVE TWO ONE. OKAY THAT IS FIVE
TO ONE I BELIEVE COULD CENTER ON
BERGEN CENTER BETWEEN APPEARS
ABOUT ALL THE VOTES THIRTY FIVE
FIVE TWO ONE THAT BILL IS OUT-
OKAY THAT WAS OUR FINAL BILL
THANK EVERYONE WE'RE NOW GOING
TO GO BACK AND- LIFT THE CALLS
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS- WE'LL START
WITH ITEM. NUMBER ONE SB FORTY
SEVEN- WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. THIS IS SENATE
BILL EIGHT FORTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR HER TADO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE HI I'M BURKE. IT IS ONE
EIGHT ZERO OKAY NUMBER IS EIGHT
ZERO NOT BILLS OUT- WILL NO GOOD
ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B. 869% OR
LEYVA PLEASE ARE CALLED ABSENT
MEMBERS CABALLERO. BOMGAR
MCGUIRE AYE BUT CHAU BOOK. THIS
IS NOT EIGHT SIXTY NINE BY
CENTER LEYVA THE MOBILE HOME TO
. ULTRABOOK NOW UMBERG. IT'S
FIVE TWO TWO VOTED FIVE TO TWO
AND THAT BILL IS OUT NEXT IS
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB NINE FORTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR BACKER- PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS SENATOR
BATES. SENATOR CAFIERO CABALLERO
AYE MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE HI I'M
BURKE. SEVEN ZERO THE BILL THAT
BILL IS OUT- NEXUS ADAM FOR SB
NINE SEVENTY ONE BY CENTER
NEWMAN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BATES. CABALLERO
CABALLERO AYE MCGUIRE CHOIR I
UMBERG CASKEY. AT SIX TWO ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT ALL RIGHT NEXT
IS ITEM FIVE S. B. ELEVEN OH
FIVE BY SENATOR HUESO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS SENATOR
BATES. SENATE MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE
HI I'M BURKE. AT SIX TO ONE K.
OUT- ON NET IS ITEM SEVEN SP
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN BY CENTER
HERTZBERG PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. UP YES IT'S CURRENTLY
FORTY ONE. BATES MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
HI SKINNER SKINNER I AM BURKE.
SAID SIX ONE THAT BILL IS OUT I
MEAN AND THEN NEXT IS ITEM
NUMBER NINE SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO SENATOR ALAN. OF THE SYSTEM
I'VE GOT THE TO COVER YOUR-
SORRY THIS IS- EIGHT NINETY
SEVEN WITH HEALTHY. WE ARE THE
I'M I APOLOGIZE OKAY THE VOTER
MICHAEL'S. WE ARE HERE- I
APOLOGIZE WE ALREADY- CENTER
ALLEN'S BILLS ALREADY OUT-
FINALLY ITEM NUMBER NINE SP
EIGHT NINETY SEVEN BY SENATOR
LIKE HOUSEKEEPERS CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS CABALLERO.
MCGUIRE UMBERG IT'S FIVE TO ONE
THAT BILLS OUT. OKAY THAT
COMPLETES OUR AGENDA THANK YOU
SO MUCH EVERYONE- AND THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING IS ADJOURNS.